COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS ENDED HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND BASS COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS
MADE NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS. TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE ARE
HOLDING OUR COMEDIC COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE REMOTELY. TODAY
BOTH OF THE CURRENT MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE ARE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND WE WILL BE
JOINED BY OUR BUDGET CHAIR
NANCY SKINNER WHO IS EN ROUTE.
THOSE PROVIDING TESTIMONY
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS. THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTICAL FEEDBACK. I ASK
THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO AND MUTE.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE
YOU BEGIN SPEAKING. OUR IT
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE. ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE A MINUTE
WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC. TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WE WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
A PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX OH ONE ONE SIX
THREE FIVE. FOR DETAILED
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES DIM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE. AND
OR THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU
MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THAT HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THAT
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AND
ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO IS
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE MORE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED I DON'T
EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN TODAY.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARINGS IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME MANNER AS IS CUSTOMARY
THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES FOR
PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE ADJUSTING
TO THE NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS
OR TECHNOLOGIES. PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT TO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES SO THAT THEY
CAN BE HEARD. IN TODAY'S
HEARING WE WILL REVIEW THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND WORKERS. THE
GOVERNOR HAS PROPOSED FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
GRANT SUPPORT TO SMALL
BUSINESSES IMPACTED BY COVERED
NINETEEN AND THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY RESTRICTIONS. FOR THE
LOW INCOME WORKERS THE GOVERNOR
HAS PROPOSED THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS WHICH CONSISTS OF TWO
POINT FOUR BILLION DOLLARS TO
PROVIDE A SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR
REFUND. TO TAXPAYERS WHO
RECEIVED THE CALIFORNIA EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT FOR THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TAX YEAR. AS
WELL AS INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER FILERS
WHO RECEIVED THE CREDIT FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY TAX YEAR. SMALL
BUSINESSES THROUGHOUT OUR STATE
HAVE BEEN DEVASTATED BY THE
IMPACT OF THE CORONA VIRUS
PANDEMIC. AS THE AGENDA POINTS
OUT AN OVERWHELMING NUMBER OF
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN
PERMANENTLY SHUTTERED AND MORE
THAN 40% A CALIFORNIA'S SMALL
BUSINESSES REPORT REQUIRING
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE OR
ADDITIONAL CAPITAL IN THE
MONTHS AHEAD. THE PANDEMIC HAS
ALSO DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED LOW WAGE WARNER
EARNERS. MANY LOW WAGE WORKERS
WERE EMPLOYED IN THE VERY
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE BEEN HIT
THE HARDEST. ADDITIONALLY
WORKERS THAT FILE THEIR TAXES
WITH INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUT OF A MAJORITY OF
THE FEDERAL ASSISTANCE THAT HAS
BEEN PROVIDED TO DATE. THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE EFFORTS TO
IMMEDIATELY PROVIDE RELIEF TO
SMALL BUSINESSES AND LOW WAGE
WORKERS ARE SORELY NEEDED AND
MUCH APPRECIATED. THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO ACT
QUICKLY TO ENSURE WE DO OUR
PART TO GET RELIEF TO
BUSINESSES AND WORKERS MOST IN
NEED. TODAY'S INFORMATIONAL
HEARING IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR THE DETAILS OF WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING AND TO
HEAR FROM STAKEHOLDERS AND
CONSTITUENTS SO THAT WE CAN
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE DOES ACT. WE'RE
DOING SO IN A MANNER THAT
MAXIMIZES THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THIS CRITICAL STATE SUPPORT. WE
WANT TO THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR
ROLLING OUT THE SMALL BUSINESS
GRANT PROGRAM PHASE ONE ABOUT A
MONTH AGO. WHICH GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ASK QUESTIONS IN
REAL TIME ABOUT LESSONS LEARNED
AND GOALS AND METRICS SO WE CAN
BE. PREPARED FOR FACE TO. ADD
MORE RESOURCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES. AS I INDICATED
TO YOU PREVIOUSLY WE WILL TAKE
NO VOTES TODAY THIS IS ONLY AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON THESE
TWO PROPOSALS. BEFORE WE BEGIN
I'D LIKE TO ASK CENTER NIELSEN
IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE A
STATEMENT. IF I MAY BE OUT OF
HERE YES. AS WE COMMENCE THE
DELIBERATIONS ON THIS BUDGET.
THERE'S AN OBSERVATION IN
GENERAL THAT I MUST MAKE. THERE
SEEMS TO BE A TREND OF
ADMINISTRATIONS PEARLS AND
PARTICULARLY THIS ONE. TO
SUBMIT TO THE LEGISLATURE BOLD
IDEAS. UNDEFINED. AND THE
ADMONISHMENT TO THE LEGISLATORS
AS WELL TRUST US WE'LL WORK IT
ALL OUT. WILL HANDLE THE
DETAILS JUST AUTHORIZED THE
EXPENDITURES. ALMOST A BLANK
CHECK AS FACT WHAT THEY'RE
ASKING. AND THAT REALLY DOESN'T
WORK ANYMORE FOR THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OBVIOUSLY THE TRAVESTY THAT'S
OCCURRING IN GOVERNMENT RIGHT
NOW. OUR IN PART THE RESULT OF
THE LEGISLATURE NOT INSISTING
ON SUCH MEASURES GOVERNING THE
BUDGETS AND THE ORGANIZATION
AND OPERATION OF THE AGENCIES
OF STATE GOVERNMENT. IT IS TIME
FOR US TO THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE TO REST THAT
AUTHORITY BACK INTO THE HANDS
OF THE ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES.
WE WILL HAVE TO BE HAPPILY WORK
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO FILL
IN THE BLANKS BUT I'M NOT
SUPPORTING ANYMORE THESE BIG
NEW ORGANIZATIONS. OR IF YOU
WILL NEW AGENCIES BEING CREATED.
WITHOUT ANY INSISTENCE ON THE
LIBERALS AND THE ACCOUNTABILITY
AND TRANSPARENCY AND THEY'RE
JUST SIMPLY IS NO TRUST THAT
THE AGENCIES WILL GET IT RIGHT
BECAUSE CLEARLY THEY HAVE IT SO
IT'S OUR JOB AS MEMBERS OF THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE THE VERY FIRST.
IN OVERSEEING AND THEN RIDING
INTO THE TRAILER BILL IS VERY
SPECIFIC MEASURABLES AND
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK
YOU SENATOR NIELSEN. WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH OUR FIRST.
PANEL SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF
GRANTS I'D LIKETO INVITE FROM
G. DIMITRA CHIEF OF ECONOMIC
RESEARCH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WELCOME THANK YOU- I
WOULD DEFER TO MY CLIENT AS MY
COLLEAGUE ABOUT THIS MONTH I'M
GO BASE TO START THIS
DISCUSSION. VERY GOOD. IDEAS
ABOUT BOOTHS MINE THE DIRECTOR
OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF THE
SMALL BUSINESS ADVOCATE WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR AND
THANK YOU ALL FOR. GIVING ME
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON
THIS PROGRAM IT'S BEEN- BUT IF
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE AS
WELL AS REPRESENT HELLO S. B.
A. THE CALIFORNIA OFFICES SMALL
BUSINESS ADVOCATING GO BASED ON
THIS REQUEST OF THE GOVERNOR'S
ADDS FOR ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA RELIEF GRANT. AT
AS YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN
DEPLOYING THE INITIAL FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
AND REQUEST AN ADDITIONAL FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION FOR GRANTS FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES BOTH FOR PROFIT FOUR
POINT ONE MILLIONSTRONG IN THE
STATE- AND NONPROFITS
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FORTY THOUSAND STRONG IN THE
STATE. 'M ALL IMPACTED BY CODE
NINETEEN I KNOW SENATORS ARE
YOU PROBABLY HAVE WITNESSED IN
YOUR OWN DISTRICTS THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY KOBE NINETEEN
ESPECIALLY THOSE DIRECTLY
AFFECTED BY THE RESULTING
HEALTH GUIDANCE AND CLOSURES-
AS WELL AS THE CHANGING
MARKETPLACE AND CONSUMER
DEMANDS- STUDIES HAVE
CONSISTENTLY ESTIMATED YOU KNOW
THIRD CLASS OF OUR BUSINESSES
ARE AT RISK OF CLOSURE. HIGHER
FOR BIG PEOPLE OF COLOR I WITH
THE RECENT STUDY BY SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY WHO I KNOW
YOU'RE HEARING FROM LATER TODAY
ESTIMATING 41% OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN FIRMS ARE AT RISK OF
CLOSURE- YET OUR ECONOMY IS
LARGELY DEPENDENT. ON THE SMALL
BUSINESSES WHO EMPLOY NEARLY
HALF OF OUR WORKFORCE AND
CREATE TWO THIRDS OF OUR NET
NEW JOBS- SO GOING INTO THIS
PANDEMIC THEY WERE ALREADY
FACING LOW CASH FLOW LEVELS IT
WAS ESTIMATED BY J. P. MORGAN
CHASE THAT NEARLY HALF HAD ONLY
TWO WEEKS OF CASH FLOW.
PANDEMIC A SO CLEARLY ARE ARE
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO ARE ARE
THE BACKBONE OF OUR ECONOMY IS
AS WE SAY OUR OUR I NEED OF OUR
SUPPORT DURING THIS TIME OF AT
NINETEEN SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
BEEN ADAPTING AND PIVOTING YOU
SEEN IN YOUR COMMUNITIES REALLY
CREATIVELY ATTEMPTING TO MANAGE
AND DISASTER FOR TEN MONTHS.
EXPERIENCING DROPS IN REVENUES
RISING DEBTS- AN UNCERTAIN
FUTURE MARKET PLACES AS WELL
THAT'S A ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THAT
THE THROUGH THIS ALL THAT
THEY'VE WANTED GRANTS. NOT
LOANS TO CARRY THE THROUGH THE
PENNED. AND THE SECOND CRISIS-
MY- IN HIS. ADMINISTERING
CALIFORNIA RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM
STRUCTURE BASED ON STUDIES OF
NATIONAL AND LOCAL BEST
PRACTICES THERE HAVE BEEN
NUMEROUS GRANT PROGRAMS
DEPLOYED ACROSS THE NATION-
THAT WE HAVE BEEN TRACKING-
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS MANY IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL- AND WE-
LEARNED FROM THOSE NETWORKS.
LESSONS LEARNED AS WELL AS-
INFORMED OUR PROGRAM DESIGN
BASED ON ON THOSE KEY BEST
PRACTICES- WE AS WELL WORKED
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON THAT
INITIAL PROGRAM DESIGN WITH
PRIORITIES AROUND. BALANCING
SIMPLICITY AND EASE OF USE WITH
OVERSIGHT AND CONTROLS TO
MITIGATE ANY FRAUD OR AND
CHALLENGES IN THE SYSTEM- AS
WELL EMPHASIZING SPEED GETTING
THESE GRANTS ON THE GROUND AS
SOON AS POSSIBLE. I'M QUICKLY
SCALING ACROSS THE STATE TO
ENSURE THAT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES WOULD HAVE THE FUNDS
NECESSARY TO SURVIVE AND- AND
SERVE AS A BRIDGE UNTIL
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL RELIEF FOR
OTHER PROGRAMS COULD BE AND PUT
INTO PLACE. I WE HAVE BEEN
PRIORITIZING. THROUGH THIS
PROGRAM THE MOST IMPACTED
BUSINESSES LOOKING AT
GEOGRAPHIC IMPACT OF THE CODE
NINETEEN GUIDANCE AS WELL AS
INDUSTRY AND- A HISTORICALLY
UNDERSERVED STATUS OUR MOST
VULNERABLE BUSINESSES IN OUR
STATE. AS THE DATA HAVE SHOWN
THAT THEY'RE AT. RISK IN
ADDITION TO THAT THE PROGRAM
DOES I WAS FOCUSED ON
LEVERAGING THE EXISTING STATE
RESOURCES- OUR BOOTS ON THE
GROUND TO THE CALIFORNIA
NETWORK OF SMALL BUSINESS
CENTERS- AS WELL AS FRANKLY THE
LEGISLATIVE OFFICES ALL CENTERS
OF INFORMATION. AND RESOURCE TO
SMALL BUSINESSES. WE KNOW THAT
CONNECTION TO RESOURCES IS A
HUGE CHALLENGE PRE PANDEMIC
ENTERING PANDEMIC. AND WANTED
TO ENSURE THAT WE REALLY WERE
ABLE TO PARTNER IN THIS PROCESS
WITH A NETWORK OF STRONG
PARTNERS TO STRENGTHEN THE
ECOSYSTEM LONG TERM AND LOOK TO
OUR RECOVERY AS WELL. AND SO
THAT SMALL BUSINESSES COULD BE
CONNECTED TO PARTNERS ON THE
GROUND FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
BEYOND THE GRANT PROGRAM
ITSELF- WE AT YEAR END AND
FINALLY JUST THAT THE PROBE.
WOULD NOT BE FIRST COME FIRST.
MOST OF THESE PROGRAMS HAVE
BEEN AYE IT'S CREATED A LOT OF
CHALLENGES FOR THE SMALLEST OF
SMALLER THE MOST AT RISK TO BE
ABLE TO GET INTO THE PROGRAM IN
TIME. AND SO IMPORTANTLY THIS
WAS AND NOT TO BE A FIRST COME
FIRST SERVE BASIS PROGRAM. AT
NOR ROLLING BASIS AT LEAD
L'INDUSTRIE AS AN INTERMEDIARY
THAT WAS AWARDED BY A
COMPETITIVE BID PROCESS- TO
HELP ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM. A
SELECTION COMMITTEE WAS WAS
THAT DEPLOYED TO- SELECT
COMPETITIVELY ONE OF THE
FINALISTS FOR THE INTERMEDIARY.
POSITION L'INDUSTRIE IS A CDFI-
ALSO RAN OTHER GRANT PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE NATION- THERE WERE
ONE OF THE LARGEST C. DIFF
ISLANDERS IN SOME OF THE KEY
FEDERAL PROGRAMS. AND SO HAS A
HISTORY AND A PERFORMANCE
HISTORY THAT WE- ARE PROUD TO
PARTNER WITH AS WELL AS THEIR
COMMITMENTS TO MISSION IS A
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT FINANCIAL.
INSTITUTION CDFI. COMMITTED TO
HELP UNDERSTOOD SMALL
BUSINESSES. WE WE AS WELL WE'RE
PLEASED TO PARTNER WITH FIVE
HUNDRED DIRECT AND INDIRECT
PARTNERS ON THE GROUND- IN SO
IN ADDITION TO OUR SMALL
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT CENTER
NETWORKS ARE WOMEN'S BUSINESS
IN A NETWORK THAT IS FUNDED
ALREADY BY THE STATE TO- DEPLOY
RESOURCES AND COMMUNITY- WE
WENT BEYOND THAT TO OTHER C. D.
F. I.'S OTHER NONPROFIT BASED
ON ORGANIZATIONS CHAMBERS
EXCEPT REST OF THAT WE CAN GET
TO AS MANY BUSINESSES ON THE
GROUND SCALE QUICKLY.
EFFICIENTLY THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. ANOTHER ADDED BENEFIT OF
COURSE OF WORKING WITH THE CDFI
SAID THEY HAVE THAT YOU KNOW
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONAL- GET A
CAPACITY TO ENSURE THAT WE WERE
IMPLEMENTING CONTROLS-
INCLUDING YOU KNOW BEING ABLE
TO VERIFY TAX RETURNS DO
BACKGROUND CHECKS WITH CLEAR
AND SECRETARY OF STATE- YOU DO
THAT THAT YOU KNOW VERIFY YOUR
BANK ACCOUNTS AND DO CREDIT
CHECKS OF THOSE THOSE THINGS
WERE IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT
THE FUNDS WERE ACTUALLY GETTING
TO THE BUSINESSES THAT WE WERE
HOPING. TO SERVE BASED ON ALL
OF THESE PRIORITIES AND FOCUSES
OF THIS PROGRAM- AND THE
STRENGTH OF OUR INTERMEDIARY
PARTNERS WE HAVE SEEN SUCCESSES
IN ROUND ONE OF THE PROGRAM
TODAY I KNOW THAT THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL REALLY
HELP US BETTER MEET THIS HUGE
I'M NOT AND YOU DEMAND THAT
WE'RE SEEING ON THE GROUND- AS
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE ANNOUNCES PROGRAM
IN NOVEMBER THIRTIETH WE OPEN
THE GRANT PORTAL AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BY DECEMBER THIRTIETH-
APPLICATIONS FOR ROUND ONE
OPENED. I AND HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED TO HELPING AS MANY AS
POSSIBLE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
THROUGH THE SYSTEM OVER THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
APPLICATIONS WERE RECEIVED- IN
LARGE PART THANKS TO THIS
NETWORK I REFERENCED OF
PARTNERS THEIR DAILY WEBINARS
IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES OVER A
HUNDRED WEAPONIZED TO DATE IN
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
BUSINESSES TRYING TO DATE BASED
ON ROUND ONE WE CAN SEE THAT
THE MONEY IS ACTUALLY GETTING
INTO THE HANDS OF IMPACTED
BUSINESSES ACROSS THE STATE.
OVER THREE QUARTERS OF THE
GRANTS AWARDED TO DATE HAVE
GONE TO DISADVANTAGED OR
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES TWO
THIRDS TO HIGHLY IMPACTED.
INDUSTRIES AND WE HAVE SEEN
EQUITY ACROSS THE STATE. OF
COURSE ALL OF THE STATE BEING
AND A STATE HOME ORDER THE TIME.
SO WHILE WE HAVE SEEN THESE
SUCCESSES- YOU KNOW ALL THOSE
ENGAGED HAVE CONTINUALLY MADE
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE PROCESS AND
WILL CONTINUE IN THAT SPIRIT.
OF ITERATION AS WE WALK INTO
ROUND TWO WHICH WILL OPEN ON
FEBRUARY SECOND. THE DISPLAY
THE REMAINING HALF OF THE
INITIAL A FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM- SOME EXAMPLES OF THAT
IN AND WANT TO SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT MORE TO- THE BROWN ONE
PROCESS AND HOW IT'S GONE- ON
TECHNOLOGY IMPORTANTLY REMEMBER
THAT THIS IS NOT FIRST COME
FIRST SERVE. A LOT OF PROGRAMS
HIT A CERTAIN NUMBER AND SHUT
DOWN- OR- YOU KNOW OR JUST
LIMITED BECAUSE OF CAPACITY. SO
WE KEPT THIS OPEN NO MATTER
WHAT SO THAT BUSINESSES FELT
THAT THEY HAD A FAIR SHOT TO
ACCESS THE FUNDS- AND DEBT AND
ABOUT BECAUSE OF THAT- DAY ONE
WITH THAT MASSIVE DEMAND THAT
WE HAD WE HAD OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND SUCCESSFUL APPLICANTS
GO THROUGH ON DAY ONE ALONE-
AND HAPPIER TENS OF THOUSANDS
TRY TO WALK IN THE FRONT DOOR
AT THE SAME TIME- WE ACTUALLY.
SPLIT THE SYSTEM INTO-
PROCESSES ONE APPLYING TO GET
EVERYBODY IN THE FRONT DOOR TO
UPLOADING DOCUMENTS TO THEN
ALLOW FOR. OF FOLKS TO COME
BACK AND REVISIT THEIR
APPLICATION IN THE FUTURE- YOU
KNOW WHILE THIS CREATED SOME.
CHALLENGES IN TERMS OF USE OUR
PARTNERS ON THE GROUND WERE
ABLE TO WALK FOLKS THROUGH- THE
PROCESS AND STILL GET THESE
GREAT RESULTS- WE KNOW WE'VE
SEEN ON OUR REGION MARKETING
THAT OUR PARTNERS HAVE
DEVELOPED A THE WEAPON OURS AS
I MENTIONED- PROMOTED
EXTENSIVELY ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
EXTENSIVE EARNED MEDIA AND
OFFERED MULTIPLE LANGUAGES- BUT
WE'VE CONTINUALLY ADDED MORE
VIDEOS AS WE'VE GONE ALONG. AND
WE FEEL STRONG IN ROUND TWO
THAT WILL HAVE THE CAN IN
ADDITIONAL- TRANSLATED
DOCUMENT. EXCUSE ME TRANSLATED
DOCUMENTS TO HELP OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES ACCESS THIS PROGRAM-
WE'VE SEEN L'INDUSTRIE RESPONDS
THROUGHOUT THIS BY ADOPTING-
INCREASING THEIR CAPACITY THE-
EXPANDING THEIR CALL CENTER
SERVICES. WHEN HIT. MASSIVE-
OVERLOAD OF THIS IS. AND- WE'RE
PLEASE. WITH WITH THE RESULTS
SHOWING ALL THOSE DELIBERATE
ITERATIVE ITERATIVE CHANGES
THAT WE'VE MADE THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THIS PROGRAM- AS
I'VE SAID THE DEMAND WAS HUGE
OVER THREE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND APPLICATIONS. RECEIVED
YOU KNOW AND WHILE THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL HELP US
NEEDS SOME OF THAT DEMAND OF
COURSE YOU KNOW WE CANNOT MEET
ALSO IMPORTANTLY. WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE REACHING THE
MOST IMPACTED BUSINESSES AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO- WE'VE
REVIEWED THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE IS REPORT. AND
HAPPY TO IN IN NOW JUST. DEFER
THE TIME TO ANSWERING SOME OF
THOSE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS. AS WE
DIVE INTO THE PROGRAM IN THE
FUTURE USE OF THOSE FUNDS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON. BY THE
MAKE A PRESENTATION ARE YOU
JUST HERE FOR TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
WE'RE JUST HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS THANK YOU SENATOR ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ONE
WILL MOVE ON TO- BRAND WHETHER
FOR THE SENIOR FISCAL AND
POLICY ANALYST FOR THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
FOR COMMENTS. WELCOME THANK YOU
THIS IS BRIAN WEATHERFORD WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE- WE PREPARED- AS THE
ADMINISTRATION MENTIONED
ANALYSIS OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL IN HAND OUT WITH WITH
INFORMATION IS AVAILABLE ON OUR
ON OUR WEBSITE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AND FOLLOWING ITS AT
ALLINA DOT CA DOT GOV- THERE IS
A LOT OF AKRON IN THE HANDOUT
SAID JUST TURNING TO PAGE SIX.
WE MENTIONED SOME OF THE
CONCERNS ON THIS PAGE THAT WERE
RAISED BY APPLICANTS AND
PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS AND THE
ADMINISTRATION- BEGAN TO
ADDRESSING THESE CONCERNS IN
THE PRESENTATION- WE JUST LIKE
TO NOTE THAT ESTABLISHING A
BRAND NEW PROGRAM OFTEN
INVOLVES ON FIFTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES AND
SO SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT-
WE NOTE AND THAT OTHERS HAVE
NOTED- MIGHT HAVE HAPPENED
UNDER OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES.
HOWEVER SOME STAKEHOLDERS ALSO
FELT THAT BETTER COMMUNICATION
AND NOT REACH FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE THIRD
PARTY VENDOR- WELL THE PROGRAM
IS BEING IMPLEMENTED COULD
ADDRESS SOME OF THE POTENTIAL
ISSUES BEFORE. THE PROGRAM
BEGAN. A TURNING THE PAGE
SEVEN. THE ARMS THE LEGISLATURE
IN CONSIDERING HOW TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL STATE RELIEF TO
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS-
SHOULD- TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE TARGET THESE FUNDS TO
THOSE ENTITIES THAT WERE MOST
WE'D LIKE TO KNOW THE TARGETING
IS IMPORTANT FOR TWO REASONS.
THE FIRST THE GRANDSON LIKELY
TO REACH ALL ELIGIBLE ENTITIES
AS PROGRAMS CURRENTLY DESIGNED-
SO WE ESTIMATE THAT THESE ON
THE FIRST FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS ALLOCATED IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY WILL
PROVIDE FOR BETWEEN THIRTY
THOUSAND AND FIFTY THOUSAND
GRANTS. AND EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM BY FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
WOULD UNDERSTANDABLY ROUGH THE
DOUBLE NUMBER OF GRANTS THAT
CAN BE- AWARDED AND-
NONETHELESS IT SEEMS LIKELY
THAT MANY OF THE ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE A GRANT AS WE ESTIMATE
THERE ROUGHLY- TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACTIVE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND- MOST IMPACTED
INDUSTRIES ALONE IN THE STATE.
AND OBVIOUSLY WITH US SINCE
SINCE WE PREPARE THIS FOR THAT
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPLICANTS APPLY TO THE PROGRAM
ED IN JUST THE FIRST ROUND. IN
ADDITION TARGETING COULD LIMIT
DUPLICATION- THEY'RE TARGETING
TO LIMIT DUPLICATION OF FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS SO. THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS- ARE NOT
AVAILABLE TO ALL BUSINESSES- WE
KNOW BUSINESSES THEN DEFAULTED
ON PREVIOUS SB A LOANS OR THAT
ARE UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS
MAY BE INELIGIBLE FOR. THE
FEDERAL PROGRAMS AND SO THE
STATE COULD TARGET THE MOST AND
IMPACTED IN. INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY NOT BE ELIGIBLE FOR THOSE
PROGRAMS. AS AN EXAMPLE OF
BETTER TARGETING NOW THE
CALIFORNIA RELIEF GRANT PROGRAM
DOES INCLUDE- TARGETING. AND-
THAT SHOULD BE ON UNDERLINE- WE
DO KNOW AT THIS POINT IT'S IN
FACT THIS EFFECTIVENESS AND
CLEAR AS WE HAVEN'T HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REVIEW ANY- OF
THE AGGRESSIVE BEEN AWARDED OR
THE DETAILS OF THE CONTRACT. SO.
IN ADDITION- BECAUSE BECAUSE WE
ARE FAMILIAR WITH EXACTLY HOW
THESE OTHER SPARTANS BEING RUN.
ON BASED ON COMMISSION THAT'S
BEEN PROVIDED TO US TODAY. WE
DO HAVE A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
ABOUT HOW AND WHETHER THE STATE
OR THE THIRD PARTY VENDOR. WILL
VERIFY THE AUTHENTICITY OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS PROVIDED
BY THE APPLICANTS IN PLACE- YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT PROCESS
HE'S BEEN PUT IN PLACE TO
DETECT FRAUD. SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD- WE THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER
PROVIDING ONE TIME FINANCIAL
RELIEF TO CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES
AND NONPROFITS THAT WERE
ADVERSELY AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC PROVIDED THOSE FUNDS
CAN BE APPROPRIATELY TARGETED.
AND WHETHER THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSALS THE BEST WAY TO DO SO
IS NOT YET CLEAR- YOU KNOW THE
INITIAL TIME AND PROCESS FOR
AWARDING THE GRANTS WAS
ARGUABLY JUSTIFIED GIVEN THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
CONTEXT OF THE TIME. ON THE
OTHER HAND WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT RECENTLY MAKING A
SECOND ROUND OF TPG LOANS
AVAILABLE AND- FINANCIALLY FOR
FURTHER ASSISTANCE FORTHCOMING
YOU THINK IT MAY BE PRUDENT FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO DEFER ACTION.
ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
UNTIL THE FOLLOWING STEPS CAN
BE TAKEN. FIRST WE UNDERSTAND
DATA HAS BEEN COLLECTED ON THIS
PROGRAM BUT IT HASN'T BEEN
BROADLY SHARED WITH MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE PUBLIC
AT LARGE SO WE THINK THIS ON
INFORMATION BUT ONLY NEEDS TO
BE MADE- MORE TRANSPARENTLY
AVAILABLE BUT ALSO- EVALUATED-
TO FIND WAYS TO. IMPROVE THE
PROGRAM ALTHOUGH IT IS-
REASSURING TO HEAR THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION SAYS IT'S-
CONTINUALLY MAKING IMPROVEMENTS
BASED ON ON THE DATA BUT
BECAUSE TO BRING IN- PARTNERS
AND- THE LEGISLATURE AND- AT
LEAST A TO SOME EXTENT I GUESS
THAT IS HAPPENING BUT- WE
HAVEN'T REALLY. BEEN INVOLVED
OURSELVES SO-IN ADDITION TO
ADDITIONAL TRANSPARENCY- THE
RESEARCHERS LEGISLATURE
CAREFULLY CONSIDER- OTHER
QUESTIONS THAT WE LIST ON PAGE
NINE OF OUR HAND- SO GIVEN THE
STATE'S MORE LIMITED CAPACITY
FOR- FOR FINANCIAL AND FISCAL
ASSISTANCE- AND- THE LIMITED
ROLE IN GENERAL OTHER WAYS TO
COMPLEMENT AND NOT DUPLICATE
FEDERAL EFFORTS. SECOND OR THE
THIRD PARTY VENDORS PROCESSES
TO ADEQUATELY VERIFY THE
IDENTITY OF APPLICANTS IN THE
ACCURACY OF THE INFORMATION.
ARE THEY ABLE TO- TO DO THAT-
QUICKLY AND ACCURATELY AND
PREVENT PRIVATE. THIRD SHOULD
THE PROGRAM'S DEFINITION OF A
SMALL BUSINESS ACCOUNT FOR THE
DIFFERENCES AMONG. DIFFERENT
SECTORS OR SHOULD CONTINUE TO
APPLY A SINGLE DEFINITION OF.
ARE CURRENTLY IT'S TWO POINT
FIVE MILLION IN ANNUAL REVENUES
AT THE RIGHT DEFINITION AND- TO
BE CONSIDERED MOVING FORWARD. A
FOURTH SHOULD THE GRANT BE
COUNTED AS TAXABLE INCOME SO
WITHOUT ACTION THESE GRANTS
WILL BE COUNTED AS TAX ONE
COMPORT STATE TAX PURPOSES
HOWEVER WE DO UNDERSTAND THE
MINISTRATION IS LOOKING AT.
MAKING THESE AREPUTTING FORTH
LANGUAGE TO MAKE THESE TAX
EXEMPT. AND LASTLY- WE QUESTION
THE NEED FOR A SET ASIDE ONLY
FOR CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
UNDOUBTEDLY MUSEUMS AND OTHER
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS ARE AMONG
THE MOST IMPACTED ENTITIES BUT
AS SUCH. IT SEEMS UNREASONABLE
THEY WOULD NECESSARILY ADDED
THAT THEY WOULD RISE TO THE TOP
AND- PROGRAM WHICH IS. BASED ON
NEED SO IT'S NOT REALLY CLEAR
ON THAT TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IS THE APPROPRIATE
AMOUNT OR- THAT THERE'S A
SPECIFIC NEED FOR A SET ASIDE.
ON AND THAT'S THE END OF MY
PREPARED REMARKS ON HAPPY
TAKING QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- ON THAT
THAT CONCLUDES THE-
PRESENTATION IN REGARDS TO THE-
TO THE PROGRAM I'M GONNA SEE IF
WE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS BEFORE
WE MOVE ON TO THE SECOND PART
OF THIS. PARTICULAR PANEL- AND
I GUESS MY FIRST QUESTION IS-
IS GOING TO BE TO- MISCUES MON
AND- THE INITIAL ROLLOUT OF
THE- THIS GRANT PROGRAM WAS
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
AND THERE IT THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY. FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
REQUESTED CAN YOU CAN YOU TELL
US. HOW YOU ENDED UP. DECIDING
ON THAT NUMBER AND IF THERE'S A
GOAL IN MIND IN TERMS OF HOW
MANY BUSINESSES YOU THOUGHT YOU
COULD. OVER WITH THAT AND- I
MEAN I IS THAT IS THAT THE
RIGHT NUMBER WE REALLY LOOKING
AT SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
MUCH LARGER GIVEN THE NUMBER OF
APPLICATIONS THAT YOU RECEIVED.
YES THE I MEAN NUMBER
APPLICATION APPLICATIONS
RECEIVED AS I SAID THAT I
ACTUALLY COMPLETED- ELIGIBLE
APPLICATIONS AT THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND- IT
OVER FOR. A BILLION IN DEMAND
B. B. S. YOU KNOW WE LOOKED AT
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WERE ROLLED
OUT THE LARGEST PROGRAMS IN THE
NATION TO PENNSYLVANIA- AS WELL
AS- LOS ANGELES COUNTY- AND
THAT YOUR ESTIMATED. THAT THE
DEMANDS OF CALIFORNIA WE KNOW
THAT WE COULD NOT FILL IT
COMPLETELY BUT WE'RE HOPING TO
BRIDGE. UNTIL ADDITIONAL FUNDS
COULD BE MADE AVAILABLE AND
FEDERAL LEVEL- I WILL KNOW
THAT. YOU'RE REGARDLESS TEN
MONTHS OF HAVING TO DEAL WITH
THAT YOU KNOW THIS THIS
PANDEMIC. EVEN IF EVEN IF THE
BUSINESSES RECEIVED ANOTHER
GRANT R. P. G. P. OR I'D ALL IT
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN ENOUGH. TO
SUSTAIN THEM FOR THOSE TEN
MONTHS AND SO- YOU KNOW WITH
ALL THOSE THINGS WERE TAKEN
INTO CONSIDERATION AS WELL AS-
YOU KNOW SOME CHALLENGES IN
BEING ABLE TO ACCESS- AND GET
FORGIVENESS ON SME OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS- IN THAT. THIS
IS WHAT THE STATE'S CAPACITY
COULD HANDLE OF COURSE THERE'S
NO- THE NUMBERS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES. FURTHER WITH THE
NUMBERS ARE. ARE NOT BASED ON
THE NUMBER OF SMALL BUSINESSES
OR A PROJECTION IT WAS IT'S
REALLY AN OPPORTUNITY TO GET
SOME RESOURCES I GUESS I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT- WON'T IT
IT THE IN TOTAL IT'S A LITTLE
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS AND I'M
I'M TRYING TO GET A SENSE OF. A
BILLION TWO BILLION THREE
BILLION IS THE APPROPRIATE
NUMBER NUMBER ONE AND NUMBER
TWO IS WHEN YOU GO OUT WITH THE
GRANT PROGRAM YOU GO OUT WITH
YOU YOU SET UP EXPECTATIONS AND
I'M WONDERING IF- IF YOU KNOW
WE TOOK THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
IN TERMS OF THEIR OF THE
NUMBERS THAT WE'RE PROPOSING.
AND I GUESS WHAT I REALLY WANT
TO DO IS TO SAY HOW DO WE GET
IT RIGHT SIZED- GIVEN. ALL THE
OTHER OBLIGATIONS THAT WE HAVE
HERE AT THE STATE. AND THE
DEMANDS ON THE MONEY WHICH WE
KNOW IT'S GOING TO BE AN
INTENSE. BUT I I'M I. I GUESS
WHAT IWANT TO OF AVOID. IS WE
KNEW THAT THE MONEY THAT WE PUT
OUT FOR UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS IS
GOING TO BE INSUFFICIENT- AND
SO IT SETS UP EXPECTATIONS AND
THEN 10% OF THE POPULATION GETS
A CHECK IN THE RESTAURANT AND
I'M TRYING TO AVOID. TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW DO WE MAKE THAT.
CALCULATION GIVEN WHERE WE'RE
AT RIGHT NOW AND MOVING THIS
PROGRAM FORWARD. YES I MEAN WE
KNEW THAT THAT WOULD BE
INSUFFICIENT. AS DEMONSTRATED
BY THE DEMAND EVEN AND RON WENT
ALONG AND SO. THEY'RE FOUR
POINT ONE BUSINESSES IF YOU HAD
IN THE NUMBER. WHICH ARE
ALLEGED FIVE WILL C. THREES AND
SEE SIX IS A BETTER. THERE ARE
AND YOU KNOW AT LEAST FORTY. SO
CLEARLY THIS IS AN AND OF THOSE
OF COURSE REAL. AT TO FIVE AND-
AN HIGHLY IN- THIS WAS NO
ENOUGH. TO MEET. BUT IT WAS A
HOPE TRY TO STAY. MANY INTEND
UP TO. OF THE DEMAND- IF HE'S A-
FUNDS ARE PRETTY. AND I KNOW I
DON'T KNOW IF. WANTS TO ADD AN-
FURTHER SUBJECT- SO THAT'S A
GOOD. I THINK. YOU KNOW- I'M-
WE KNOW THE DEMAND IS GREAT.
AND YOU KNOW THE RACE. AREN'T
LIMITED FROM WE CAN- SO IT'S
YOU KNOW WITH WE DON'T KNOW HOW
MUCH OUT THE PROPOSED FUNDING
IS. AND IT'S JUST THE WAY POINT
FOR BILLION SPECIFIC TO SPOT.
JUST SHOWS THE ADMIN- COME. TO
UP THE EFFECT. BUSINESSES AS
THEY GO THROUGH THIS TIME. TIME
AND SO MUCH OF WE ARE PER. IS
TO IT IMMEDIATELY ABOUT. TO GET
THAT IMMEDIATE HELP. TO
BUSINESS TO SET. THEM AND THEY-
THIS IS ALSO GOING TO BE IN
ADDITION TO THE ADDITIONAL UP.
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. THAT BRIAN
MENTIONED AND THAT WAS APPROVED
ACTUALLY IN LATE DECEMBER. AB
PROVIDES. A NATIONWIDE THREE
NINE TEN BILL DOLLARS FOR THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM.
FIFTEEN MILLION FOR THE LIVE
VENUES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO. OPEN AT ALL. AND I'M
FIFTEEN BILLION FOR UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES OF THIS IS JUST-
OUR ATTEMPT TO. TRY TO BRIDGE
GAP A LITTLE BIT BETWEEN THE
NEED AND WHAT WE CAN ACTUALLY.
PROVIDE AND NOW THAT I HAVE. ON
THE AS WELL IT TO JUST. THAT
THE FEDERAL. WILL CAN. TO
PROVIDE- FEDERAL RESERVE. IN
AREA AND ARE. CAN COME UP
ALONGSIDE IN MAY FELT IN THE
NEED. THAT ARE NOT MET THROUGH
THE FEDERAL PROGRAM IS THAT IT
LEAST IT. CONTEMPLATED IN THIS.
YES THAT'S PART OF IT YES WE
ARE HOPING TO- WORK M.
ALONGSIDE THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION. I'M TO PROVIDE
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE. THE PEOPLE
AND EFFECTIVE BUSINESS. ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M
ALSO- IT IN IN YOUR STATEMENT-
MISCUES MON YOU INDICATED THAT-
THAT THE FIRST GRANTS THAT ARE
BEING ROLLED OUT. SATISFY THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THE PROPOSAL
FOR GEOGRAPHIC INDUSTRY AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES CAN YOU
GIVE US. YOU HAVE A LITTLE BIT
MORE DATA ON THAT OR IS THAT
SOMETHING YOU CAN PROVIDE AYE
AYE. AM I AM- VERY SENSITIVE TO
THE G. A. DISTRIBUTE- THIS
WASN'T YOUR PROGRAM BUT QUITE
FRANKLY THE MONEY THAT WENT OUT
TO COUNTIES- TONY SINCE.
INDICATE THAT THE WE DO AS PART
OF THAT- CARE ACT DISTRIBUTION
INDICATED THAT MANY OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT
WE'RE SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANTLY
SHORT CHANGED IN TERMS OF THE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS AND SINCE
I AT MY DISTRICT IS MOSTLY
RURAL- IT DID THAT THERE IS A
SENSE AND A FEELING THAT- RURAL
COMMUNITIES ALWAYS END UP.
GETTING THE SHORT END OF THE
STICK WHEN IT COMES TO FINANCES
AND THAT FLOWS THROUGH THE
STATE AND SO- CAN YOU GIVE US
SOME INFORMATION ON THE
GEOGRAPHIC- DISTRIBUTION AS
WELL AS THE INDUSTRY'S- THAT
HAVE BEEN I. AND IN TERMS OF
THAT BUT UNDERSERVED I WAS THE
IMPRESSED BY THE NUMBERS THAT
YOU CITED- AND I LOOKING AT MY
NOTES THAT IT THREE QUARTERS OF
THE- OF THE GRANTS WENT TO
DISADVANTAGED- SMALL BUSINESSES
AND TWO THIRDS TO THE HIGHLY
IMPACTED INDUSTRIES AND IF YOU
COULD TALK A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT THOSE. THOSE TWO ISSUES
THAT WOULD BE THAT WOULD BE
REALLY GREAT ACTUALLY A THREE
ISSUES. YES OF COURSE SENATOR
AND WE ARE PRIORITIZE THOSE
IMPACTED AREAS- AND L'INDUSTRIE
OUR INTERMEDIARY HAS HAD STRONG
PERFORMANCE AND IN THOSE AREAS
IN THE PAST AND SO- YOU KNOW
THOSE THOSE CALCULATIONS WERE
MADE AS THEY ASSESS THE FULL
GRANT- POOL OF APPLICANTS AT
ONCE THE APPLICATION CLOSE- FOR
THE UNDERSERVED SMALL
BUSINESSES YOU KNOW WE DEFINE
THAT. ALIGNS WITH OUR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WHICH IS- PEOPLE OF
COLOR WOMEN RURAL AS WELL AS-
AS WELL AS VETERAN OF
BUSINESSES AS WELL AND THEN IN
ADDITION TO DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES LMI TRACKS THAT
EXIST AROUND THE STATE SO. THE
ALL OF THOSE ARE INCLUDED. IN
THE TOTAL PERCENT OF COURSE
THERE'S CROSSOVER AND THEY'RE
DEFINITELY YOU KNOW VETERANS
WERE ALSO PEOPLE OF COLOR
EXCEPT TRAP BUT THAT THAT THREE
QUARTERS IS- INDIVIDUALLY
TOTAL- THE AND THEN IN TERMS OF
THE IMPACTED INDUSTRIES WE
PRIORITIZED IT PRIORITIZED
INDUSTRIES IMPACTED BY
CORPORATE NINETEEN OF COURSE
THERE ARE SOME THAT ARE DEFINED
IS HIGHLY IMPACTED. THOSE ARE
THE ONES I WAS REFERENCING IN
TERMS OF TWO THIRDS WENT TO
HIGHLY IMPACTED INDUSTRIES THAT
SAID. A FEDERAL DEFINITION BUT
IT INCLUDES- YOU KNOW CERTAIN
INDUSTRY CODES LIKE PERSONAL
CARE AND EVERYTHING WITHIN THAT
RESTAURANTS AND OTHER EATING
PLACES A CHILD CARE SERVICES A
RETAIL CLOTHING STORES
SPECIALTY FOOD- AND THEN THE
REMAINDER OF THE GRANTS WENT TO
OTHER IMPACTED INDUSTRIES- BUT
WE WERE. GLAD TO SEE THAT
HIGHLY IMPACTED INDUSTRIES ALSO-
YOU ROSE TO THE TOP IN TERMS OF
THEM IN TERMS OF DOLLARS
RECEIVED. THE- AND THEN IN
TERMS OF THE GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION GEOGRAPHY AND
ESPECIALLY IMPACT BY COPA
NINETY. WERE FOUND. I WITH THE
STATE COMPLETELY. AT A STATE
HOME OR I'VE ALL. AT ALL ALL
CAO WERE IN. AND SO- YOU SEE
AND IT JUST. OF THIS- WHICH
ALSO TO THE ABILITY THESE PAR
ON THE TO SEE- INTO- INTO COME.
AKAU. ACROSS THE STATE FOR
BUSINESS OUTREACH ON OUTRAGE.
SO WE DID A- ACROSS THREE WE DO
FOR SOME FURTHER DE- THAT WOULD
AND TO. DO THE LEGISLATIVE.
LAST FROM FINANCE ARE HOPEFUL
YOU ENOUGH TO REVIEW THAT IS
ENJOY. WHAT WERE TRYING TO IT
SHE AND WHAT WE WERE ABLE. AND
THEN- WAS THERE SOME. IT WAS
PART OF THE- ALSO WERE THOSE
PER IN SAID RECEIVED FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE AND PAST. THE
BUSINESS'S OUR OUR ARE WHAT
OTHER GRAN OR PER THEY RECEIVE
AS WELL WHAT THEY'RE- DROPS
WERE- AND SO THAT THOSE- IMPACT
COULD BE- PROCESS YEAH. CHANNEL
WITH THE HIM FOR AS WELL FROM
THE IN. I OKAY VERY GOOD.
SENATOR NAY. YOUR RECORD IS
MINE ARE THESE DISTRIBUTION-
MOAMMAR. IN A CON. OR
MEMORANDUM OF UNDER WHAT IS THE
FOR MAY OF- AFFECTING THEN
TRAIN OF MY AND WHAT KINDS OF
REQUIRE ARE IMPOSED. ON THE END
OF WHO GETS THE GIRL- WHAT ARE
THE LEVEL WHAT MUCH THEY DO.
TWO COULD TO GET THE BEST. I
SEE YOUR YOU ARE THE END OF
SMALL ALREADY CRIME YES WE
DON'T WANT TO GET ON A BIG FOR
THING THAT SO RAMP AND GOV
TODAY. HOWEVER WE GO TO AND THE
AND THEY'VE IS VAL AND THAT
THEY ARE IN FACT DISTRICT THE
MONEY AND THE WITH THEY'RE
REPRESENT WAS. CRACKS THAT WE
DO SOME. THIS IS AS I MENTIONED-
AT BEN OF WORK WITH THAT A
FINANCIAL TO. IN THIS CASE A WE
NEED TO BE FUND INSTITUTIONS
THAT THERE ACCUSTOMED THE LONG.
TO CHECK ABOUT SO THERE ARE
NONE THERE ARE BACKGROUND CHECK
IN PLACE TO CLEAR- THAT ARE
DONE CREDIT CHECK. AS WELL AS-
AS CHECK ON SEX OF STATE OR
OTHER YOU KNOW LOCAL. CHANGE SO
THAT WE CAN ABOUT. THIS IS NICK
BUSINESS AB BENEFIT OF THIS
FOR. I BY STRUCTURE IS THE
BUSINESS HAD BE OPERATE IN
THOUSAND NINETEEN WHICH WE
CANNOT SEE. TAX WHICH AND SO
THOSE ARE. IN ADDITION SO THERE
ARE STEM- YEAH. CHECKS TO MAKE
SURE THIS IS AN- INVALID. I IN
TO PREVENT FROM WASTE AND ABUSE
I. ADDITIONALLY OF COURSE THERE
IS A LOT OF THAT. FROM THE BEST
IN TERMS OF USE OF FUNDS WE
ASKED THEM TO OUR YOU KNOW
CONFIRM THE THEY WOULD BE. THIS
ARE L. FOR. ADDITION OF THIS
PROGRAM AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING
ON THE GROUNDS- IF THROUGH OUR
PARTNERS AS WELL WHO HAPPENED A
XIN SHIPS ARE IN MANY CASES
WITH THESE. WITH THESE ENTITIES.
ARE THESE FORMALIZED IN SOME
MANNER THEN YOU HAVE
INDIVIDUALS ASSIGNED TO OVERSEE
THIS AND THEN REPORT. DO YOU TO
THE ADMINISTRATION AND TO THE
LEGISLATURE AS TO OUR PROGRESS.
WITH OUR ELECTED LEADER
INDIVIDUALLY THANK YOU SENATOR
YES OUR OUR INTERMEDIARY AND
USUALLY UP FRONT AND TRACKS ALL
THOSE CHECKS THAT I WAS
MENTIONING TO YOU INVALIDATES
THOSE I'M ON AN INDIVIDUAL
APPLICANT BASIS- A AND DAY AND
VERIFIES THAT THE APPLICANT HAS
TO WHEN APPLYING- VALIDATE AND
CERTIFY THOSE VIA THE USE OF
FUNDS EXCEPT TRACK AND THEN
WHEN THEY SIGNED THEIR CONTRACT
RECEIVED- FUNDS IS STILL ACTED
THEY ALSO HAVE TO VALIDATE. ALL
THAT INFORMATION AND CERTIFY
THEIR USE EXCEPT. I ALL THAT IS
WHAT I MIGHT HAVE MISSED THIS
BUT WHO THE INTERVIEW OR THAT
THROUGH THE HOME THIS IS
REPORTED ARE THEY WITHIN YOUR
AGENCY OR ANOTHER INDEPENDENT
pOUTSIDE- INTO T. A COMMUNITY
BUILDING FINANCIAL INSTITUTION
CALLED THE REGISTRY AND SO IT
IT IS- EXTERNAL CONTRACT THAT
WE HAVE. AND COMPETITIVELY BID
TO SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
OF THIS PROGRAM AND DESERVE
CONTRACT HAVE DELIVERABLES- IN
IT AND TIME LINES. CORRECT
CORRECT WE HAVE DELIVERABLES
SCHEDULES AND WELL AS YOU KNOW
A COMMITMENT TO DELIVER I
PRIORITIES ON IT WITHIN THAT
CONTRACT FACT. AND WHAT IS YOUR
MEANS OF- TRANSMITTING SUCH
INFORMATION TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. AT
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I UNDERSTAND THAT
THEY'VE THAT SUBMITTED SOME
INFORMATION TO THE BUDGET.
COMMITTEE AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION AS WE GET THROUGH
ADDITIONAL ROUNDS OF THIS
PROGRAM. OKAY BUT THE ONE THANK
YOU I'M I'M DRAWING ON THAT
BECAUSE THIS IS SOMETHING AND
I'M GOING TO KEEP A VERY CLOSE
EYE ON. AND THEN IT'S OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY AND IN THE TERMS
OF ITS BUDGET AUTHORITY- THIS
COMMITTEE WILL HAVE TO BE VERY
FASTIDIOUS ABOUT THAT AND AS
YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS THE BUDGET COMMITTEES OF
THE SENATE HAVE BEEN VERY VERY.
ON THE TO OVERSIGHT- NOT JUST
TO GIVE US A REPORT AND WE'LL
FILE IT AWAY BUT WE WE'VE HAD
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND WE'RE
GETTING INTO THE- OF MINUTE AND
THE MYTH MINUSCULE. AND WE'RE
REALLY LOOKING OVER THE. TO
KEEP TRACK OF THIS THIS IS A
LOT OF MONEY. GOING OUT. AND WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE IT IS GOING
OUT IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE
PROMISE. AND THE FILL UP LET ME
IF I MAY MISTER WHETHER FOR
COULD YOU- PIPE IN HERE TOO AS
TO. YOU OUTLINED A NUMBER OF
VERY VALID AREAS OF CONCERN.
ARE YOU SATISFIED AT THIS
POINT. THAT PROGRESS IS BEING
MADE IN THE FORMATION AND THE
ORGANIZATION AS DESCRIBED BY
THE DIRECTOR. IT SEEMS LIKE YOU
POINTED OUT SOME DEFICIENCIES
AND WE NEED TO BE ON TOP OF
THOSE I THINK THAT'S MY POINT
I'M NOT BEING ACCUSATORY BUT
THAT THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE ASSURE YOU. WE'VE RAISED
OUR CONCERNS THAT WERE. WERE
RAISED TO US- AND THEY- THEY IT
SOUNDS LIKE THE ADMINISTRATION
IS BEGINNING TO ADDRESS THOSE
AND WE'VE ALSO RAISED CONCERNS
ABOUT- TRANSPARENCY AND-
ADMINISTRATION HAS BEGUN TO
FLOW DOCUMENTS TO US- SO FOR
EXAMPLE OUR OFFICE RECEIVED.
THE CONTRACT. A COPY OF THE
CONTRACT. A YES AFTERNOON BUT
WE HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE FOR
EXAMPLE TO REVIEW IT SO YOU
HAVE- HOPEFULLY OVER THE
COMING. DAYS YOU HAVE A CONTENT.
WE DID RECEIVE A COPY OF THE
CONTRACT COULD YOU TO TRANSMIT
THAT OR- IF I MAY ASK FINANCED
TO TRANSMIT THAT. TO THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. SO WE GET THE KIND
OF REVIEW THE CONTRACT
OURSELVES. YES I'D BE HAPPY TO
DO THAT IF. I WANT TO VERIFY
THAT THE THAT I DID I. IF I DO
APOLOGIZE MY INTERNET WAS I WAS
OUT YESTERDAY SO IT'S A LITTLE
BIT HECTIC IN HE AFTERNOON-
UNDERSTOOD BUT ON. WELL I'M
SORRY TO HAVE TO MAKE THIS
OBSERVATION BUT I HAVE LITTLE
TRUST. AND SO I NEED MORE
VERIFICATION AND THAT'S WHAT
I'M LOOKING TO IN YOUR
CONTRACTS WITH YOUR PROVIDERS.
AND TRACKING THE SUCCESS OR THE
LACK OF SUCCESS. OF WERE OF
THAT MONEY IS DIRECTED. AND
MOST ASSUREDLY I'M AS CONCERNED
AS OUR CHAIR IS ABOUT THE
DISTRIBUTION FAIRLY ACROSS THE
STATE. IT IS THE NORM NOT THE
EXCEPTION THAT THE RURAL AREAS
ARE NEGLECTED. WE'VE SEEN THAT
MOST RECENTLY IN A SO CALLED
WEBSITE SINCE THEN PUT UP FOR.
THE TO ASSIST OUR OUR CITIZENS
SO THAT WEBSITES ONLY AVAILABLE
TO ONE COUNTY ENOUGH TAKE UP TO
SIX MONTHS FOR THE OTHER. FIFTY
SEVEN COUNTIES THE TO ACCESS
THAT. THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE TO ME SO WE'RE
GONNA NEED A LOT OF THAT
OVERSIGHT WE THANK YOU FOR
BEING FOR SERIOUS ABOUT THAT
AND RAISING THESE CONCERNS. AND
THEN BE ADVISED I'M GOING TO
CERTAINLY BE WATCHING IT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER NELSON.
SENATOR NIELSEN- ON ON NOT ON
THAT ISSUE- I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ON. THE PHONE CALL WHERE
L'INDUSTRIE WAS INTRODUCED AND
WROTE THE PROGRAM WAS ROLLED
OUT AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
TIME. I WAS VERY IMPRESSED WITH
LINDA STREETS- QUALIFICATIONS
WITH THEIR THEIR MISSION AND-
THE FACT THAT THEIR TO THEIR-
LICENSE AS A CDFI. SAYS A LOT
ABOUT WHAT THEIR MISSION AND
THEIR GOAL IS AND SO I'VE BEEN-
I I'M I'M VERY HOPEFUL THAT
THIS PROGRAM RUN SMOOTHLY AND
THAT THEY'VE GOT THAT. THE
EXPERTISE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY MEET THE- THE STATED
PURPOSE FOR WHICH THIS GRANT
PROGRAM WAS SET UP. BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
TRANSPARENCY SOME REALLY GLAD
TO HEAR THAT THE CONTRACT- YOU
HAVE A COPY OF THE CONTRACT
AND- WILL GET A CHANCE TO
REVIEW THAT TO MAKE. SURE THAT
THERE ARE DELIVERABLES- THAT WE
CAN. VERIFY A THE KIND OF
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED BY
SENATOR NIELSEN- AND- AND I AND
I THINK THAT- AS THIS PROGRAM
ROLLS OUT THERE HAVE BEEN SOME
ISSUES RAISED BY SOME OF THE-
SOME OF THE- PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT THE FIRST
ROUND OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. AND I'M I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN. IN HEARING WHAT
KIND OF IMPROVEMENTS YOU CAN
SEE TO THE PROGRAM THAT ARE
GOING TO MAKE IT EITHER MORE
ACCESSIBLE OR- OR YEP MORE
ACCESSIBLE ACTUALLY IS REALLY
WHAT IT WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT I
THINK THAT. THAT THE- I'VE BEEN
IMPRESSED WITH THE SPEED AT
WHICH- THIS PROGRAM IS ROLLED
OUT AND THAT THE-
PROFESSIONALISM OF L'INDUSTRIE
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE
OUT- A LOT OF COMPLAINTS ABOUT
ACCESS THAT- THAT NEED TO BE
DEALT WITH SO IF YOU COULD TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT THEN
WILL MOVE ON TO- SENATOR
SKINNER'S QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
SENATOR YES AND- YOU KNOW THE
IT WAS A COMPETITIVE BID
PROCESS THAT SELECTED
L'INDUSTRIE OUR REQUEST FOR
PROPOSALS WAS PUT OUT ON CAL
THE PROCURE. I WITH THE
STATEMENT OF WORK TO FIND-
WHICH YOU WILL FIND MIMICKED IN
THE CONTRACTS SO IT WAS IS. A
PUBLIC PROCESS FROM THAT
PERSPECTIVE- V. THE- THE
ADDITIONAL- THING I WOULD SAY
IS THAT YOU KNOW WHAT WE'VE
WHAT WE FOUND TO BE REALLY
EFFECTIVE AS IS THE CDFI
NETWORKS THAT ARE COLLABORATING
TOGETHER- ARE YOU. TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE NETWORKS THAT ARE
COLLABORATING TOGETHER- THEY'VE
HAD TIME TO RAMP UP STAFF IN
MANY CASES THEY'VE DONE
MULTIPLE WEBINARS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE NOW FOR CONTENT-
WE'VE BEEN THAT EFFECTIVE IN
GETTING. THE MESSAGE OUT VIA
EARNED MEDIA AND SOCIAL MEDIA-
TOO MANY SMALL BUSINESSES AND
SO- YOU KNOW WE FEEL THAT THAT
THAT IS GOING TO GIVE US
ADDITIONAL CHARGES WE ENTER
ROUND TWO- YEAH WE'RE PLEASED
THAT WE WERE ABLE TO WRAP UP
ROUND ONE QUICKLY AND GIVE YOU
THE DATA AS SOON AS POSSIBLE OF
COURSE. AS WE WERE GOING
THROUGH THE PROCESS AND DATA
WAS NOT AVAILABLE. IN A TO
SHARE AS WE WENT THROUGH BUT
NOW THAT THE ROUND ONE IS
CLOSED WE'RE PLEASED THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT DATED
TO YOU AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE-
SO WHAT WE HOPE TO DO IN IN
ROUND TWO FOR IMPROVEMENTS- WE-
ARE OUR PARTNERS ON THE GROUND
CONTINUALLY NEED THAT SUPPORT
WE EVEN HAD ONE PARTNER- IN
THE- IN. IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY-
DOING DRIVE THROUGH DOCUMENT
UPLOAD AND ASSISTANCE AND SO
OUR PARTNERS ARE GETTING
CREATIVE IN TERMS OF THAT THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE ON THE GROUND WE'RE
HAVING SOME. TARGETED LANGUAGE-
WORKING GROUP'S WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO- AND CONTINUALLY
MEETS THE NEEDS OF THOSE WHO
REQUIRE SERVICES IN DIFFERENT
LANGUAGES- AND WHERE YOU'RE
TRANSLATING THE APPLICATIONS-
IN MULTIPLE LANGUAGES SO THAT.
INDIVIDUALS CAN CAN FOLLOW
ALONG IN ADDITION TO THE VIDEOS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN PROVIDED
TO THEM FOR APPLICANTS-
APPLICATION PROCESS. AND SO-
YOU KNOW THAT THOSE TYPES. OF
THE CONTINUOUS CREATIVE OUT WE
THE- THE- AND- ASSISTANCE WILL
WILL BE. AT ABOUT AS WE THROUGH.
THE PROCESS- IN TERMS OF- IN
TERMS OF THE TECHNOLOGY AND
THAT THE CALL CENTER SUPPORT
THAT L'INDUSTRIE HAS. HAS
DELIVERED THE INCREASE THEIR
CAPACITY- THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS AS WELL AS EXPANDED THE
CALL CENTER SUPPORT TOWARDS THE
END OF THE PROGRAM THEY
EXPANDED HOURS YOU KNOW
BASICALLY UP UNTIL ELEVEN PM AT
NIGHT. A SIX AM TO ELEVEN PM
AND THEY WELL IN ROUND TWO-
EXPAND THEIR CUSTOMER SERVICE
CALL CENTER. AVAILABILITY IS
AGAIN AGAIN WHAT WE FOUND-
THROUGH THIS EXPERIENCE WAS
THAT- ONE AND YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WERE VERY FRANTIC AND APPLYING
MORE THAN ONCE IN JAMMING THE
SYSTEM 25% OF- OF ALL.
APPLICATIONS ABOUT THE THREE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
WERE DUPLICATES AND THAT WE
HAVE TO CLEAR OUT THE SYSTEM
WITH AND SO. I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW YOU'LL YOU'LL SEE THAT
THEN. HOPEFULLY THAT- THAT
FRANTIC THIS HAS HAS RESIGNED A
LITTLE BIT SO THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE CUSTOM SUPPORT FOR
THOSE WHO WHO NEED IT- TO GET
THROUGH THE SYSTEM- IN IN
ADDITION- YOU KNOW WE HOPE TO.
CONTINUE TO TRY. WORK WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO SEE IF THERE ARE
ANY SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT
NEED FURTHER CLARIFICATION WE
WANT TO INCREASE OUR
COMMUNICATION ACROSS THE
APPLICATION FEATURES AS WELL
AS- THROUGHOUT THE PROGRAM TO
MAKE SURE THAT. EVERYBODY HAS
THE INFORMATION THEY NEED IN A
TIMELY MANNER AND SO INCREASED-
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR PARTNERS
AND WITH THE APPLICANTS WILL
WILL BE A NEW FEATURE AS WE
MOVE INTO THIS NEXT ROUND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THAT-
CENTER SKINNER. THANK YOU CHAIR
CABALLERO- I WANTED TO MY EYES
GOING TO DIRECT MY FIRST
QUESTION TO- ADMINISTRATION REP
WHO IS MOST APPROPRIATE TO
ANSWER THIS. IN LOOKING AT THE
LETTER THAT THE LEGISLATURE
RECEIVED REGARDING THE GRANTS
THAT WERE DISTRIBUTED SO FAR.
I'M LOOKING AT THE TABLE WHERE
IT INDICATES THAT WHICH- D.
IMPACTED INDUSTRIES WORDED AND
IT SHOWS A GOOD PERCENT FOR
PERSONAL CARE WHICH I THINK
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO MOST
EVERYONE GIVEN THAT ALMOST ALL
PERSONAL CARE. I FACILITIES HAD
TO BE CLOSED IN REALLY SOME NOT
OPENED AT ALL- IN VARIOUS OTHER
THINGS NOW WHAT'S NOT CLEAR
FROM HERE. IS THE- PERFORMANCE
WILL RECORD CULTURAL BUT
PERFORMANCE MUSEUM THINGS LIKE
THAT WHICH WE KNOW. IF WE TAKE
IF WE COMPARE TO RESTAURANTS
WHILE RESTAURANTS AND BARS WERE
SERIOUSLY IMPACTED. MANY COULD
STILL OPERATE TO A DEGREE WITH
TO GO FOR EXAMPLE WHERE S.
PERFORMANCE VENUES MUSEUMS AND
ALL THAT HAD TO CLOSE
COMPLETELY AND MOST OF NOT
OPERATED AT ALL SINCE MARCH. SO
IT I WANTED. TO- WE'RE NO
GRANTS PROVIDED TO THAT
CATEGORY IN THIS LAST ROUND AND
IS IT ONLY ARE WE ONLY LOOKING
FORWARD FOR THAT IN THIS NEXT-
IN THE PROPOSAL YOU HAVE BEFORE
US OR WERE THERE SOME INCLUDED
IN THIS LAST ROUND. BUT WE CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH SPECIFIC DATA ON
THAT- I KNOW THAT THAT YES
THERE WERE MULTIPLE INDUSTRIES
IN INCLUDING- YOU KNOW MANY
NONPROFITS SERVED- WITHIN THAT
CATEGORY BUT I HAVE TO FOLLOW
UP WITH YOU FOR SPECIFIC AND
KIND OF COURSES YOU KNOW JUST
LIKE REGULAR BUSINESS NONPROFIT
IS A HUGE CATEGORY NONPROFIT
COULD MEAN. ANY ANY NUMBER OF
IT DOESN'T NECESSARILY
PERFORMANCE OR CULTURAL.
OPERATIONS SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
REALLY TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
THIS- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
TARGETING IMPACTED INDUSTRIES
THIS IS WHEN I'M TRYING TO GET
A HANDLE AT- ARE WE DO WE HAVE
CRITERIA. THAT TARGETS THOSE
THAT HAVE HAD. TO EXPERIENCE
FAR MORE SUBSTANTIAL OR
SIGNIFICANT AND OFTEN USING
DIFFERENT WORDS THAT CLOSURES
OR DROP IN OPERATIONS THAN
OTHERS. WE WERE TKING INTO
ACCOUNT THE BLUEPRINTS- YOUR
FIRST SAFELY REOPENING AS WELL
AS SARAH IT IS WELL IT'S JUST
YOUR GRAPHIC INDUSTRY IMPACT
WHEN WE WHEN WE PRIORITIZE
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS TO BE
SERVED. OKAY WELL LOOKING AT
THE RESPONSE TO THE FIRST ROUND
IN OBVIOUSLY SO MUCH LARGER
THAN WHAT WE HAD AVAILABLE AND
EVEN IF WE ACT AND- ME EVEN.
THE REQUESTED NOW IS ALREADY
LOWER THAN WHAT WE KNOW THE
DEMAND WHETHER THAT WHETHER
DEMAND THE NEED- EXACTLY THE
SAME I'M NOT GONNA QUITE YET
BUT- IF I JUST TAKE DEMAND. SO
ASSUMING THAT THERE IS GREATER
NEED. THAN THE FUNDS THAT WERE
NOW TALKING ABOUT BEING MADE
AVAILABLE. HOW IS IT THAT WE
CAN ENSURE THAT THOSE MOST
IMPACTED FINANCIALLY ARE BEING
ABLE TO ACCESS THESE GRANTS.
YEAH A LOT OF IT THAT I THINK
IS DRIVEN BY THE OUTRAGE AND
THE ENGAGEMENT THAT WE THAT WE
CONDUCT OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS THE SECOND ROUND
DISCOVERY SECOND THROUGH A IN
ADDITIONAL FUNDS ARE AWARDED-
CONTINUING TO ADD ON INTO
FUTURE ROUNDS- I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S ALONE I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
OUR REACH IS IMPORTANT BUT IT'S
THE CRITERIA ADDITION RIGHT I
THINK THAT'S HE QUESTION WHEN
WE USE THE WORDS LIKE
TRANSPARENCY WHAT WE'RE REALLY
MEANING IT I THINK MAYBE
SOMEBODY ELSE MEANS SOMETHING
ELSE BUT- IS WHAT. ARE THE
CRITERIA. YES SENATOR I AGREE
AND DOES NOT WAS GOING TO BE
THE SECOND POINT WAS IN
ADDITION- THE WAY THAT WE'VE
PRIORITIZED- IMPACTED
INDUSTRIES AS WELL AS IMPACTED-
COMMUNITIES GEOGRAPHIES AND
UNDERSERVED BUSINESS GROUPS AND
SO- YOU KNOW IF. IF MORE
SPECIFIC TARGETING TOWARDS
SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES IS OF
INTEREST I KNOW THAT THERE'S
BEEN A REQUEST FOR TWENTY FIVE
MILLION SPECIFICALLY FOR
CULTURE INSTITUTION AS AN
EXAMPLE. OF ME THAT CAN BE
EMBEDDED IN IN THE PROGRAM IN
THE ANALYSIS IN FUTURE IN
FUTURE ROUNDS WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. OKAY SO
NOW- I WANT SOME QUESTIONS THE
ELADIO- SO YOU LAID OUT YOUR
REPORT IN THESE VARIOUS
RECOMMENDATIONS- AND I NOTICED
IN THE FINAL PAGES YOU DO MAKE
SOME SPECIFIC SUGGESTIONS FOR
HOW TO TARGET- BUT THE MAIN
SPECIFIC ONE IS TARGET ENTITIES
THAT WERE NOT ABLE TO GET THE
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE. ON AND WE
MAY WANT TO REVISIT WHETHER OUR
CRITERIA IN FACT DOES THAT OR
NOT BUT WHAT I'D LIKE TO HEAR
FROM LA- IS WHAT I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE- L. A. O. OFTEN
RAISES SOME VERY LEGITIMATE
POINTS BUT DOES NOT NECESSARILY
GIVE US. SPECIFIC CONCRETE
SUGGESTIONS FOR WHAT WE MIGHT
CONSIDER IN TERMS OF IMPROVING.
EITHER THAT OF IMPROVING OUR
ABILITY TO REACH THE MOST
IMPACTED ENTITY OR IMPROVE
TRANSPARENCY SO WHAT I WANTED
TO HEAR FROM LA- IS IF. THEY
HAD ANY SPECIFIC.
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR OUR
CONSIDERATION BEYOND FOR
EXAMPLE THE TARGETING OF
ENTITIES THAT COULDN'T GET
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE. HELLO YES
SO- ONE ONE THING THAT WAS
BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION WAS
THE IN DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PROVIDED
ON GRANTS OR A NEW A NEW
PROGRAM TO PROVIDE FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE TO PERFORMING
INSTITUTIONS AND MANY OF THE
STATE'S MUSEUMS AND CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS WITH PERFORMANCE
SPACES WILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THAT FEDERAL PROGRAM FOR
EXAMPLE BUT- BUT SOME OF THAT
DON'T HAVE DEDICATED
PERFORMANCE SPACES MAY NOT BE
AND SO THAT MIGHT BE ONE AREA
IN PARTICULAR WHERE WE MIGHT
LOOK AT TARGETING THIS PROGRAM
BETTER SO IT TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE DO HAVE A SET ASIDE FOR
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS. YOU
MIGHT LOOK AT WHERE. WHERE
THERE'S A GAP IN THAT IN THAT
PARTICULAR WAY. ON THAT THAT'S
ONE CONCRETE- SUGGESTION WE
HAVE. ANOTHER IS ACTUALLY
ASKING- YOU KNOW WHEN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE INDUSTRY'S- THAT
THAT WERE MOST TARGETED AND
LOOKING AT. THE ON THE REVENUE
DECLINES- DID THEY- DID THEY
RECEIVE- A P. P. P. THAT WAS
PROPORTIONAL WITH THE AMOUNT OF
THE REVENUE DECLINE AND- IN MAY
BE PRIORITIZING IT TOWARDS
THOSE THAT HAVE THE LARGEST GAP
BETWEEN. THEIR ON THEIR DECLINE
IN IN REVENUE AND PERHAPS ALSO
LOOKING AT. THREE ANY INCREASE
IN THEIR OPERATING EXPENSES IN
RESPONDING TO COPE IT. SO
THERE'S WAYS TO- FURTHER
FURTHER NARROW- WITHIN THIS
GROUP THAT'S ORIGINALLY
TARGETED SO- YOU KNOW IN
ANOTHER- ANOTHER OBSERVATION WE
HAD IS THAT- IN THE GEOGRAPHIC
DISTRIBUTION. ALL COUNTIES IN
THE STATE HAVE BEEN- UNDER-
STATE HOMEOWNERS AT SOME POINT
SO- WHERE IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE
WE'RE KIND OF- GEOGRAPHICALLY
BEING EVENLY WEIGHTED AND HOW
WE'RE LOOK FOR LOOKING AT
OTHERS. AND STILL STILL NEED A
LITTLE BIT MORE INFORMATION ON
THAT BUT- BUT PERHAPS IT SHOULD
BE TARGETED TOWARDS- THE
COUNTIES WHERE THEY WERE UNDER-
MUCH LONGER- IN THE PURPLE
CHAIR FOR EXAMPLE. THANKS I
APPRECIATE THAT AND I RAISE
THAT BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE IN
OVERSIGHT HEARING NOW WE'RE NOT
VOTING AND- WE'RE OBVIOUSLY.
THE GOVERNOR'S INTENT WHICH I
SUPPORT AND I THINK I THINK.
NOT TO BE TOO BOLD FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S INTENT ALSO WOULD
BE TO WE KNOW. THAT OUR SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY IS HURTING
WE KNOW THAT THEY ARE IN TERMS
OF GETTING US BACK ON TRACK
ECONOMICALLY THEY ARE THE
PRIMARY PROVIDER OF JOBS IN THE
STATE AND WE KNOW THAT. VAST
MAJORITY OF JOBS LOST OF PEOPLE
ARE STILL UNEMPLOYED WERE
PEOPLE THAT WERE HAD BEEN
EMPLOYED BY SMALL BUSINESS.
THIS IS CLEARLY A VERY
IMPORTANT AREA. AND WHAT THE L.
A. O.'S AND IT'S AND IT'S NOT
ONLY A. VERY IMPORTANT AREA
IT'S ONE OF THOSE WHERE.
URGENCY AND IMMEDIACY ACTION IS
BENEFICIAL. BUT WE ALSO WANT TO
DO IT RIGHT SO THE L. A. O.'S
DOCUMENT WAS A LITTLE- OKAY
LESS HELPFUL FOR ME ONLY
BECAUSE IN SAYING THE
LEGISLATURE MIGHT WANT TO
COLLECT DATA OR REVIEW THESE
THINGS BEFORE. AND THAT IS
OPTIMAL AT TIMES BUT WE ARE IN
A WE ARE WE ARE IN NEED OF
IMMEDIATE ACTION NOW SO GIVEN
OUR PAST EXPERIENCE. AND A
WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE TO LA ONE
OTHERS HAVE. SOME CONCRETE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR THE FOURTH
WASTE EITHER TARGET OR- ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT ELIO
RAISED WOULD BE I. THINK
HELPFUL FOR US- THE OTHER
SENATOR SKINNER YOU MIGHT WANT
EXCUSE ME YOU MIGHT WANT TO ASK
ABOUT THE RANKING- IS- OF
MISCUES MON- SINCE THEY SET UP
THE THIS PROGRAM AND- ANYWAY
THAT MAY BE THAT THE
APPROPRIATE THE WAY TOO YEAH TO
GET. A LITTLE BIT MORE AND WILL
BECAUSE THAT IF I UNDERSTAND IT
RIGHT AND I DID MISS THE VERY
OPENING IS THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
ACCESS TO HOW THE RANKING WOULD
OCCUR PRIOR TO THE ISSUING OF
THE GRANTS CORRECT SO. IT I
THINK IT WOULD BE VERY
IMPORTANT TO SEE THE EXACT. THE
PROPOSAL FOR HOW TO RANK AND
MAYBE IT HOW IT WAS RANKED SO
FAR AND THEN HOW. THE
ADMINISTRATION IS. PROPOSING TO
RANK FOR THE NEXT ROUND SO THAT
WE CAN IF WE FEEL APPROPRIATE
MODIFY THAT GOING FORWARD. SO
IF I IF FROM THE ADMINISTRATION
COULD RESPOND TO THAT I'M NOT
SURE WHICH PERSON IS THE PROPER
ONE. THIS IS A DIRECTOR THIS
MONTH SO WE- WE DID NOT HAVE
SPECIFIC TARGET NUMBERS FOR SET
ASIDES BY INDUSTRY OR BY
GEOGRAPHY OR BY UNDERSERVED
CATEGORY SO THERE WERE NOT A
PERCENTAGE- GOALS OR OR OR
STATUS SIDES IDENTIFIED- IT
WAS. MORE OF AN ANALYSIS AND
ALGORITHM THAT L'INDUSTRIE
CREATED TO- TO ENSURE THAT WE
WERE HITTING THOSE PRIORITY
CATEGORIES GEOGRAPHIC- IMPACT
OF COOLEY NINETEEN. BASED ON
YOUR BLUEPRINTS IN ENCLOSURES
EXCEPT TRACK AS WELL AS
INDUSTRY IMPACTED BY YOU KNOW
IMPACTED INDUSTRIES YOUR FALL
OFF IN TERMS OF THEIR CLOSURES
OR REVENUE DROPS SUBJECT- AND
THEN THE. UNDERSERVED AND
DISADVANTAGED. SO I APPRECIATE
AND I COMPRISED FINE WITH THAT
THEIR WORK PER SE SET ASIDES.
BUT I THINK IT WOULD BE HELPFUL
FOR US IF L'INDUSTRIE COULD
PROVIDE US SOMETHING MORE
CONCRETE THAT SHOWS WHAT THE
CRITERIA WORK. BECAUSE IT IN
OTHER WORDS IT IS IT THAT'S
WHERE IT BECOMES THIS ISSUE OF
TRANSPARENCY SO IS THERE
SOMETHING MORE. A LITTLE MORE
CLARITY ON. THE EITHER HOW THE
ALGORITHM DETERMINED PRIORITY
OR CRITERIA FOR PRIORITY WE CAN
WE CAN THE SENATOR WE CAN
DEFINITELY FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
AND SEE WHAT WE CAN PROVIDE- I
KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW L'INDUSTRIE
AS IN ALL THESE ORGANIZATIONS
HAVE PROPRIETARY TECHNOLOGY- SO
WE CANNOT AND WE ARE WORKING WE
CAN SEE WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE SPECIFIC ENOUGH TO
SHARE FURTHER INSIGHTS WELL. I
APPRECIATE THAT SO MAYBE IT'S
INSTEAD WHAT DIRECTION WE GAVE
THAT BECAUSE IT IS STATE MONEY
IS GOING TO LEAD TO SPREE SO
CERTAINLY I DON'T WANT TO.
INTERFERE WITH LINDA STREETS
PRIORITY BUT- WE WERE THAT YOU
KNOW. IT IS STATE MONEY AND WE
ARE. TRYING TO PROVIDE MORE OF
MORE THAN JUST HIGH HIGH LEVEL
GUIDANCE ON HOW IT GOES OUT.
SENATOR IF I MAY AND WILL WE
WILL GET BACK TO YOU AND ALL
THE INDUSTRIES THAT WERE
COVERED AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
WE CAN. AND ALL THE OTHER
INFORMATION- OKAY SO THAT WOULD
BE WHAT WAS COVERED BUT ALSO
GOING FORWARD WHAT YES. OKAY
NOW. SOMEONE MAY HAVE ALREADY
ASKED THIS. BUT GIVEN THAT WE
ARE HOPING NOT HOPING WE INTEND
TO EXPAND THAT YOUR PROPOSAL
AND WHILE IT'S NOT BEEN ADOPTED
YET I AM GOING TO ASSUME THAT
THE LEGISLATURE IS IN AGREEMENT
THAT WE DO WANT TO EXPAND- THIS
LED TO STREET IS THAT YOUR
ASSESSMENT THAT L'INDUSTRIE YES
THE CAPACITY TO DO SO. OR ARE
YOU ALSO TALKING OTHER VENDORS.
IT WOULD BE OUR INTEREST TO
CONTINUE WITH THAT THE SAME.
VENDOR I MEAN ONE THE SYSTEM IS
SET UP- SO IN TERMS OF
EFFICIENCY AND SCALE AND DOING
THIS QUICKLY- L'INDUSTRIE IS
EQUIPPED TO DO THAT- YEAH THEY
DID OPERATE THE LARGEST A GRANT
PROGRAM IN THE STATE BEFORE
THEY DID PENNSYLVANIA'S AS AN
EXAMPLE- AMONG. NINE OTHER
PROGRAMS. SO WE DO TRUST AND
HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THEIR
SYSTEMS AND CONTROLS TO DELIVER
THE RESULTS THAT WE WANT- YEAH
ADDITIONALLY. WE HAVE THOSE
APPLICANTS IN THE SYSTEM IT
WOULD BE A SHAME TO HAVE THOSE
SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE TO
REAPPLY WITH ANY OTHER VENDOR-
I THINK THAT WOULD LEAD TO AN
EXTREME CRIMES OCCUR OKAY. NOW
AND MAYBE ON I MAY HAVE MISSED
THIS BUT IS OUR ANTICIPATION
THAT IF THE IF THE BUDGET MAN
ON THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO
APPROVE THE FUNDING THAT'S BEEN
REQUESTED THAT WE WOULD ONLY BE
CONSIDERING THOSE THAT HAVE
ALREADY APPLIED OR WOULD WE BE.
ON OPENING. AGAIN AND
CONSIDERING NEW APPLICANTS. YES
WE WOULD BE OPENING AGAIN EVEN
IN OUR ROUND TWO WITH THIS HALF
SECOND HALF OF THAT FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROGRAM
WE ARE RE OPENING AT TWO NEW
APPLICANTS SO ALL THE- ALL
THOSE WHO WERE NOT SELECTED ONE
ONE D. ROUND ONE TO MOVE
FORWARD. AND OTHERS ARE ABLE TO
APPLY. OKAY SO AT THAT POINT WE
WOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO FOR
EXAMPLE IF THERE WAS. IF IN THE
FIRST ROUND WE HAD- LIMITATION
LIMITED MATERIAL SAY IN A
DIFFERENT LANGUAGE OR- WHATEVER
LIMITED TYPE OF OUTREACH WE
COULD WE COULD ADDRESS THOSE.
THAT'S CORRECT OKAY- I THINK
THOSE ARE THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
I WANTED TO ANNEX IN ASKING
THOSE QUESTIONS I WANT TO BE
CLEAR I AM NOT RAISING THEM TO
CAUSE US TO NOT MOVE FORWARD
I'M RAISING THEM TO GIVE US THE
ABILITY TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THE BEST EFFICIENCY SIMPLICITY
BUT ALSO MEETING THE NEEDS OF
THOSE WHO WHO NEED IT MOST THEY
CAN GIVE US THE BEST RETURN IN
TERMS OF- MAINTAINING THOSE
BUSINESSES AND ULTIMATELY WHEN
ART WHEN WE ARE ABLE TO
CIRCULATE BETTER. THAT THOSE
BUSINESSES WOULD THEN BE ABLE
TO RE EMPLOY PEOPLE. YES
SENATOR IF I MAY JUST ADD TO
THAT BRIEFLY THAT- WE DO WE CAN
PROVIDE TO YOU THAT THE
CRITERIA IT WAS OUTLINED IN OUR
OURS P. AS WELL AS OUR CONTRACT
AND- WE CAN PROVIDE THAT DETAIL
TO YOU AGAIN. VERY GOOD WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
IT MAY BE THAT- FOR FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE THAT JUST THE
VISUALS OF WHERE THE GRANT. THE
GRANTS- HAVE GONE TO M. AND-
THE TYPES OF BUSINESSES BYE BYE
BYE CARE CATEGORY WOULD BE REAL
HELPFUL FOR US TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE BIT BETTER- HOW THAT. I
THINK THAT THAT THE BUSINESSES
THAT YOU TALKED ABOUT ARE ALL.
WE HAVE ALL HAD PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE THAT THOSE ARE THE
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE BEEN
IMPACTED THE MOST SO I
APPRECIATE THAT THE DETAIL AND
I THINK THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR- THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING OUR QUESTIONS WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON. TO THE OTHER TWO
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL LIKE TO
INVITE MARC HERBERT THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY TO. TESTIFY
WELCOME. THANK YOU SIR THANK
YOU A CHAIR VICE CHAIR FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
AFTERNOON OR THIS MORNING
RATHER ON A REALLY CRITICAL
PROGRAM- I WORK REMOTELY SMALL
BUSINESS MAJORITY WERE NATIONAL
SMALL BUSINESS EDUCATION AND
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION. AND WE
WORK WITH SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
TO HELP THEM TAKE THEIR NEXT
STEP ON THEIR JOURNEY AND WE DO
HUNDREDS OF EDUCATIONAL
WORKSHOPS- AS WELL AS AND-
ENSURE THAT THEIR VOICE IS PART
OF POLICY CONVERSATIONS HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AS WELL AS- OTHER
STATE CAPITALS- AS A- DRUG TO
USE MY MENTION THEIR FOUR POINT
ONE MILLION SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND AS IN THE US CENTERS
MENTIONED. ROUGHLY OUT THE
PRIVATE SECTOR LABOR FORCE IS
EMPLOYED BY SMALL BUSINESSES
THESE OF THE JOB CREATORS- AND
WE CAN'T OVERSTATE ENOUGH HOW
IMPORTANT THIS PROGRAM IS. FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THE
SURVIVAL OF CALIFORNIA
ENTREPRENEURS OUT WE STILL
APPRECIATE THE VERY QUICK
ACTION- THAT THE GOVERNMENT
SHUT AND HOW QUICKLY THE
LEGISLATURE IS MOVING NOW- TO
REALLY BE THOUGHTFUL ABOUT HOW
DO WE MAKE SURE THAT WE MOVE
FAST I WITH. THE- APPROPRIATE I
COUNTY ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
TO MAKE SURE THAT IN THIS
MOMENT WHERE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE HURTING AND IT NEEDS
AHLERS ARE REACHING SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS. IN THE
COMMUNITY- WE'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR GRANTS AS AN
ORGANIZATION BOTH NATIONALLY
AND THROUGHOUT THE STATE SINCE
THE BEGINNING OF THE CRISIS. WE
KNOW THAT BUSINESS OWNERS I
KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH THE MONEY
THAT THEY RECEIVE TO HELP THEM
SURVIVE INTO HANG ON DURING
THESE REALLY CHALLENGING TIMES
AND THAT'S WHY THIS GRANT
PROGRAM IS SO CRITICAL. WE
RECENTLY RELEASED SOME POLLING
LAST MONTH. THE TAKE A LOOK
BACK AT HOW SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS TO HAVE SURVIVED. THE
HEARING CALIFORNIA OVER THE
PAST TEN MONTHS. ROUGHLY A
THIRD HAVE HAD TO CUT EMPLOYEE
HOURS I 25% HAVE REDUCED
EMPLOYEE WAGES. AT QUARTER HAVE
HAD TO COMPLETELY CHANGE THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL- AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE. FOR
ENTREPRENEURS OF COLOR IN
ENTREPRENEURS- IN UNDER
RESOURCE COMMUNITIES- AND 60%
SAID THEY STILL HAVEN'T BROUGHT
BACK- THEIR EMPLOYEES AND WE
KNOW THIS THE DATABASE. ABOUT-
THEN CENTERS YOU MENTION I
THERE A LOT OF PERSONAL STORIES
THAT HAVE ALL HEARD. AND
BUSINESSES WHO BEEN YOU NEED
EMPIRE- AND THE PROPOSAL SENT
RIGHT NOW FOR SMALL USUALLY AS
WE LOOK FORWARD. AS OUR POLLING
SHOWS ROUGHLY 40% OF
BUSINESSES- SIX SIX SAY THAT
THEY ARE LIKELY TO DRAMATICALLY
CHANGE HOW THEY DO BUSINESS IN
ORDER TO SURVIVE. IN ORDER TO
HANG ON I'M A FULL THIRTY A
FULL THIRD. BELIEVE THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
FURTHER CUT EMPLOYEE HOURS IN
THE COMING MONTHS AND ANOTHER
FOR THIRD BELIEVE THAT THEY
WILL HAVE TO. REDUCE EMPLOYEE
WAGES AGAIN IN THE COMING
MONTHS- AND AS DIRECTED WAS MY
MENTIONED EARLIER I WE HAVE A
SURVEY EARLIER THIS YEAR
SHOWING THAT ROUGHLY 40% OF
BLACK ENTREPRENEURS WHERE REST
OF CLOSING. AND NOW WE ALSO
KNOW THAT ROUGHLY 60% ARE
STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR RENT OR
THEIR MORTGAGE AND THERE'S SO
MANY OTHER CHALLENGES. AND WE
KNOW THAT PPP WAS HELPFUL FOR
BUSINESSES OVER THE SUMMER- BUT
AS WE RECALL MOST OF THAT WAS
GOING TOWARD SALARIES AS IT
SHOULD AS A PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM. BUT THERE'S SO MANY
OTHER CHALLENGES THAT BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE FACING AS THEY'RE
TRYING TO HANG ON AS THEY'RE
TRYING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF
THEIR- CUSTOMERS OTHER
BUSINESSES- 25% ARE BEHIND ON
RENT PAYMENTS ON. DEBT
PAYMENTS- AND A NUMBER HAVE
MISSED THOSE PAYMENTS- AND SO
THE LANDSCAPE REALLY
CHALLENGING ESPECIALLY AS WE
JUST CAME THROUGH THE HOLIDAY
SEASON WITH MANY OF THOSE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS GET BACK INTO
THE BLACK- AND WE WERE IN THE
MIDST. OF A CHALLENGING-
INCREASE. AND THE SPREAD OF THE
PANDEMIC WHICH REQUIRED. US TO
A SHOULD HAVE STAYED HOME
ORDERS WHICH MADE EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES- AND THAT'S WHY THIS
GRANT PROGRAM IS SO IMPORTANT.
TO MOVE SO QUICKLY AND TO MEET
THIS MASSIVE MASSIVE MEDIA WE
WERE PROUD. TO JOIN CALLOUS BA
AND LENDINGTREE WE ARE ONE OF
THOSE FIVE HUNDRED
ORGANIZATIONS- THAT THE
DIRECTOR DOES NOT MENTION- THAT
WERE- THAT STOOD UP AND WERE
READY TO SUPPORT ENTREPRENEURS.
AROUND THE STATE AS ACCESS. AND
THIS THAT THIS GRANT PROGRAM.
I'M AND I'M IS IT YOUR MOTHER
PERSONALLY YOU. WE HAVE GREATLY
ENJOYED PART WITH YOU- ON
WEBINARS ABOUT ENGLISH AND
SPANISH. FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
IN YOUR DISTRICT I KNOW MY TEAM
I REALLY APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH YOUR TEAM AND WOULD LOVE
TO CONTINUE TO. THINK ABOUT
WAYS WE CAN SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SPONSORSHIP
OF SB SEVENTY FOUR I KNOW
THAT'S NOT THE- THE PURVIEW OF
THIS. SPECIFIC OVERSIGHT
HEARING BUT JUST MAKING SURE
THAT THAT CONVERSATION ABOUT
THE SCALE OF THE NEEDS
CONTINUES TO BE FRIENDS CENTERS
CRITICAL AND APPRECIATING YOUR-
YOUR QUESTIONS EARLIER ABOUT
HOW DO WE RIGHT SIZE THIS-PROBABLY PICKED THE RIGHT
NUMBER. AND BECAUSE THE NEED IS
JUST SO GREAT AND SO. WE
APPRECIATE THE SPEED THAT WERE
MOVING- AND APPRECIATE THINKING
ABOUT SCALE AND HOW DO WE GET.
TO A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
ACTUALLY MEET THE NEEDS OF
ENTREPRENEURS AROUND THE
COUNTRY. AND IN COLLABORATION
IS HUGE COLLABORATING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE CRAP OF POVERTY
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
WITH THE FIVE HUNDRED
DIFFERENT. ORGANIZATIONS.
AROUND THE STATE THAT WE ARE
PROUD TO BE A PART OF. IS
ESSENTIAL IN A MOMENT. I'M A AS
WE JUST TALKED THE SCALE WE
KNOW THAT NOT EVERY SMALL
BUSINESS. IS GOING TO GET A
GRANT- HAVE BUT WE KNOW THAT
MANY OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND WE SEE THAT FROM THE
DEMAND STILL NEED HELP. AT AND
ONE OF THE REALLY GREAT PARTS
OF THIS PROGRAM AND HOW IT WAS
DESIGNED. WAS TO DRIVE MANY
SMALL BUSINESSES. TO LOCAL
RESOURCE PROVIDERS THAT OFFER
FREE OR LOW COST SMALL BUSINESS
SUPPORT. AND EVEN IF THEY DON'T
GET A GRANT- WE KNOW THAT THEIR
HOPEFULLY GETTING CONNECTED
WITH. SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT CENTERS OR NON
PROFITS THAT SUPPORT
ENTREPRENEURS OR POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFIES THAT HAVE ACCESS TO
OTHER TYPES OF CAPITAL
PRODUCTS. TO HELP THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES. AND WE'RE PROUD TO
BE A PART OF THAT EFFORT TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE
PARTNERS. ARE DOING EVERYTHING
THAT WE CAN IN THIS MOMENT TO
MEET THE NEED A SMALL
BUSINESSES ACROS THE STATE-
AND SO PROUD OF THIS PROGRAM
THINK THAT PROGRAM DESIGN
ELEMENT IS RELEASED. AS
SIGNIFICANT AND IMPORTANT. TO
MAKE SURE THAT BUSINESSES
REGARDLESS OF WHETHER THEY GET
THE GRANT OR NOT. ARE GETTING
CONNECTED INTO THEIR LOCAL
SMALL BUSINESS ECOSYSTEM TO GET
THE HELP THAT THEY NEED. TO
HELP AND GIVE IT TO HELP THEM
THINK ABOUT HOW DID THEY
SURVIVE TO HELP THEM ACCESS TO
OTHER TYPES OF RESOURCES. AND
CAPITAL- THAT ARE OUT THERE AS
WELL SO. WE KNOW SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE FACING HUGE
CHALLENGES IN THIS MOMENT- THIS
PROPOSAL'S BOLD. WE APPRECIATE
THAT AND WE HOPE THEY CAN MOVE
QUICKLY AND NIMBLY- TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF SMALL BUSINESSES HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
APPRECIATE. AT THIS HEARING AND
THE. OVERSIGHT OF THIS ALL
IMPORTANT PROGRAM THANK YOU
VERY. AND YOU FOR YOUR THEIR
THE HELP THEM COLLABORATION
YOU'VE DONE WITH THIS GRANT
PROGRAM. OUR NEXT WE'D LIKE TO
HEAR FROM LUCY SALCEDO. CARTER
PUBLIC POLICY DIRECTOR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFITS WELCOME. THANK YOU
CHECK OUT BY IT ALL AND SENATOR
NELSON FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR TODAY I AM LUCY SALCEDO
CARTER THE PUBLIC POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT SO WE
CALL IT CAL NONPROFITS FOR
SHORT. CAL NONPROFITS IS A
POLICY ALLIANCE OF MORE THAN
TEN THOUSAND ORGANIZATIONS AND
THE VOICE OF CALIFORNIANS
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY. WE
ADVOCATE FOR POLICIES THAT
PROTECT AND PROMOTE THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR. WE ARE ALSO A
CONTRACTED APPLICATION PARTNER
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF
GRANTS PROGRAM IT'LL JUST CALL
THE RELIEF PROGRAM WE'RE GLAD
TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT
NONPROFITS APPLYING FOR THESE
GRANTS AND WE ALSO WANT TO
THANK DIRECTOR GOOSE MON FOR
HER LEADERSHIP IN MAKING THAT
HAPPEN. MY COMMENTS TODAY
REFLECT OUR EXPERIENCES IN THAT
ROLE AND THE FEEDBACK THAT WE
HAVE GOTTEN FROM HUNDREDS OF
NONPROFITS REGARDING THE
PROGRAM. OUR UNDERSTANDING OF
WHAT NONPROFITS NEED. ALSO
INFORMED BY THE KNOWLEDGE WE'VE
GAINED FROM SUPPORTING
CALIFORNIA NONPROFITS. THE
FEDERAL PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM PROCESS. YOU CAN. THIS
I. WHAT WHAT WILL BE PATIENT I
THINK SHE MAY COME BACK. THANK
HELLO. YEAH THE I FOCUSED
SPECIFICALLY. MS CARTER YOU
HAVE FROZEN ON OUR SCREEN. I
WANT TO FOCUS TO GET CAN YOU
HEAR ME I. I THINK YOU NEED TO
HANG UP AND CALL BACK AGAIN
YOUR LINE IS NOT GOOD. WELL
JUST A EVERY MINUTE. THEIR
EMAIL YOUR BASS I AM BACK. THIS
IS LUCY SALCEDO CARTER CAN YOU
ALL HEAR ME NOW WE CAN THANK
YOU FOR CALLING ACT YEAH THEY
HAVE BEEN TECHNOLOGY SPEAKING
OF TECHNOLOGY- SO I'LL CONTINUE
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE WHERE I
CUT OUT THAT- I'LL JUST MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT I WANTED TO
FOCUS SPECIFICALLY ON THE
NONPROFIT EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
PROGRAM- I WANNA SAY FIRST
THAT. WERE REALLY. GRATEFUL
THAT OUR PROFITS ARE INCLUDED
IN THE RELIEF PROGRAM- 98% OF
NONPROFITS ARE SMALL.
NONPROFITS LIKE SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE IMPORTANT JOB
CREATORS AND ECONOMIC
CONTRIBUTORS MANY NONPROFITS
ARE STRUGGLING TO STAY AFLOAT
DURING THE PANDEMIC AS YOU KNOW
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT WITH- SMALL
BUSINESSES AS WELL MANY ARE
RESPONDING TO INCREASED
COMMUNITY NEED WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. WHILE
OTHERS HAVE HAD TO CLOSE AND
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO OPEN AS MANY
AS A THIRD. THE RELIEF PROGRAM
GRANTS AREN'T LARGE BUT THEY
CAN BE A LIFELINE FOR
NONPROFITS AND YOU'VE SEEN THAT
INTEREST BY NONPROFITS IN THIS
GRANT OPPORTUNITY HAS BEEN
REMARKABLY STRONG. BUT THE
RELIEF PROGRAM APPLICATION
PROCESS HAS ALSO BEEN
DIFFICULT. FOR NONPROFITS IN A
NUMBER OF WAYS. FIRST ALTHOUGH
THERE ARE SEPARATE APPLICATIONS
FOR SMALL BUSINESSES AND
NONPROFITS MANY OF THE TERMS
USED IN THE NONPROFIT
APPLICATION ARE UNFAMILIAR OR
IRRELEVANT FOR NON PROFITS. FOR
EXAMPLE BECAUSE NONPROFIT
LEADERS ARE NOT CONSIDERED
OWNERS OF THE NONPROFIT. IT'S
BEEN VERY DIFFICULT FOR
NONPROFIT APPLICANTS TO
COMPLETE ANY OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT ASK ABOUT. ASK FOR OWNER
INFORMATION. SECONDLY SEVERAL
OF THE QUESTIONS THAT ASK
APPLICANTS TO CHOOSE AMONG A
FINITE SET OF BUSINESS TYPES OR
INDUSTRIES NONE OF WHICH ARE
RELEVANT FOR MOST NONPROFITS.
IT IT COMPELS NONPROFITS TO
SELECT AN INACCURATE ANSWER
THAT MIGHT AFFECT THEIR CHANCES
OF GETTING A GRANT- AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY CONCERNING- IF THESE
QUESTIONS ARE ABOUT
PRIORITIZING CERTAIN
INDUSTRIES- FOR ELIGIBILITY FOR
THE GRANT. SO IN ADDITION SOME
OF THE INFORMATION REQUIRED IN
THE APPLICATION IS INFORMATION
NON PROFITS ARE NOT ACCUSTOMED
PROVIDING ON GRANT APPLICATIONS
NONPROFIT LEADERS ARE NOT
TYPICALLY REQUIRED TO PROVIDE A
PERSONAL SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
AND DATE OF BIRTH OR BE SUBJECT
TO ANY KIND OF PERSONAL CREDIT
CHECK AS PART OF A- GRANT
APPLICATION PROCESS. A TAX ID
NUMBER FOR AN ORGANIZATION
WOULD BE MUCH BETTER CHOICE FOR
NONPROFITS AND WOULD GIVE A
MORE ACCURATE REPRESENTATION OF
THE NONPROFIT APPLICANT I'M AND
FINALLY SOME OF THE REQUIRED
DOCUMENTS ARE DIFFICULT FOR
NONPROFIT APPLICANTS TO OBTAIN
ON SHORT NOTICE. GIVEN THAT
THEY ARE NOT DOCUMENTS
TYPICALLY REQUIRED WHEN
NONPROFITS APPLY FOR GRANTS.
THE CERTIFICATE OF
INCORPORATION AS ONE EXAMPLE
NONPROFITS DON'T TYPICALLY HAVE
THAT AT THEIR FINGERTIPS. I DO
WANT TO SAY THAT WALK UP WITH
THAT AS WE HAVE RAISED THESE
ISSUES WITH THE INTERMEDIARY
L'INDUSTRIE. WE'VE GOTTEN
INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
NONPROFITS CAN COMPLETE SOME OF
THE DIFFICULT QUESTIONS AS WELL
AS WORK AROUNDS FOR SOME OF THE
OTHER REQUIREMENTS. BUT
NONPROFITS ARE ST STILL
STRUGGLING. TO FIT SQUARE PEGS
INTO ROUND HOLES. SOME OF THESE
CHALLENGES DISCOURAGE SOME NON
PROFITS FROM APPLYING AT ALL
FRANKLY SO- THEY SERVED AS A
AND UNINTENDED GATEKEEPING
FUNCTION THEY ALSO CAUSED UNDUE
STRESS FOR MANY WHO DID GO
THROUGH THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
AND APPLICATION PROCESS THAT
FAILS TO GIVE NONPROFITS A
CHANCE TO ACCURATELY DESCRIBE
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES AND NEEDS.
ALSO FAILS TO PROVIDE THE BEST
INFORMATION FOR ASSESSING WHICH
ORGANIZATIONS SHOULD RECEIVE A
GRANT. THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
ACCOUNT ON PROFITS HAS
ADVOCATED FOR RELIEF PROGRAMS
FOR NON PROFITS COMPARABLE TO
THE RELIEF PROGRAMS FOR PROFIT
ENTITIES. WORK FOR CALIFORNIA'S
NONPROFITS IS VITAL FOR THE
STATE'S SERVICES SUPPLY CHAIN
FOR ITS JOB MARKET AND FOR THE
ECONOMY. THE SECTOR IS THE
FOURTH LARGEST EMPLOYER BY
INDUSTRY IN THE STATE AND
GENERATES 15% OF THE GROSS
STATE PRODUCT. THE STATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COUNTY NONPROFITS
TO PROVIDE A VARIETY OF STATE
SERVICE OF VITAL SERVICES THE
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING THIRTY
TWO PERCENT. OF MEDICAL
SERVICES. NONPROFITS ARE ON THE
GROUND IN AND PART OF
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE
CURRENT AMOUNT ALLOCATED FOR
THE RELIEF PROGRAM AS WELL AS
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT IS NOT
ENOUGH BY A LONG MEASURE TO
ADDRESS THE FINANCIAL NEEDS OF
NONPROFIT SMALL BUSINESSES IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. THE
MAGNITUDE OF THE NEED IS CLEAR
EVEN JUST FROM THE THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND APPLICANTS THAT WE'VE
HAD IN THE FIRST ROUND. HELLO
PROFITS IS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
ADDITIONAL STATE RESOURCES FOR
RELIEF PROGRAMS FOR NONPROFITS
AND SMALL BUSINESSES. AND WE
SUPPORT THE- THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDS IN THE- GOVERNOR'S-
PROPOSED BUDGET AS WELL AS SB
SEVENTY FOUR. GOING FORWARD
HOWEVER RELIEF PROGRAMS SHOULD
HAVE A DISTINCT APPLICATION.
PROCESS FOR NON PROFITS. THAT
REFLECTS THE NONPROFIT
EXPERIENCE INCLUDING
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE
MISSION APPLICATION QUESTIONS
SHOULD ALLOW NONPROFITS TO
ACCURATELY DESCRIBE THEIR
FINANCIAL CONDITIONS AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THEY MAKE TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND LOCAL
ECONOMIES. THE SMALL SIZE OF
THE CURRENT PROGRAMS GRANTS
ALSO WARRANTS A SIMPLER APPLET
APPLICATION PROCESS FRANKLY-
FOR ALL NONPROFITS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES. THAT SIMPLE OUR
APPLICATION PROCESS WILL BE
LESS WORK FOR EVERYONE
INCLUDING FOUR L'INDUSTRIE AND
CALLOW SPLA. SO FINALLY I JUST
WANT ALSO- MAKE A POINT THAT
OTHERS HAVE MADE AS WELL
PROGRAM DATA IS NEEDED THE
PROGRAM DATA THAT HIGHLIGHTS
THE NUMBER AND PERCENTAGE OF
NONPROFIT GRANT RECIPIENTS
WOULD REALLY BE HELPFUL
INCLUDING THEIR DEMOGRAPHIC AND
GEOGRAPHIC INFORMATION SO THAT
WE CAN UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THE PROGRAM IS REACHING
NONPROFITS AND THE COMMUNITIES
IN MOST NEED SO WITH THAT I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
APOLOGIES FOR THE TECHNOLOGY
AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND- AND YOUR
PERSISTENCE AS WELL FOR JOINING
US BACK AGAIN HE MADE SOME
REALLY GOOD POINTS I GUESS SOME
LET ME START OFF WITH- YOU MISS
CARTER- YOU RAISE SOME REALLY
GOOD ISSUES- AND I'M WONDERING.
IF YOU HAVE AN IDEA BASED ON
THE WORK THAT YOU'VE DONE ABOUT
HOW MUCH MONEY WE NEED IN THE
POT FOR NON PROFITS IN ORDER
FOR US TO I YOU KNOW BEST CASE
SCENARIO- JUST. I GUESS PART OF
THE CHALLENGE THAT I HAVE IS
THAT WE ALWAYS SEEM TO BE
WORKING IN A VACUUM AND WE WERE
NOT REALLY SURE THAT THE DATA
WE HAVE IN REGARDS TO LANDLORD
TENANT SMALL BUSINESSES- THAT
THAT WE HAVE A NUMBER THAT WE
CAN FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THE
DO YOU HAVE A NUMBER IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBER OF- OF THEM
NONPROFITS THAT THAT YOU THINK
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS KIND
OF A GRANT PROGRAM. AND SHOULD
BE. EVEN IF IT'S AS I REMEMBER
I JUST. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE REALLY APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS
PROGRAM IS THAT- THEY'RE A LOT
THERE ARE A LOT OF NON PROFITS
THAT ARE ALSO ALL VOLUNTEER BUT
THEY PROVIDE CRITICAL SERVICES
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT THIS
PROGRAM INCLUDES VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATIONS OF PPP FOR
EXAMPLE. THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM DOES DOES
NOT ALSO INCLUDE AND VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATIONS SO I MEAN IT-
DIRECTOR GOOSE MON MENTIONED A
HUNDRED AND FORTY THOUSAND
NONPROFITS- IN THAT FIT IN THE
CATEGORIES THAT ARE ELIGIBLE SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
CONSIDERABLE NUMBER. I MEAN ONE
WAY WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT IT IS
WE COULD TAKE A PERCENTAGE OF
THE OVERALL FUNDS AND SET THEM
ASIDE FOR NON PROFITS WE ARE
PROPOSES THE NUMBER 15% BECAUSE
WE CONTRIBUTE. 15% THE STATE
GROSS PRODUCT- SO THAT'S JUST
ONE. ONE THING TO CONSIDER- BUT
THE VAST MAJORITY OF NONPROFITS
ARE STRUGGLING- YOU KNOW SO
COMPARABLE TO SMALL THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMUNITY- AND IT IT I
THINK IT WAS SENATOR SKINNER
WHO POINTED OUT THAT THE
COMMUNITY IS VERY VERY. BUT
EVEN- PROFITS THAT ARE
PROVIDING ESSENTIAL SERVICES
ARE BEING TAXED- BY THE NEEDS
OF THEIR COMMUNITIES AND NOT
ALWAYS GETTING THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED TO PROVIDE THOSE
SERVICES SO- SO I CAN'T GIVE
YOU WHAT YOU KNOW AND- A-
DOLLAR AMOUNT TO BUT- BUT I DID
PROPOSE A PERCENTAGE AND I.
WOULD BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
THINK ABOUT THIS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND OF COURSE BE
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHERS. WHAT
WELL THAT WAY OF ANALYZING IT
IS REALLY HELPFUL BECAUSE IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO COME UP WITH
A NUMBER BUT- 15% THAT'S
RELATED. TO THE CONTRIBUTION TO
THE ECONOMY MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE TO ME AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT CREATIVE
OUTSIDE IT RIGHT OUTSIDE OF THE
BOX- AT THINKING AND THEN- I
GUESS THAT THE OTHER PART WOULD
BE- ARE YOU WILLING TO WORK ON
A APPLICATION THAT YOU THINK
WOULD. WOULD MORE
APPROPRIATELY. CAPTURED THAT.
THE DATA THAT WOULD BE NEEDED.
FOR THIS KIND OF A PROGRAM. IF
THIS PROGRAM MOVES FORWARD AND
THERE'S MORE MONEY PUT IN I
THINK I THINK I THINK THERE'S-
VERY GREAT CONCERN OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT WE DO WHATEVER
WE CAN TO. JUMPSTART THE
ECONOMY AND THIS IS ONE WAY TO
DO IT IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE-
PROVIDE AN ELEMENT TO
SURVIVABILITY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES IN THE NONPROFIT SO.
SO I SEE THIS MOVING FORWARD I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE
THE BEST PROGRAM IN THAT WERE
REALLY CAPTURING DATA THAT WE
NEED. TO MAKE GOOD DECISIONS.
SO THE QUESTION WOULD BE- I
WOULD BE HONORED YOUR
SUGGESTIONS THAT. THAT THE
APPLICATION BE MUCH MORE
TAILORED TOWARDS THE NONPROFIT
WORLD HAVING RUN A NONPROFIT
FOR SIX YEARS I HAVE. A REAL
SENSITIVITY TO THAT AND IF YOU
HAVE TO TRY TO EXPLAIN WHAT YOU
DO. IN LITTLE CHECK BOXES YOU
KIND OF LOSE. LOSE THE IMPACT
OF THE WORK THAT YOU AS A
NONPROFIT DO SO- I. WOULD BE
HONORED TO PARTICIPATE AND
WORKING ON MAKING AN
APPLICATION THAT IS REALLY.
MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR NONPROFITS
AND REFLECTS THE WONDERFUL WORK
THEY DO IN THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THEY MAKE THAT'S VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND- A QUESTION FOR MARKER
BURKE I APPRECIATED THE
COMMENTS. ABOUT THE POLLING
INFORMATION THAT YOU PROVIDED
IT IS EXCELLENT- IT'S- THERE.
AS I SAY SOMETIMES WE- WE
STRUGGLE BECAUSE WE JUST DON'T
GET THE GOOD GOOD DATA ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING OUT IN THE
WORLD WE- GET VIGNETTES FROM.
SMALL BUSINESSES. CALLING US
AND HAVING CONVERSATIONS AND
FROM DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS-
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE IN IN- IN THAT HELPING TO.
HELPING TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
CAN SURVIVE AND REOPEN EVEN IF
THEY'VE HAD TO CHANGE THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL- TOUGH TIME
SOMETIMES. IS IT IS CREATES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR INVENTION- IT
WILL BE WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING
WITH HOW MUCH. WE NEED TO PUT
IN THIS PART DO YOU HAVE AN
IDEA OF. FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
WHAT THE NEED IS AND WHAT IS AN
APPROPRIATE NUMBER THAT THAT.
WE SHOULD BE STRIVING FOR MEN
AGAIN WE'VE GOT A LOT OF A LOT
OF NEEDS IN THE STATE THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO MAKE SOME TOUGH CHOICES
BUT I'M TRYING TO. GET MY HEAD
AROUND WHAT. WHAT SHOULD WE BE
LOOKING. TO PUT INTO THIS INTO
THIS RESOURCE. IT IS A VERY
CHALLENGING QUESTION AT
APPRECIATE THAT CENTER AND
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR THIS
HEARING- I'D BE HAPPY TO IT TO
COME BACK TO YOU WITH SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS JUST BASED ON
WHAT WE'VE SEEN- THROUGH A PPP
DOLLARS THAT HIT THE MARKET IN
THE SUMMER ALL RIGHT I THINK IT
WAS ALMOST A HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLARS IN PPP AND I'D ALL. THE
**** LIKE SIXTY EIGHT IN B. B.
B. AND ANOTHER THIRTY SOMETHING
IN IN IDLE- AND MANY OF THOSE
BUSINESSES MAY NOT MAKE IT AND
SO I THINK THAT THE SHEER SCALE
AND WE THINK ABOUT HALF OUR
ECONOMY- AND THIS SIZE. RIGHT
HALF OF THE PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYMENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE STRUGGLING AS
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THOSE ARE
ARE HAVING CHALLENGES AND
BRIGHT SOME OF OUR POLLING
SHOWS THAT. 60% HAVE NOT
REHIRED- BACK TO THE PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS SO WE KNOW THAT
THE DATE IS TELLING US THE
SCALE IS SOMETHING WE'VE QUITE
HONESTLY NOT SEEN BEFORE AND SO
BEING ABLE TO RIGHT SIZE THE
SOLUTION IS CHALLENGING I'M
HAPPY TO PROVIDE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW WE THINK
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO GET THERE-
BUT I THINK AT THIS MOMENT MORE
THAN ANYTHING IS. HOW CAN WE
MOVE QUICKLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
AS BUSINESSES ARE HANGING ON
THAT WE NEED THEM WHERE WE ARE
OUR MAIN CONCERN IS THAT AS
TIME GOES BY MORE AND MORE
BUSINESSES JUST CAN'T HANG ON
ANYMORE- AND WE'RE CREATING A
SCENARIO WHERE IN THE SPRING I
WE'RE GONNA HAVE. A LOT OF
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE FAILED IN
THE QUESTION IS AND WHAT DOES
THAT DO TO OUR NEIGHBORHOODS
AND WHAT DOES THAT DO TO OUR
ECONOMY. AND TILT. BIGGER IS
BETTER HE INTO OF. SILVA AND
WE'RE- THAT FEDERAL. HAS
FINALISED IN- BUT REALLY THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE STATE TO MAKE
THIS POSSIBLE. IS I IS SUCH A-
IT'S SUCH A HUGE STEP FORWARD.
I'M SO HAPPY TO PROVIDE SOME
ADDITIONAL DETAIL FOR ALL HAPPY
TO PASS ALONG THE POLLING THAT
WE JUST RELEASED THAT I
REFERENCED- BUT ALSO AT THIS
SCALE IS SO BIG. IT'S HARD TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT WHAT A RIGHT
SIZE SOLUTION BE WHEN YOU THINK
OF THE CONTEXT OF WHAT THE
STATE HAS ALREADY RECEIVED IN
FEDERAL RELIEF. BUT WHAT THE
NEED IS AND THEN I THINK THE
REAL QUESTION IS- AS AS A
CENTER SKINNER AND IS YOU ALSO-
I'M SURE I'VE HAD MENTIONED IS
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
TARGETED THE BUSINESSES THAT.
NEED IT THE MOST- AND THAT'S
WHAT THE SCORING CRITERIA THAT-
CALLOUSED BA AND L'INDUSTRIE
PUT TOGETHER SO EFFECTIVE TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT ARE THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF POWER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. HOW DO WE TARGET
THOSE BUSINESSES IN COMMUNITIES
THAT HAVE HAD STAYED HOME
ORDERS. THAT HAVE BEEN UNIQUELY
IMPACTED- BY THE PANDEMIC I
WHERE THE INDUSTRIES- WHO WHO
ARE UNDER A RESOURCE OPTION
ENTREPRENEURS THAT WE NEED TO
SERVE. ALL THOSE SCORING
CRITERIA ARE ABOUT PRIORITIZING
THE BUSINESSES. THAT HAVE
TRADITIONALLY BEEN LEFT BEHIND
OR WHO MAY NOT HAVE RECEIVED AS
MUCH OF THE FEDERAL LEAF- BUT
THE WHOLE BUT IN TERMS OF SCALE
IF YOU NEED HELP. AND HOW MUCH
HELP IS NEEDED AND IS- IT IS
SIGNIFICANT AND BIGGER THAN-
THAT WE SEEN AND SO AGAIN. SO
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR
LEGISLATION TO CONTINUE TO
DRIVE THE CONVERSATION- TWO
BIGGER AND BOULDER PLACES AND
SB SEVENTY FOUR AND- PLEASE LET
US KNOW HOW WE CAN HELP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. AND THAT'S THE
REASON FOR THE QUESTION IS.
WHAT SHOULD THE NUMBER BE
APPRECIATE THAT. CENTER NEAL-
MISSED WHETHER FOR YOU'RE STILL
THERE. THE- CONCERN I HAVE
AGAIN IS WITH THOSE SMALL
BUSINESSES THEY'RE ON THE BRINK.
AND I'M FEARFUL THAT WE ARE NOT
KEEPING CLOSE ENOUGH TRACK. ON
THE BIG PICTURE HERE AS IT
EVOLVES AND MAYBE SOMETIMES
DEVOLVES WE HAVE TO BE
CONCERNED I HAD LUNCH MONDAY AT
A LITTLE RESTAURANT IN THE
REASON BASEBALL TOWN. THERE WAS
NOBODY IN THAT RESTAURANT. EVEN
NOW. AND THAT REALLY ALARMING
IT'S A MOTHER AND HER DAUGHTER.
IN THE STRUGGLING TO SURVIVE
AND THEY ARE ON THE BRINK. AND
I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK THE
THING WILL. ARE YOU TO MISTER
WHETHER FOR ARE YOU A KEEP AN
EYE ON THESE. FAILURE ISN'T AND
HOW MUCH HOW CLOSE TO THE BREAK
SOME ARE AND HOW WE CAN
REDIRECT MONEY TO THEM AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN. JUST TO KEEP
THEM GOING THIS IS- NOT JUST
LONG TERM THIS IS. IMMEDIATE
AND URGENT AND WE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE A BIG PROGRAM ANNOUNCED
THAT IS BUT A FALSE HOPE. ARE
WE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY. SUFFICIENTLY THE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND RECRUITING
DIRECT RESOURCES TO THEM
QUICKLY. WELL WE CERTAINLY ARE
KEEPING AN EYE ON THE- THE
GENERAL ECONOMIC SITUATION I
THINK GETTING DATA- AT THE
LEVEL YOU'RE SUGGESTING. IS
VERY DIFFICULT AND A PROGRAM
SUCH AS AS THIS ONE- WHERE IT'S
WHO WORDS REQUESTING- THE
BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE THEIR-
THEIR THEIR ACTUAL DECLINE IN
REVENUE- I THINK LATER IN IN-
IN THE COMING WEEKS ALSO HEAR
ABOUT THE MAIN STREET HIRING
TAX CREDIT PROGRAM WHICH ALSO-
TRACKS- DECLINES IN REVENUE
AND- PROVIDES RELIEF BASED ON
THAT. IS A LITTLE BIT MORE
EFFECTIVE SO WE ARE TRYING TO
GET THE DATA THAT IS AVAILABLE.
HE POINTED MANY OF BUSINESSES-
ARE AFFECTED- MORE THAN AND-
THE EXTENT WE CAN OUR PROGRAM
TO THOSE- ON YOUR DEPEND IF IT
DOESN'T MOST OF IS PROBABLY THE
BEST USE OF THE LIVE AMOUNT OF
RESOURCE. WELL IT SEEMS TO BE
OUT NOT VERY THAT YOU HAVE MADE.
LEAD OFFICE THAT. THIS SEPARATE
MAY NOT HAVE RECEIVED IMPACT ON.
X. ON WHAT OF DATA. OR BACK
DOORS DID THE ANALYST BAY THAT
THAT WE HAVE LITTLE. ON THE- SO
THIS ECONOMY IS X. LARGE AND-
SO EXAMPLE- IS MORE CURRENT
MENTIONED- THE FEDERAL THE
FIRST ROUND AND- PEOPLE LEARNS
ABOUT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
THE- THE IDEA ALONE- ASSISTANCE
WAS- AROUND THIRTY BILLION-
THIS- PASSAGE TO ADDITION
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE BUSINESS
IS JUST. X. LIMITED IN
COMPARISON TO THAT- THAT CITED
THE BUSINESS RECEIVE THE
ASSISTANCE- I OFTEN MUCH
SMALLER THEN- THE BUSINESS AND
CERTAIN AFFECTS THEM- BENEFITS
INTO LEVEL MUCH BUT THIS OF OUR
OF OUR MULTI TRILLION DOLLAR
STATE ECONOMY IT'S JUST REAL
SMALL. WHAT MADE UNDER SAME
CLASS FOR THE OF FROM. THE IS
THE OF FINANCE SAYS TO THESE
THIS AND DOES. UP AND OF- ALEX
THE- GETTING SO OF THE SMALLER
BUSINESS. VERY VERY SOON
SILICON HAVE THEM THE M. OF THE
POOREST IF YOU WERE THEN GOING
OUT OF I SAY GOING TO SAY THEM.
AND GET THEM ACCOUNTS. SANDRA
UNTIL THE OVERALL ECONOMY ZIPS
UP BUT- THIS IS PART OF
FINANCIAL THE SENSE FOR ARE YOU
SENSE OF TO THIS. UP IF WILL.
PLEASE THANK YOU YES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS CENTER
TO THE NEEDS OF THIS BUSINESS-
AND TRYING TO KEEP THEM GOING-
YOU KNOW ON THE ECONOMY
RECOVERY UNTIL WE HAVE A WIDE
OUT ABOUT ROLE OUT- AND LIKE
THAT SO WE ARE TO- THANK YOU
SAID FORCE HO KEEP THAT LIGHT
ON I KEEP PEOPLE AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE- TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE. WELL RIGHT NOW THE
WHAT THEY- IS. A RAY OF. BUT
THEY NOT NEED OF PROMISE. THE
DOES NOT DELIVER. NOT THIS IS A
BIG THE- HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF BILLS AND STATE. A GOOD FOR
OF THEM ARE OF GREAT SOMEONE
MAY SOME OF THEM. RE MINOR. BUT
IS IMPORTANT FOR A THE NOT ALL
THEM FALSE HOPE. SO I WOULD ASK
THAT YOU BE VERY STEADIER. AND
ENSURING THAT MONIES GET THEM.
S. AS POSSIBLE. AND ONE ON AS
WELL OR RATHER CLASS. ARE THERE
A LOT OF THE REPORT AND THAT
CAN. IMPEDIMENTS ARE DEMAND ON
THESE THAT IT IS HARD FOR THEM
TO GET THAT DATA TOGETHER TO
SUBMIT TO THE GRANTING AGENCIES
AND DEPARTMENTS. THE RED TAPE
IN OTHER WORDS. SEVENTY TIME
HAPPY TO JUMP IN AT THE WELCOME
AS WE BELIEVE SO WE BELIEVE
THAT WE PUT A CONTROL THAT WERE
CAN THE NEW FOR EXT. OUT TO GET
THESE FUN OUT- BUT STILL HAVE
CONTROLS- TO LIMIT THE FRAUD
WASTE AND ABUSE AND SO YOU'RE
COMING UP WITH EITHER YOUR TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN OR NINETEEN
TAX RETURNS AND PROVIDING SOME
BASIC INFORMATION IN TERMS OF
YOUR- YOU KNOW ANY ANY
ESTABLISH SECRETARY OF STATE OR
LOCAL LICENSES IS REALLY
SHOULDN'T BE UNREASONABLE- AND
THIS IS PUBLIC BENEFITS THIS IS
A PUBLIC FUNDS AND SO WE HAVE
TO BE PRUDENT. AND ENSURE THAT
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION I IS
TRACK SO THAT WE CAN LIMIT FIVE
WAYS TO BE SO I DON'T I DON'T
BELIEVE SO I THINK THAT IT WAS
A SIMPLE PROGRAM BALANCED WITH-
THE NEED FOR BOTH. IN CONTROL
AS WELL AS SIMPLY FOR THE-BUSINESS. THANK YOU AND GOOD
ONE MORE QUESTION. IN THE-
OPERATOR OF THE YOUR FOR.
AGENTS THE ALL IS SMALL THAT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY RECALL. UNDER
MINUTES LOCK FOR PROMULGATING
REGULATE TO DO WHAT NEED TO DO.
OR CAN YOU THE EFFECT BY EIGHT.
MOVE AHEAD. IS THERE A
REGULATORY YOU HAVE GOT TO GO
THROUGH TO GET MONEY SENT OUT.
WE HAVE A THE PAST ON UNDER PRO
ON RULES OF EXAMPLE ON A TWO
SAYS EXPAND PROGRAM- ON ON THIS
ONE OF THE WE THE- INTO OUT AND
RULES ENGAGEMENT WITHIN THE ARE
PROCESS. THE REQUESTED PROCESS
WHERE WE DEFINED ELIGIBILITY WE
DEFINE PRIORITIES WE DEFINE DAD
TIMING EXCEPT. AND I TREAT YOU
WITH AND YOUR HIGH ALREADY YOUR
FOR ORGANIZATION AS A ALL
AGENCIES GOVERNMENT. THE BEAVER
OPEN AND- WITH THE LEGISLATURE.
FILL THAT WE CAN HAVE RIGHT IN.
TO THE PEOPLE WE READ. AND THEM
NOT BE FOR HOPE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU MUCH-
AND I WANTED IT THAT PART AS A
PAN ON PANEL APPRECIATE YOUR I
THINK THE YOU MAY MY OF YOU MAY
AROUND FOR THE PANEL I LOOKING
TO IF. BUT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON
TO PASS NUMBER TWO AT SO YOU
THANK YOU VERY. AND THIS IS THE
GOLDEN STATE STEMMING- DISCUSS
I AM I'D LIKE TO. CALL ON JANE
J. CHAMBER. THE CHEAP UP FRONT
READ APART OF FINANCE. I WOULD
START WITH YOU. THIS. SO I HAD
TO NAME ST JAMES PARTNER
FINANCE SO THE GOLD STREET IS A-
THAT AIMS TO QUICKLY MONEY THE
PARK OF THE GROUP OF CAL. ALSO
ZERO TWENTY TWENTY UNDER THIS
PROPOSAL THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE WOULD BASED ON
INFORMATION PROVIDED BY THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. EITHER
SEND CHECKS TO OR MAKE DIRECT
DEPOSITS INTO ACCOUNTS OF
TAXPAYERS RECEIVE THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT FOR THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TAX YEAR IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. IN ADDITION
TAXPAYERS WITH INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS WHO
QUALIFY FOR THE EITC FOR
CALIFORNIA IF YOU SEE IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TEXTURE WHICH IS
THE FIRST YEAR THERE THE
BEATLES BEFORE THE ATC THEY
WILL ALSO RECEIVE A SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR. A TAX REFUND. FOR THE
MAJORITY OF TAXPAYERS WITH
SINCE I WAS NINETEEN. EATER DC
THE PAYMENTS WOULD GO OUT OF
WITHIN THREE TO FOUR WEEKS
AFTER ENACTMENT- HELLO
ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS TO THE
SENATORS GOING ON THROUGHOUT
THE YEAR- AND FOR THE TWENTY
TWENTY TAX YOUR ITIN FILERS OF
THEIR PAYMENTS WOULD GO OUT-
SHORTLY AFTER THE FINAL WINNER
THERE A TWENTY TWENTY TAX
RETURN. IN TOTAL THIS PROGRAMS
IS EXPECTED TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE CASH ASSISTANCE TO
ROUGHLY FOUR MILLION LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS. SO THAT
CONCLUDES MY PREPARED COMMENTS
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE COMMENTS AND
I ALSO WANT TO MENTION YOU ARE
NET COMMITTEE FROM THE- FOR
LEGISLATIVE. SERVICES DIRECTOR
FOR THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD IS
ALSO AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT.
ABOUT THE IMPLEMENTATION
PROGRAM. VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- I'D LIKE TO INVITE
THAT CASH ALAMO THE PRINCIPLE
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE. THANK YOU TRAVIS ALLEN-
WITH THE L. A. L. OUR OFFICE
PRODUCED A BRIEF ANALYSIS OF
THE GOVERNOR'S GOLD STATES TO
MOST PROPOSAL TODAY ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS WELL AS
A PARTS I'LL BE WORKING LARGELY
OFF OF THAT BUT JUST A FEW
BRIEF COMMENTS- AS WE ALL KNOW
THE- EFFECT OF THE PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN WIDESPREAD AFFECTING. ALL
WORKERS IN AND ALL OF US- BUT
OBVIOUSLY IT'S BECOME CLEAR
THAT THE EFFECTIVE
DISPROPORTIONATELY- ON LOW WAY
WORKERS PARTY OF THE INTO AT
THE MOST OF TYPE HEALTH ORDER.
AT THE SAME TIME THE COST FOR
SAYS AND FOR ARE SPEND MORE AND
ARE THEY SPEND MORE TIME WITH.
FOR- THROUGHOUT THE PANDEMIC
HELLO ARMENPRESS FEDERAL LEAVE.
HAVE A- MOST AND- AND THAT THE
JEWS HAVE ALL. BRING UP OUR
FIRST FOREMOST- ENHANCED PLAN
INSURANCE BENEFITS. ARE THERE
WERE INCLUDED IN PART OF THE
CARES ACT- AS AN EXAM OF A
MINIMUM WAGE WORKER. WHO BECAME
UNEMPLOYED AND RECEIVE HESE
RIGHT BUT IF IT'S A TYPICALLY
EARNED. ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY DOLLARS A WEEK AND WAY.
ON AND UNDER THE IN BENEFITS
I'LL- IN THE SPRING AND SUMMER
WAS RECEIVING ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY DOLLARS IN
WEEKLY ALIVE BENEFITS. AND
WOULD RECEIVE ABOUT FIVE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY. OUR A WEEK
YOU LIVE. ARE THE REASON
FEDERAL. ON IN THE AS A LAWSUIT
OF UP MAGNITUDE THE U. I.
BENEFITS ADDITIONALLY- THE TWO
ROUNDS OF FEDERAL STIMULUS
TRACKS ARE THEY'RE GONNA HAVE
TO FAMILIES HAVE GREATLY HELPED.
STABILIZE MOST HOUSEHOLDS
FAMILY INCOMES ON BUT- WHILE
THESE PROGRAMS HAVE HELPED MOST
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIAN
HOUSEHOLDS ARE UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS IN PARTICULAR HAVE NOT
BEEN ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
ASSISTANCE TO THESE FEDERALLY
PROGRAMS ON AND MINDFUL OF THAT
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE TOOK
TWO ACTIONS TO SUPPORT THIS
GROUP OF WORKERS OUR FIRST
CREATING THE DISASTER RELIEF
ASSISTANCE FOR IMMIGRANTS
PROGRAM A GRANT PROGRAM FOR
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS. IN THE
SPRING AND SUMMER OF LAST YEAR
AND AS WELL EXPANDING THE
CALIFORNIA EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT TO BE AVAILABLE TO A TO
TAX FILERS WHO FILE USING-
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER OF
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS A HIGH TECH-
ABOUT HALF OF THE STATE'S
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS FILE STATE
TAXES USING AND HIGH TECH- I
WON'T GO THROUGH THE SPECIFICS
OF IT THE PROPOSAL ITSELF IS
RESEARCHING WIND AND ALL MOVE
FORWARD DIRECTLY TO SORT OF OUR
ASSESSMENT AND NOT RAISED A
COUPLE OF POINTS OUT THE FIRST
IS THAT. GENERALLY SPEAKING
USING ONE TIME FUNDS- FOR
PANDEMIC LEAVE AT THIS POINT
MAKES SENSE- THE STATE IS THAT
RECEIVER ONE TIME REVENUE
WINDFALL. FALL BY YOURS AS WE
ESTIMATE OF. BUDGET STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS AND SO USING ONE TIME
RESOURCES NOW OPT FOR ONE TIME
RELIEF EFFORTS FIX FISCAL
SENSE. I'M BUT THE SAME TIME.
THE PAYMENT SOME DON'T. ARE
LIKELY TO BE A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC RECOVERY- AND THIS
ISN'T. I JUST THINK THE PROGRAM
ITSELF IS JUST A- RECOGNITION
THAT AFTER TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL IS
RELATIVELY SMALL IN THE CONTEXT
OF THE OVERALL STATE ECONOMY I
REPRESENTS ABOUT ONE TENTH OF
1% OF THE STATE'S ECONOMY. ON
THE THIRD POINT. IS SORT OF
RELATED TO THE SECOND THAT WE
POINT OUT IN OUR ASSESSMENT IS
THAT BECAUSE THAT IS THE
STIMULUS EFFECT ISN'T FIRST AND
FOREMOST- ONE OF THE KEY GOALS
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. OUT
WE POINT OUT THAT INSTEAD
FOCUSING ON FILLING IN THE GAPS
WERE FEDERAL LEAVE HAS NOT BEEN
AVAILABLE I SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE STATE. OF WHICH HE'S
FUNDS. AND AS SUCH IT'S NOT
CLEAR TO OUR OFFICE THEY'RE
PRIORITIZING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN. CAL E. I. T. C.
RECIPIENTS- ON IS THAT THE BEST
APPROACH AT THIS TIME IN PART
BECAUSE MANY OF THESE WORKERS
THOUGH CERTAINLY SOME OF WHOM
HAVE SUFFERED JOB LOSSES DURING
THE PANDEMIC. HAVE BEEN
ELIGIBLE FOR THE FEDERAL
PROGRAMS I MENTIONED BEFORE AND
THOSE FROM THE PROGRAMS ARE
WILL HELP STABILIZE THESE
HOUSEHOLD INCOME- ADDITIONALLY
THERE ARE SOME OTHER
LIMITATIONS USING THE KEPT THE
EITC TARGETING MECHANISM- FIRST
AND FOREMOST THAT ABOUT 20% OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE ELIGIBLE
TO RECEIVE THE EITC DO NOT
CLAIM IT AND SO USING THIS
MECHANISM WOULDN'T REACH THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS AND SECONDARILY. ON
THE KEY ADVANTAGES OF THE EITC
FROM A RESEARCH STANDPOINT-
FIRST AND FOREMOST THAT THEY'RE
PROVIDES WORK AND EDUCATIONAL
AND SOME HEALTH BENEFITS TO THE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT THE RECEIVE THE
CALIFORNIA E. I. T. C. DON'T
NECESSARILY EXTEND TO THIS
PROGRAM THAT'S BECAUSE IT'S A
ONE TIME PAYMENT- IT ALSO
DOESN'T VARY WITH INCOME AS THE
EITC DOES IN ITS ONGOING
FORMULATION ARE RATHER
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSED TO USE
THE I. T. ACT YOU SEE SORT OF
AS A WAY TO IDENTIFY THESE
HOUSEHOLDS RATHER THAN. AS A
WAY TO FURTHER OF THE BENEFITS.
OF THE EITC PROGRAM ITSELF. I'M
SORRY THINK. YOU FOR WITH A RED.
WE NOW A GOOD TIME TO LET COMES
CONSIDER OTHER APPROACHES TO
INTERVIEW THE SORT OF ONE OVER
ARCHING QUESTION THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER AS
IT AS IT CONTEMPLATES THIS. AND
THAT IS WHAT'S THE BEST WAY TO
HELP LOW IN CALIFORNIA LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AT THIS
TIME. I'M ON ON PAGE OF OUR
HAND I WILL SEVERAL QUESTIONS I
WILL GO THROUGH THEM IN
PARTICULAR BUT WE USE THESE
QUESTIONS OF A FILTERING
PROCESS TO. HELP IDENTIFY
GROUPS THAT THE STATE COULD ARE
MOST. OF PRIORITIZE FUNDS FOR
AT THIS POINT IN THE FIRST
QUESTION. IS SIMPLY WHO HAS
BENEFITED LEAST FROM FEDERALLY
EFFORTS GIVEN THE MAGNITUDE OF.
THE FEDERALLY- RAMS ADVANCED
SUCH A AND DOWN THE CAMP. I
BEGINNING ON PAGE OF OUR HAND
OUT OUTLAW AN APPROACH ALLEGE
COULD CONSIDER AN WE CALLED HIM
HARD AT A RELATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON JUST A
FEW BRIEF COMMENTS ON THIS
APPROACH. IN ESSENCE- BECAUSE
ON. WORKERS HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT JOB LOSSES BUT NOT
BENEFITTED FROM FEDERAL INCOME
SUPPORT THE LEGISLATURE COULD
NARROW THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
TO PROVIDE A LARGER BENEFIT SO
LARGER THAN THE SIX HUNDRED
DOLLAR ONE TIME. I'M TO A
SMALLER GROUP OF WORKERS-
SPECIFICALLY I TEN FILERS WHO
ARE UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR FEDERAL
BENEFITS- THEY ARE TARGETED
APPROACH SUCH AS THIS WOULD GET.
I'M MONEY OUT SOMEWHAT FASTER
THAN THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
FOR I. TEN FILERS BECAUSE WE
PROPOSE TO. MAKE THESE PAYMENTS
AVAILABLE TO I. TEN FILERS
BASED ON THEIR TWENTY NINETEEN
FILING STATUS I WHICH WOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO GO OUT IMMEDIATELY
RATHER THAN WAITING FOR TAX
FILERS TO FILE THEIR TWENTY
TWENTY TAXES AND THEN ISSUE THE
PAYMENTS. I'M HAVING TROUBLE OF
A MORE TARGETED APPROACH THE
STATE COULD PROVIDE A LARGER
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DOLLAR REFUND
PER I. TEN ADULT BYLER. WITHIN
AND WITH INCOME BELOW THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS- THIS IS
JUSTIN HOLLISTER ILLUSTRATIVE
EXAMPLE OUT WE THINK THIS. TYPE%
OF EXAMPLE WOULD COST SOMEWHERE
IN THE RANGE OF. SEVEN HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS. ON BECAUSE THIS AMOUNT
IS SMALLER. THAN THE GOVERNOR'S
TO FOUR BILL DOLLARS. WE WOULD-
SELECTS TO CONSIDER USING.
REMAINING FUNDS TO TARGET ONE
TIME PAYMENTS FOR OTHER LOW
INCOME GROUPS ON. FIRST ON THAT
LIST FOR OUR. OFFICE- WOULD BE
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS DO FILE
TAX USING AN ITEM. ON SIMILAR
TO. OR ARE JEWS AND I TEND
THESE WORKERS HAVE NOT BEEN
ELIGIBLE FEDERAL PFEFFER. ON
THE MACINNES TO IT ONE TIME
PAYMENTS FOR THE GROUP IS A
MORE CHAO. OTHERS WOULD HAVE TO.
CONSIDER HOW DOES. MAKE THAT
THAT. HAVE THE ADVANTAGE
WORKING DRAFT BE ON THE
CONTROLLER OFFICE MR. BOB
MENSCH. INSECT I LOOK COULD.
ONE TIME. TO RECIPIENTS THE
JUST SOCIAL SAFETY NET. ON
AGAIN SIMILARLY IF THE DESERVE
BACK IN FOR THESE WOULD HAVE BE
TO TURN LIKELY TO SOMEWHAT. IN
THE COMING MONTHS OUR BODIES.
PROGRAMS TEND TO SERVE THIS WAS
IN PUBLIC MANY OF WHOM MAY HAVE.
STRUGGLED THE PAN WITH ACCESS
TO COMMUNITY RESOURCES OR
RISING- COSTS FOR THINGS LIKE
UTILITIES THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER. ON RESIDENTS ARE HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS ON ON. OUR
OFFICE RECOGNITION FOR A MORE
TARGETED APPROACH OR THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY- NEXT I'D LIKE TO
MOVE ON TO SERRA SERRA
KIMBERLIN SENIOR POLICY ANALYST
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER WELCOME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND I'M GONNA SHARE
MY SCREEN SOLUTION. JUST
LOOKING FOR THE- IN SHARE. YEAH.
YES I'M WORKING YEAH YES THANKS.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
AGAIN MY NAME IS SARA KIMBERLIN
AND I'M A SENIOR POLICY ANALYST
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER I'M I'M HERE
TODAY BECAUSE I WAS ASKED TO
SPEAK ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PROPOSAL
INCLUDING OPPORTUNITIES TO
STRENGTHEN THE PROPOSAL
PARTICULARLY TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM OTHER COMMIT
NINETEEN RELIEF. AND SO I WANT
TO START BY COMMENDING THE
OVERALL APPROACH OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. SINCE THE
START OF THE KEVIN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN
HISTORIC JOB LOSSES AS ROMA
WHERE MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
HAVE BEEN OUT OF WORK AND LAST
MONTH WE ACTUALLY SIGNED NEW
NET JOB LOSSES. AND YET THE
EFFECTS OF THIS RECESSION HAVE
BEEN DEEPLY UNEQUAL THOUGH JOB
LOSSES HAVE BEEN HEAVILY
CONCENTRATED AMONG WORKERS IN
LOW WAGE JOBS WHILE HIGH WAGE
WORKERS HAVE BEEN MUCH LESS
AFFECTED. AND WHILE THE STOCK
MARKET HAS BEEN BOOMING. THE
BUDGETCENTER HAS ANALYZED THE
JOBS HELD BY INDIVIDUALS WHO
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE TO BENEFIT
FROM THE PROPOSED GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS PAYMENTS. M. AND AS
SHOWN HERE ON THE SCREEN- WE
FOUND THAT MANY BENEFICIARIES
ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK IN LOW
WAGE JOBS IN INDUSTRIES THAT
HAVE BEEN ESPECIALLY HARD HIT
BY KOBE JOB LOSSES LIKE LEISURE
AND HOSPITALITY AND RETAIL AND
MANY OTHERS ARE CODE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS IN LOW WAGE JOBS YOU
HAVE CONTINUE TO REPORT TO WORK
TO KEEP OUR FOOD HEALTH CARE
AND OTHER SYSTEMS AND SERVICES
OPERATING DURING THE PANDEMIC
OFTEN AT RISK TO THEIR HEALTH
AND THE HEALTH OF THEIR
FAMILIES. AT THE SAME TIME THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
ESPECIALLY CARRYING THE BURDEN
OF THE EFFECTS OF THE PANDEMIC.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT MANY OF THESE
CALIFORNIANS WERE STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET EVEN BEFORE KOBE
NINETEEN HAT. SO THEY ARE THE
LEAST LIKELY TO BE ABLE TO
WEATHER THE LOSS OF A JOB OR AN
UNEXPECTED HEALTHCARE EXPENSES
OR ANY OTHER ECONOMIC CRISIS
RIGHT NOW. FOR ALL THESE
REASONS IF THERE EVER WAS A
TIME FOR THE STATE TO GO BANK
IN SUPPORTING CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE STRUGGLING THIS IS THAT
TIME- IT IS A SMART CHOICE TO
TARGET SUPPORT TO CALIFORNIANS
WITH LOW INCOMES. YOU HAVE BEEN
MOST DIRECTLY AFFECTED BY THE
ECONOMIC EFFECTS OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND WHO ARE
STRUGGLING TO MEET BASIC NEEDS
EVEN BEFORE COPE AND- IT ALSO
MAKES SENSE TO BUILD ON
EXISTING STATE INFRASTRUCTURE
SUCH AS THE TAX FILING AND
PAYMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
AVAILABLE THROUGH THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD. AND IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE TO ALSO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIANS WITH
LOW INCOMES IN THIS COURT. THAT
COULD INCLUDE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE LOST THEIR JOBS DURING THE
RECESSION AND NEARLY QUALIFY
FOR THE CARRIER TO SEE WHEN
THEY FILE THEIR TAXES THIS YEAR.
AT THE SAME TIME. WE FEEL THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL COULD
PARTICULARLY BE STRENGTHENED BY
PROVIDING A GREATER LEVEL OF
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIANS
WHO HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM
FEDERAL COVET RELIEF.
SPECIFICALLY POLICYMAKERS COULD
SIGNIFICANTLY BASED THE SUPPORT
PROVIDED BY A FOR CALIFORNIANS
WHO ARE UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
AND THOSE IN MIXED STATUS
FAMILIES. THESE CALIFORNIANS
ARE DEEPLY INTEGRATED IN
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. TWO AND THREE HAVE LIVED
IN THE U. S. FOR A DECADE OR
LONGER. AND MORE THAN ONE IN
EIGHT CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS MAY HAVE AN
UNDOCUMENTED PARENTS.
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
UNDOCUMENTED ARE ALSO A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF THE STATE'S
WORKFORCE BOTH IN SECTORS HIT
HARD BY KOBE JOB LOSSES LIKE
HOSPITALITY. IN IN JOBS THAT
ARE CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL DURING
THE PANDEMIC. IN THESE WORKERS
ARE CONSIDERED ESSENTIAL
WORKERS DURING PREVENT WHETHER
OR NOT THEY HOLD A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER. THE GOVERNOR'S
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS PROPOSAL
INCLUDES UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS WHO FILE TAXES
WITH AN INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBER. AND WHO
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THE CALLIE IDC
WHEN THEY FILE THEIR TAXES THIS
YEAR. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
STARTING POINT. BUT IT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THESE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM VIRTUALLY ALL FEDERAL CODE
REALLY SO FAR. AND SO LEFT OUT
OF ACCESS TO THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS THAT HAVE HELPED OTHER
CALIFORNIANS GET THROUGH THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES. FOR EXAMPLE
FOR A FAMILY WITH TWO CHILDREN
AND TWO ADULTS. FEDERAL
ECONOMIC IN IMPACT PAYMENTS
HAVE PROVIDED UP TO FIVE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLARS
FOR MOST CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
WITH LOW AND MIDDLE INCOMES.
FAMILIES WHERE BOTH PARENTS ARE
UNDOCUMENTED HAVE RECEIVED
NOTHING. AS A RESULT THESE
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
MAKE IMPOSSIBLE CHOICES ABOUT
WHICH BASIC NEEDS TO COVER IN
WHICH TO PUT OFF DURING THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES. EVEN BEFORE
THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN ONE IN
FOUR CHILDREN OF IMMIGRANTS AND
WORKING FAMILIES WERE LIVING IN
POVERTY. MORE THAN DOUBLE THE
SHARE OF OTHER CHILDREN AND
WORKING FAMILIES. AND THE
POVERTY RATE HAS SURELY RISEN
EVEN HIGHER OVER THE PAST YEAR
CONSIDERING THAT IMMIGRANT
CALIFORNIANS WERE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO LOSE THEIR JOBS AT
THE ONSET OF THE RECESSION. SO
CAL HAS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THIS INEQUITY. HELPFUL
FREE MARKETS TO CONSIDER THE
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL COVERED
RELIEF THE UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS AND EXTENDED
FAMILIES HAVE BEEN BLOCKED FROM
ACCESSING. AND TO LOOK TO CLOSE
THAT GAP. SO AS THE RIGHT ON
THE SCREEN SHOWS. I'M THE
PROPOSAL THE STATE SENATE'S
PAYMENTS WOULD CLOSE ONLY A
SMALL FRACTION OF THE GAP FOR
THESE FAMILIES JUST 10% FOR A
FAMILY OF FOUR TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY CLOSE THE GAP IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE TO PROVIDE
LARGER PAYMENTS FOR THESE
CALIFORNIANS AND TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT FOR ADULT AND CHILD
SIMILAR TO THE STRUCTURE OF THE
FEDERAL PAYMENTS FROM WHICH
THESE FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS
WERE BLOCKED FOR EXAMPLE. SHARE
THIS TABLE ON THE SCREEN HERE
SHOWS. THAT I AM BY PROVIDING
FOR EXAMPLE ONE THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER TAX FILER
SPOUSE AND DEPENDENT THAT WOULD
COVER ABOUT 80% OF THE FEDERAL
CODE RELIEF SUPPORT AND WHICH
THESE INDIVIDUALS HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED. LISTING SUPPORT FOR
ITIN FILERS THROUGH THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS IN THIS WAY
WOULD BUILD ON OTHER ACTIONS
CALIFORNIA'S TAKEN TO RECOGNIZE
UNDOCUMENTED CALIFORNIANS AND
MAKE STATUS FAMILIES IS VITAL I
YOU'D COMMUNITY MEMBERS WHO
SHOULD NOT BE LEFT UNABLE TO
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS. HIS
ACTIONS LIKE EXTENDING THE
EXCLUSION OF I. TEN VIOLATION
THE CALLIE I YOU SEE A YOUNG
CHILD TAX CREDIT. INCLUDING
CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS IN
MEDIKAL COVERAGE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THESE PAST
CHOICES BY POLICY MAKERS HAVE
MADE AND WILL MAKE AN IMPORTANT
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF OUR
UNDOCUMENTED AND MIXED STATUS
COMMUNITY MEMBERS. YET THESE
CALIFORNIANS STILL REMAIN
EXCLUDED FROM ANY OF THE PUBLIC
SUPPORTS THE HELP OTHER
CALIFORNIANS MEET THEIR MOST
BASIC NEEDS BOTH DURING THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND MORE
BROADLY. EXCLUDED FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS MEDICARE
FOR SENIORS AND MOST WORKING
AGE ADULTS. OUT FRESH FOOD
ASSISTANCE AND THE FEDERAL
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT FOR
EXAMPLE. CALIFORNIA CAN DO MORE
TO PROTECT AND INCLUDE THESE
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS. THE
LISTING PAYMENTS THROUGH THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS FOR TAX
FILERS USE I TENS IS ONE
IMPORTANT OPPORTUNITY TO
PROTECT THESE ESSENTIAL
COMMUNITY MEMBERS CLOSE THE
INEQUITABLE GAP IN SUPPORT FROM
WHICH THEY HAVE BEEN BLOCKED
AND MAKE SURE THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE THE SUPPORT.
THEY NEED TO GET THROUGH THIS
CHALLENGING TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WOULD BE TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. VERY GOOD- THANK
YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION. HAVE
YOU I AM I KNOW THAT YOU HAVE.
COME OUT WITH THE REPORT AND I
HAVE TO APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I
DIDN'T GET IT UNTIL THIS
MORNING LIKE SECONDS BEFORE I
WALKED INTO THE COMMITTEE
HEARING I WILL READ IT- WHAT IS
YOUR RECOMMENDATION IN REGARDS
TO THE EITC AS THE- AS THE-
MECHANISM. FOR DOING THE GRANTS
AND THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
USING TWENTY NINETEEN AND
TWENTY TWENTY. OR A COMBINATION
RECOMMENDATION. OUR INTERESTS
ARE IS THERE ANY OTHER- METRICS
THAT WE CAN BE USED TO
DETERMINE WHO THESE FAMILIES
ARE. I THINK I'VE YOU GENERALLY
IS THAT- THAT THE KELLY IF YOU
SEE DOES A GOOD JOB OF
IDENTIFYING- WORKERS IN
FAMILIES IN CALIFORNIA THE
WORKERS WITH THE LOWEST
INCOMES. AND TARGETED TO
HOUSEHOLDS THAT- TAX THAT
AREN'T. WORKING- PART YEAR YOU
KNOW- IN VERY LOW WAGE JOBS AND
THEY SEEM TO BE A LOT OF
BENEFITS TO TAKING ADVANTAGE OF
THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE DATA TAX FILING YOU
CONSTRUCTION TAX IN AN
INFRASTRUCTURE- I THINK THAT-
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER TO USE
TWENTY NINETEEN OR TWENTY
TWENTY- KELLY ATC'S STATUS OR
BOTH. AND I THINK THERE'S A
BEDSIDE THAT GOOD REASON TO
LOOK TO INCLUDING AND-
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE LOST JOBS
DURING THE RECESSION AND SO
MIGHT FIRST QUALIFY FOR KELLY
HD DURING THAT DURING THAT.
TWENTY AD DURING. THE CURRENT
TAX FILING SEASON. AND IT ARE
THE ARE GENERAL THOUGHTS ABOUT
THAT. THANK THANK YOU THAT
APPRECIATE IT- I BET ACTUALLY
THE SAME QUESTION I AM I POSE
FIVE POSED TO THE
ADMINISTRATION. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT. THE NUMBERS FOR THAT. THE
FILERS. THE CALIENTE C. FILERS
ARE DIFFERENT EACH YEAR THEN
THE NUMBER SEEMS TO VACILLATE
AND NOT CLEAR TO ME EXACTLY WHY
THAT HAPPENS- IT MAY BE THAT
THE INCOMES VACILLATE IN THOSE
FAMILIES AND THAT'S WHY THEY
THEY COME IN AND OUT OF THE
PROGRAM BUT- IT IS YOUR
PROPOSAL A PREDICATED UPON-
USING THAT. BOTH OF THOSE. SIX
YEARS OR ONLY ONE I'M NOT SURE
I UNDERSTOOD. YEAH THANK YOU SO
OF SORE PROPOSAL DOES- DOES.
HELLO PROPOSAL WE WOULD FOCUS
JUST ON THE TWENTY NINETEEN
YEAR FOR MOST TAXPAYERS- AND
THE REASON FOR THAT IS THAT WE
WANT TO GET THE MONEY OUT
QUICKLY- AND SO IF YOU WAIT FOR
TWENTY TWENTY RETURNS YOU HAVE
TO WAIT TILL THE FILED THEN
TAKE SOME TIME BEFORE IT GETS
SENT OUT- THE ONE EXCEPTION
WOULD BE FOR TAXPAYERS WITH.
WITH ITUNES- WHO WERE
KNOWLEDGEABLE IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND SO WE WOULD BE
GETTING- WE'VE BEEN RELYING ON
THEIR TWENTY TWENTY TAX RETURNS
AS HE INDICATED OF THE ISSUE.
THE ON THE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
WELL THANK THANK YOU FOR THATTHAT THAT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE
I DO. I THINK MY CONCERN IS
THAT WE REALLY PICK UP THE
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN AFFECTED
THE MOST- AND- AND I WANT TO
RECOGNIZE AND THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR WORKING SO HARD
WITH THE LEGISLATURE ON
EXPANDING CAL THE ITC IT IS A
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT. PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR WORKING FAMILIES TO BE ABLE
TO ACCESS A CREDIT BACK TO HELP
THEM ECONOMICALLY AND- THE LONG
TERM IMPACT OF RECEIVING THAT
KIND OF A BENEFIT IS- IS HAS
BEEN SHOWN TO BE. A TREMENDOUS
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT TO THE
FAMILY BUT ALSO THE ULTIMATE-
ECONOMIC BENEFIT FOR THE CHILD
WHO GROWS UP IN A FAMILY THAT'S
RECEIVED CAL THE ITC WHICH I
FIND REALLY INTERESTING SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON THAT
I GUESS THAT THE NEXT QUESTION
WOULD BE WHAT KIND OF OUT
REACH- DO WE NEED TO DO. AND
THE COMMUNITY IN ORDER TO- MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PICKING UP- AS
MANY- OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
HAVE NOT QUALIFIED FOR FEDERAL
PROGRAMS AS POSSIBLE AND I'M
WONDERING IF THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS A PLAN TO DO OUTREACH AS
PART OF THIS PROPOSAL. SO FOR
THIS PARTICULAR PROPOSAL- HERE
PARTICULARLY SINCE WE'RE
RELYING ON ON TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN. RETURNS THERE WOULD
BE OBVIOUSLY THOSE TAXPAYERS.
MAJORITY THOSE TAXPAYERS HAVE
HAVE ALREADY FILED THE RETURNS-
WE DO ALLOW- WE DO ALLOW FOR
TAXPAYERS. TO FILE THEIR TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN RETURNED ALL
THE WAY THROUGH- NOVEMBER OF
THIS YEAR SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE COULD BE SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDERS- WE WOULD ALLOW THAT
AND THERE WILL BE- HI I WILL
HAVE TO GET BACK TO THE DETAILS
I DO KNOW THAT THERE WILL BE
SOME NOT REACH TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE- TAXPAYERS TO FILE.
THEIR TWENTY NINETEEN TAX
RETURN IF THEY HAVE NOT DONE
THAT YET AND MAKE YOUR
ELIGIBLE- BUT I'LL OF HIM BACK
FROM THE DETAILS OF THE AVERAGE
ALL RIGHT THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WAS ALSO- CONCERNED
ABOUT THE I. TEN BECAUSE THAT'S
A NEW PROGRAM IT'S NEW
OPPORTUNITY- AND- BUT IT TAKES
FILING. FIFTY EXACT DOING THE
PAY. AND FINALLY THE
APPLICATION TWENTY TWENTY FOR
THE NEW I. TEN MORE- ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES AS WELL. AND SO I
WOULD ASSUME THAT THERE'S THE
SAME EDUCATION ISSUE- THAT'S
GOING TO BE REQUIRED FOR THAT
AS WELL. RIGHT OKAY. THANKS
VERY MUCH AS CENTER NIELSEN. IF
I AM ABLE MISTER CHAIRMAN WHILE
YOU'RE THERE AND I THINK I'D
LIKE TO INQUIRE OF MS KIMBERLY
PROGRAM AND I SEE SOME MERIT
YET BUT I WOULD SUGGEST IT NEED
TO BE VIEWED NOT AS AN
ENTITLEMENT AN ONGOING
OBLIGATION OF THE STATE. BUT AS
AN OPPORTUNITY AND A BRIDGE TO
GREATER THINGS IN THE FUTURE.
DO YOU IN FINANCE- INVASION S.
AS JUST A ONE TIME STOPGAP FOR
THE DURATION OF A PANDEMIC OR
IS THERE A LONG TERM GOAL. HERE
FOR THIS PROGRAM. YES TO THE
QUESTION SENATORS SO ON SO THIS
IS A ONE TIME PROGRAM REALLY
GIVEN THAT THE- THE CONDITIONS
WERE UNDER THE SORT OF
EXTRAORDINARY CONDITIONS THAT
WE ARE PARTICULARLY ARE A LOT
OF LOW INCOME FAMILIES AND
CALIFORNIANS USUALLY CONSIDERED
A ONE TIME I HELP TO FAMILIES
TO GET THEM THROUGH THE
PENDING- THAT'S HELPFUL TO ME
NOW- MISS CAMERON HOW DO YOU
VIEW THIS- IT DO YOU VIEW THIS
IS A ONE TIME THING OR THAT
THIS WOULD BE A PATHWAY TO SEE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES. FOR THE
UNDOCUMENTED TO HAVE A LONG
TERM INCOME IN CALIFORNIA.
PARTICIPATING IN THE ECONOMY.
AT THE I UNDER. IS THAT THIS IS
A ONE PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THE
EXTRAORDINARY NEEDS DURING THE
KEVIN NINETEEN PANDEMIC WHICH I
THINK WE ENT ON. THE GRILL AT
THE ALLEY AS ASSESSMENT THAT
THIS IS THAT A GOOD TIME FOR
ONE TIME. PAYMENTS TO ADDRESS
THOSE NEEDS PARTICULARLY GIVEN
THAT THERE'S A- REVENUES
AVAILABLE NOW- AT THE SAME TIME
THAT THERE ARE LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
AND GET THROUGH THIS THIS TIME
THOUGH. WHERE YOU KNOW WE ARE
VERY. THESE THAT BUT THAT. WIRE
GENERAL KILEY IDC- NOW INCLUDES
ITIN FILERS ON AN ONGOING BASIS
BUT THAT IS THAT SESSION THAT
WAS MADE. LAST YEAR AND IS
SEPARATE FROM FROM THIS
PROPOSAL. I WOULD SUBMIT THAT I
THINK BASED ON. POLICIES THAT
THE THIS POPULATION IS GOING TO
CONSIDER REALLY CONTINUE TO
GROW AND CALIFORNIA SO WE NEED
TO BE AWARE OF THAT TOWARD THE
FUTURE THANK YOU KIND OF CHECK.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU I'D CARE AND
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE SENSE OF
HEARING AS A- I THINK THESE-
PROPOSALS THAT WE ARE
DISCUSSING TODAY ARE REALLY
GOOD AND REALLY IMPORTANT AND-
I THINK THE- I WANT TO. GIVE
KNOWLEDGE MEANT TO THE
MINISTRATION WHICH I DIDN'T
BEFORE THAT THIS IS WHEN WE ARE
IN A SITUATION WHERE WE KNOW SO
MANY SMALL BUSINESSES AND SO
MANY CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
INDIVIDUALS FAMILIES AND SUCH
ARE REALLY HURTING. THAT AND WE
HAVE. SOME HOT REVENUES DUE TO
THE STOCK MARKET WHICH THESE
OTHER THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
HURTING IN THE BUSINESSES
EARNING AREN'T NECESSARILY
BENEFITS THEY'RE NOT BENEFITING
FROM THE HIGH STOCK MARKET BUT
WE HAVE. SO THIS IS EXACTLY THE
APPROPRIATE THING TO DO IS TO
LOOK AT ALL RIGHT WHAT OF THESE
ONE TIME ONLY REVENUES. CAN WE
MAKE AVAILABLE TO THOSE THAT
HAVE BEEN MOST ECONOMICALLY
IMPACTED BY THE PANDEMIC SO I
REALLY WANT TO APPLAUD. THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR BRINGING
THESE FORWARD AND- JUST BE
CLEAR THAT ARE THAT THE KIND OF
QUESTIONS AND THINGS THAT WE
ARE RAISING OUR AROUND HOW DO
WE- IMPROVE THESE THINGS SO
THAT THEY GET TO THOSE WHO
REALLY NEED IT. BOTH BUSINESS
WISE AND INDIVIDUALS AND THEY
ARE SIMPLE EFFICIENT AND S.
FRAUD PROOF AS POSSIBLE. SO NOW
IF I GO TO THE STIMULUS PART- I
WOULD- ASK- WELL I WOULD SAY
THAT THE EITC PROPOSAL HAS A
LOT OF MERIT IN MY OPINION
BECAUSE- IT IS. FOLKS WHO
RECEIVE THE H. THEY'VE ALREADY
PROVEN THEIR ELIGIBILITY
THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN SCREENED
IT'S SO IN TERMS OF THAT-
GIVING HIGHER CONFIDENCE OF THE
FRAUD PROOF IT'S GREAT FROM
THAT POINT OF VIEW. HOWEVER AS
I THINK IT'S BEEN ACKNOWLEDGED
THE TWENTY NINETEEN E. I. T. C.
RECIPIENTS MAY NOT ALL BE ISN'T
AS MUCH NEED AS SOME OTHER.
INDIVIDUALS OR FAMILIES SO HOW
IS IT THAT WE DESIGN SOMETHING
TO MAKE SURE GIVEN THAT WE KNOW
THE FED CHAIR YOU KNOW THIS
PROPOSAL WAS DEVELOPED BEFORE
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT APPROVED
THE DECEMBER THE LAST YEAR'S
ACT. SO HOW CAN WE IMPROVE THIS
PROPOSAL TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ASSISTING THOSE FOLKS THAT
MAY NOT HAVE BEEN HELP YET. AND
I LIKE THE- THE FOCUS ON I. TEN
FILERS THAT'S AN IMPORTANT ONE
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT HELPED
BUT I THINK THE CHAIR ALREADY
ON. BUT BASS THAT WAS SHE
DIDN'T QUITE BUT I WANT TO KNOW
IS WHAT PERCENT DO WE HAVE AN
ESTIMATE OF WHAT PERCENT. OF
ARE UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS ARE
AYE TEN FIVE FILERS. IS THERE A
GIVE US A SENSE OF WHETHER WE
ARE ADEQUATELY WHETHER THAT
MECHANISM IS ADEQUATELY
SUPPORTING- SOME OF THE ROAD
FOR FAMILIES OR SOME OF THE
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA THAT
OTHERWISE MIGHT NOT. HAVE
RECEIVED FEDERAL SUPPORT SO DO
WE ARE DOING NOW. THAT WOULD
PROBABLY BE ATTENTION FOR-
RENDON YEAH. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. HI I DON'T NEED TWENTY
I BELIEVE- SO STRONG THE NUMBER
OF ITEMS FILERS MUST PROJECT IS
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND- AND
I THINK. OF SOMEONE WHO
CORRECTLY BUT GOT THROUGH BUT
IT MIGHT- THERE I THINK THERE'S
ABOUT TWO MILLION. UNDOCUMENTED
WHICH WOULD MAKE IT ABOUT. A
THIRD OF. LAST NAME YOUR DATE
OF. ALL RIGHT. FILE ITEM OKAY-
AND WE ALSO KNOW I THINK IT WAS
A. O. REPORT THAT- THAT IT NOW
I'M GOING A LITTLE BROADER THAT
EVERYONE. ALL FAMILIES THAT ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR EITC DIDN'T
NECESSARILY APPLY SO WE HAVE
20% THAT DIDN'T APPLY. SO GIVEN
THAT I'M WONDERING IS THERE
ANOTHER. ON THE THEME OF
SIMPLICITY EFFICIENT C. AND
TRYING TO ACHIEVE YOU KNOW IT'S
FRAUD PROOF AS POSSIBLE IS
THERE A NOTHER CATEGORY THAT WE
CAN USE AND- I THINK THE
CALIFORNIA- ERIN RAISED
SOMETHING ABOUT BENEFITS FOR US
I WONDER IF CALIFORNIA. IS A-
A- PROGRAM THAT CAPTURES SOME
MORE OF THESE- INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES THAT WE ARE TRYING TO
SUPPORT AND WHETHER. USING THAT
MECHANISM. IT N. MAYBE MAYBE
IT'S NOT INSTEAD OF BUT MAYBE
IT'S IN ADDITION TO AS A WAY TO
IF ACHIEVE THE OBJECTIVE OF
HELPING THOSE. FAMILIES WHO MAY
NOT HAVE- OR INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY NOT HAVE GOTTEN FEDERAL
ASSISTANCE. AND AGAIN
CALIBRATION THING WERE YOU
ALREADY HAD TO BE A SCREEN TO
ALREADY HAD TO PROVE I DO YOU
HAD TO PROVE ELIGIBILITY- IN
MANY CASES FAMILIES FOR EXAMPLE
OF UNDOCUMENTED THEIR
APPLICATION IS BASED ON THE
CHILDREN. BUT BUT GO AHEAD.
QUESTIONS YES THE CARE WHETHER
YOU ADD TO IT WHETHER YOU
REVIEWED. SO YEAH. AND I AM YES
SO WE DID LOOK AT THE- I THINK
IT WILL POINT WE WERE LOOKING
AT CALFRESH AND THE PROBLEM.
WITH OUR WITH CALPERS BY
RECALL. I APOLOGIZE I CAN GET
BACK TO YOU ON THAT- ON
SPECIFICS BUT- I BELIEVE THE
PROBLEM IS IT IS A MINISTRY BY
COUNTIES AND THEREFORE WOULD
REQUIRE IT BE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO IDENTIFY- HI. THE
V. IN THE COST. IS UPPER WEST
PROVISIONS THEY WERE DETERMINES
REPUBLICANS WELL I THINK IT'S
WORTH IT FOR US TO LOOK AT IT
BECAUSE INDEPENDENT OF BEING
REGISTERED BY COUNTIES. THEY
DID ALREADY DO THE
DETERMINATION IF YOU ARE A
RECIPIENT OF AN EBT CARD THAT
FOR CALFRESH BENEFITS YOU ARE
HAVE ALREADY BEEN SCREENED AND
ADDITIONALLY. THERE WE KNOW
THAT FOR EXAMPLE SCHOOLS HAVE
BEEN. VERY HELPFUL TO FAMILIES
WHO MAY NOT HAVE BEEN AWARE OF
CALFRESH SO THAT WHEN YOUR
CHILD A PLACE FOR THE FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH THAT OFTENTIMES
THEY'RE INFORMED ABOUT
CALIBRATION DATE OFFICE SO
SOMETIMES THEY MAY BE A FAMILY
THAT HAS A CALPERS BENEFIT BUT
HOUSE EMPLOYED TO ANY ITC
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT AWARE OF
IT. OR MAYBE ARE TO I. TEN
FILER ADDITIONALLY IT'S A
MECHANISM THAT- YOU KNOW WE
CERTAINLY YES THERE'S THAT
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES HOWEVER IT
IS AN EXISTING. PROGRAM IT'S
NOT SOMETHING WE HAVE TO START
ALL FOR MY FOR A FRESH AND NEW-
SO I THINK IT'S A WORTHWHILE TO
LOOK AT TO SEE IF IT ACHIEVES
SOME OF THE OBJECTIVES THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE THROUGH
THIS. ON THE OTHER THING THAT I
WANTED TO RAISE. AND THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT SEPARATE FACT- I. IN
LOOKING AT THE PROPOSAL'S FIVE
ALSO BEEN AWARE THAT IN THE-
GOVERNOR'S OVERALL IN THIS IS
YOUR OR HEARING THAT WE HAD ON
THE OVERALL BUDGET THAT THE.
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET
PROPOSAL BEFORE US CONTINUES-
SUPPORT- OR READING LIST AND
STATE SOME PROGRAM SUSPENSIONS
AND BUT NOT IMMEDIATELY BUT FOR
THE FUTURE AND THOSE PROGRAM
SUSPENSIONS ARE PROGRAMS THAT
SUPPORT THE VERY FAMILIES THAT
WE ARE TRYING TO ADDRESS RIGHT
NOW. AND SO I REACHED THIS
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE YES IT IS
ABSOLUTELY THE CASE THAT WE
MUST BE VERY WISE FISCALLY AND
WHEAT IS PROJECTED THAT WE WILL
FACE SOME KIND OF- REVENUE
CHALLENGES SAY IN TWO YEARS
FROM NOW. BUT WE SHOULD NOT
RIGHT NOW PREDICT WHAT ARE THE
APPROPRIATE IF NEEDED CUTS. TO
MAKE AT THAT POINT BECAUSE THIS
BECAUSE CIRCUMSTANCES JUST LIKE
NOW WHO WOULD HAVE PREDICTED
TWO YEARS PRIOR THAT WE WOULD
BE IN A PANDEMIC. SO GIVEN THAT
WE DON'T HAVE WE WILL NOT KNOW
WHAT THE SITUATION OF FAMILIES
SMALL BUSINESSES AND OTHERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE IN TWO YEARS
FROM NOW WE SHOULD NOT ALREADY
FIX. WHAT WHAT PROGRAMS WE
WOULD BE CUTTING. AND IN THE
SAME THEME THAT THESE STIMULUS
PROGRAMS THAT ARE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY BOTH FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND FOR- YANKEE C.
FILERS AND SUCH. WE SHOULD NOT
ALSO BE INCLUDING A CONTINUED
CUT OF PROGRAMS THAT WE KNOW
SUPPORT MANY OF THE SAME. PARTS
OF THE POPULATION SO I JUST
RAISE THAT WHILE IT IS NOT
SPECIFIC TO THESE PROPOSALS I
THINK IN THE BACKDROP OF WHAT
WE ARE DOING IT SHOULD VERY
MUCH BE FACTORED. VERY GOOD-
YOU KNOW I JUST REALIZED THAT-
CHESS ALAMO HAS HIS HAND UP I'M
NOT SURE IF. YOU WANTED TO
RESPOND TO ONE OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED. BUT I AM
HOPEFULLY THAT IT HASN'T BEEN
UP TO FOR A LONG TIME. ONLY A
SHORT PERIOD ROLE GETTING USED
TO THIS ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR OF. SENATOR SKINNER
AND IN RESPONSE YOUR COMMENTS
ABOUT THE CALFRESH HOUSEHOLDS
OUR OFFICE ON. SPENT A GOOD
DEAL OF TIME THINKING ABOUT
EXISTING STATE PROGRAMS WITH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE ALREADY
EXISTS WHERE YOU MIGHT BE ABLE
TO TARGET ONE TIME USE OF
FUNDS. AREN'T ANY PARTICULAR
STATE PROGRAMS THAT BENEFIT
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS WHO ARE
ELIGIBLE BUT WHO ALSO HAVE
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS THESE MIXED
STATUS HOUSEHOLDS WOULD BE AN
ELIGIBLE- ONE EXAMPLE THAT THAT
IS TOP OF MIND IT WOULD BE- CAL
WORKS HOUSEHOLD AS A CHILD ONLY
CASES. WHERE THE CHILDREN ARE.
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE A COWARDS
BENEFITS- BUT ONE OR MORE THE
ADULTS ARE INELIGIBLE TO THE
IMMIGRATION STATUS THIS IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE OF A- HOUSEHOLD IN
WHICH THE STATE HAS A- DIRECT
EXISTING PROGRAM RELATIONSHIP
WITH. BUT FOR MANY ADULTS ARE
INELIGIBLE CURRENTLY FOR
FEDERAL ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS-
AND SO THESE ARE SORTS OF
OPPORTUNITIES ARE THAT WE HAD
IN MIND WHEN SUGGESTING THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDER THIS WITH
EXISTING SAFETY NET. AS AN
OPTION FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDS
VENDORS CALFRESH FIT IN THAT
ALSO OR IT WOULD WERE YOU
THINKING. THAT SOLELY AND ONLY
CAL WORKS. I WE THOUGHT AS WELL
ABOUT HOW NEEDS THE USE ON
SIMILARLY- UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ARE NOT ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE CALFRESH BENEFITS BUT-
CITIZEN CHILDREN OR OTHER
RECORD HOLDERS IN A HOUSEHOLD
RECEIVE RIGHT FITS I'M ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY- WE THOUGHT
FIRST TO CAL WORKS IS IT
GENERALLY SERVES A LOWER INCOME
POPULATION AND CALFRESH- SO
IT'S A MORE TARGETED APPROACH-
WE THOUGHT THAT WAS BETTER
ALIGNED WITH SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS WE RAISE OUR HAND OUT
ABOUT HOW BEST UC SPONSORED
VERY TARGETED FASHION OF THE
TIME. OKAY I. THAT
CLARIFICATION AND I WAS GOING
TO USE CAL WORKS ADDITIONAL IS
AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT I DIDN'T
WANT TO GO TO LONG BUT- ON THE-
BACK ON THE CALFRESH. FRONT THE
OTHER THING I THINK IT
CAPTURES. POTENTIALLY IS THAT-
MANY OF THOSE MANY FOLKS WHO
EXPERIENCED NEW LEVELS OF.
ECONOMIC HARDSHIP IN THIS YEAR
WHO MAY HAVE NEVER BEEN IN I.
E. I. T. C. FILER IN THE PAST
FOR EXAMPLE EARLY. MAY WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S A THERE'S BEEN A
JUMP IN ENROLLMENT IN CALFRESH
SO IT WAS IN MY THINKING WAS
PERHAPS WOULD CAPTURE SOME OF
THESE FOLKS WHO HAVE THAT. WE
WOULD HAVE NEVER PUT IN A
CATEGORY OF ECONOMIC HARDSHIP
SAY LAST YEAR. BUT NOW ARE SO-
THERE WAS THE OTHER THOUGHT
ABOUT CALFRESH. VERY GOOD WELL
THIS SOME INCLUDES OUR OUR-
THIS PORTION OF THE HEARING
WORD NOW READY TO MOVE ON TO
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
THE HEARING LET ME JUST SAY IN
WRAPPING UP THAT OTHER SECTION
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE.
EVERYBODY'S TESTIMONY AND I
ALSO APPRECIATE THAT THINKING
THAT HAS GONE INTO. TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THIS DONE
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
OF YOUR COMMENTS AND- FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS HERE TODAY- ONTO
OUR PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
OUR HEARING- THE I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYBODY THAT THIS IS A
PROMOTIONAL HEARING ON THESE
TWO ITEMS- THAT HAVE ARE PART
OF THE GOVERNOR'S. BUDGET
PROPOSAL AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SIX ZERO ONE. ONE SIX
THREE FIVE. DUE TO THE
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARING.
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS. ON THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR MAY INSTITUTE
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY TODAY
I'M GOING TO ASK EACH MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENTS
KEEP THEIR REMARKS TO ONE
MINUTE AND THIS IS NOT THE LAST
TIME WE'RE GOING TO DEAL WITH
THIS ISSUE WILL BE BACK AS A-
AT WHEN WE'RE READY TO TAKE
ACTION. NOW LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. LIKE TO INVITE
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GIVE A
PUBLIC COMMENT TO PLEASE COME
UP AND- COME UP TO THE MIKE.
SEEING NO MOVEMENT ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM. ONE
TWELVE WHO WISH TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON EITHER OF
THESE TWO ITEMS. I DON'T SEE
ANYONE THERE TO SAID LITTLE
ROOM THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE NOW
MOVES ON TO WITNESSES WAITING
TO RIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE.
MODERATOR MODERATOR GREECE IF
YOU WOULD PLEASE PROPERTY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN.
THANK YOU FOR ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU MAY PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND WE WILL GO TO
A LINE OF FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YOU MAY PROVIDE A
FIFTY SEVEN YEAR ONE OF THE.
ONE OF THE AT THE NUMBER AND
BREADTH SILVA. YEAH I REMEMBER
THAT IS INCORRECT REPORTS OF
BAR OF CHOCOLATE IS THE LEVEL
THAT. THE NEW PERCENT OF THE-
AMEND SECOND NO LET ME MY
COUNTY DELI DEAL I LOOKED ABOUT
HOW IT'S BEEN THE TARA. AGAINST
THE DOOR BLUE DON'T THEY WILL
ADVOCATE IT AS WILL MORE RUNS.
ONE PARTICULAR FROM THE THIRTY
COMMENT H. E. R. LET YOU KNOW
DO NOT I'LL MEANT THAT. EIGHTY
FIVE OH IS THE MORAL OF THE
ORDER A LOT DO WE- EVENING I
MEAN OR JUST CANCEL LATTER ONE
TEAM THE COMMON STOCK. DIVIDEND
THAT ILLEGAL WITHOUT YOUR EYES
NOT ONLY THAT IS NOT THE YOU
GOT ORDER TO SEE THAT. AND THEN
IT COULD NOT. GET MORE TALK I'M
HERE TO READ ABOUT I KNEW WHAT
WAS THE WILL OF. THEY LET
THEMSELVES THE MEDI GUN IT'S
ALMOST A LOT THEY ORDERED HIS
BEYOND IF IT ISN'T AVAILABLE HE
GOT A CANNOT BE HONEST. LOOKING
EMERALD NOT ONLY THAT MINISTER
DALY YORK HONESTLY LOVE THE
MOCK YES HIM FOR THE REMOTE
THAT RELY BUT IRAQI THAT
NOTHING TO ARE UP AT FOUR I
KNOW TO. THAT YES WE CAN ASSIST
IN YOUR. MODERATOR CAN YOU MOVE
ON TO THE NEXT CALLER. OUR NEXT
WELCOME A SIX FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON ARE NOT
CHAIR CHRISTOPHER POLICY WITH
QUESTIONS ON LAW POVERTY WE'RE
SUPPORT OF THE GUY CALL STATE
THE NEW YORK HOWEVER WE
ENCOURAGE ALLEGE THAT CALL FOR.
EXPANDED THE USE TO IT MANY CAL
OF POVERTY DURING PANDEMIC OF.
AS YOU KNOW THE MAJORITY OF AND
NUMBER BLACK I CAN IN WILL WANT
TO BE BLOCKED FROM TIME COULD
DESPITE BEING THREE IMPACTED BY
COLIN. THEY MUST PROVIDE RELIEF
TO CALIFORNIANS IMMEDIATELY
ADDITIONALLY WE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT THE RECIPIENT OF SFI
AND SOME OF THOSE THAT ARE
RECIPIENTS OF WELL THOUGHT TO
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE THOSE IN
POVERTY I WILL NOT BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OUR STIMULUS
BECAUSE THEY DO NOT FILE TAXES.
GIVEN THE COMPRESSIONAL LASTLY
I WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THAT MANY IMMIGRANTS
HAVE JUST ROLLED AND SOCIAL
SERVICE PROGRAMS DUE TO THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION PUBLIC
CHARGE DESPITE HAVING IN YOUR
MINISTRY SENT THAT EXPECTED ON
ALL MATCH- OF IMMIGRANTS WOULD
BE LOWER- IN THESE PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND I FIND COME
FROM WIND ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING NAME IS THE ONLY
OUT OF KNOW WHAT THE WAY WORKER
RESOURCE HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
FIFTY NET FOR ALL. COALITION
I'M CALLING BECAUSE URGE YOU TO
GET THE AMOUNT OF A- TO ONE
DOCTOR WORKERS WHO BEEN OUT OF
RIDLEY FROM THE GOVERNMENT ARE
THEIR COUNTERPARTS HAVE
RECEIVED SPECIFICALLY ON
MERGING THE LEGISLATORS TO
INCREASE THE GOLDEN GATE
SIMILAR PREPAYMENT. I TEN
FIGHTERS EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS IN ORDER TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF PROVIDING NECESSARY
RELIEFS WHO DID UNDERSERVED AND
UNDER RECOGNIZED COMMUNITY.
IT'S LIKE CALIFORNIA TO QUALIFY
FOR A CENTURY STATE AND THEN
BOTH LEFT. STAND THE FOUR MILE
TO PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITY DURING THE TIME THAT
WE CAN OUT A DOCUMENT THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN
IMPACTED IMPASTO HALF AWAY AT
THE RATE OF. THREE CRYING- ARE
NATIONALIZED INDIVIDUAL NO ONE
SHOULD BE DYING THROUGH THAT.
AND THEN THAT IT. EDUCATOR NEED
TO PROVIDE WHAT IF NOTHING. FOR
ALL OF OUR COMMUNITY IS
PROTECTED BUT FANDOM. THANK YOU
VERY. NEXT CALLER TO. OUR NEXT
WILL COME FROM SEVENTY SEVEN
YOUR LAW IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
I'M NOT AND SHARE SOME SKINNER
AND HER NIELSEN AND IT IS THE
NEW APOLLO ON THE FOR THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS. ACT FROM THE SUPPORT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
RELIEF PROGRAM BUT WE WANTED TO
UNDERSCORE A FEW BARRIERS THAT
ARE PREVENTING FARMERS FROM
APPLYING. FIRST THE NEED FOR A
SPANISH LANGUAGE APPLICATION
WELL THERE IS A SPANISH
LANGUAGE GUIDE MANY FARMERS WE
WORK WITH SPEAK OR WRITE
PRIMARILY IN SPANISH AND
SPANISH LANGUAGE APPLICATION
WOULD MAKE THE PROGRAM MORE
ACCESSIBLE FOR THEM. I CAN'T
CONCERNS REGARDING THE
TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH THE
SOFTWARE POP UP BLOCKERS ARE
HINDERING FOLKS FROM FINALIZING
THEIR APPLICATIONS AND IF THEY
DO NOT COMPLETE- COMPLETED
THEIR THEY DON'T GET A
CONFIRMATION EMAIL EITHER-
LETTING THEM KNOW THE
APPLICATION WITH THE MINUTE.
THIRD THE APPLICATION CURRENTLY
FOCUSES ON ARE. ONLY APRIL TO
SEPTEMBER SEASON AND DOESN'T
ACCOUNT FOR LOSSES OUTSIDE OF
THAT WINDOW THERE ARE MANY
SEASONAL FARMERS WHO WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED OUTSIDE
OF THAT PERIOD YOU MAY NOT SEE
THE RELIEF THEY NEED- FINALLY
MANY FARMERS PARTICULARLY OLDER
GROWERS ARE NOT COMPUTER
LITERATE. AND THAT'S PREVENTING
THEM FROM COMPLETING
APPLICATION AND EASILY
PRINTABLE APPLICATION FORM
WOULD ASSIST THESE GROWERS
ADDITIONALLY MANY GROWERS ALSO
DECIDED NOT TO APPLY BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT FEEL COMFORTABLE
SHARING THEIR FULL TAX RETURNS.
AND OR SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
AND WE WILL SUBMIT THESE
COMMENTS IN WRITING TO THE
COMMITTEE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU ARE NOT OUR
NEXT LINE COME FROM MY EAST
YOUR LINE IS A- GOOD MORNING
AFTER. MORNING TEARING MEMBERS-
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER I'M
HERE TODAY TO RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOU TO PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR
THE BACKBONE OF OUR WORK FORCE
SHOULD BE UNDOCUMENTED
WORKFORCE POPULATION WHO HAS
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL RELEASED
SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THIS
PANDEMIC. UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS HAVE BEEN SHUT OUT
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS OF
FEDERAL RELEASED DESPITE BEING
ON THE FRONT LINES OF THE
PANDEMIC THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS AND ACCOMPANYING
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE ALLEY-
ARE GREAT STARTING POINTS TO
ENSURE ARE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY CAN RECEIVE ECONOMIC
SUPPORT I JUST CRISIS CONTINUES
TO DEMONSTRATE UNPRECEDENTED
IMPACTS. I INCREASING PAYMENTS
FRIGHTEN HOLDERS EXPANDING
ACCESS TO I CAN FOR PEOPLE WHO
DO NOT ALREADY HAVE THEM AND
INCLUDING THEM IN OUR STATES
RELIEF OPPORTUNITIES. WE CAN
BEGIN TO MOVE CALIFORNIA IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE ANNETTE EXPLAINED
WILL COME OUR NEXT LINE WILL BE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU A TURN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SABRINA
SANTIAGO WITH GOLDEN STATE
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN ANTI POVERTY
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS IN.
EACH WE NEED SUPPORT TO THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS BUT THINK
THAT THERE ARE AREAS FOR
GROWTH. INCLUDING THE A MORE
GENEROUS BENEFITS I CAN FILERS
THIS IS REALLY A COMMUNITY IN
NEED. WE ALSO ASK THE COURT
HAVING- DIFFICULT TO
EXPENDITURES WHEN TWENTY FOUR
HOURS JUST BECAUSE- SO SHOULD
BE LEFT OUT JUST BECAUSE THEIR
IMPACT WAS FELT LEADER. AND
FINALLY I THINK THE KEY PART OF
THIS IS TO SAY THAT WE'RE GING
TO NEED OUTREACH DOLLARS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE HELPING
REACH ALL THE STOCKS AND NOT
MAY BE PART OF A CONVERSATION
FOR. ANOTHER DAY BUT WANT TO
FIGHT BACK WE ARE GOING TO BE
REACHING LARGER NUMBERS OF
FOLKS AND IF WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERYONE WHO NEEDS
THE HELP OF GETTING IT WE NEED
TO PUT OUR SUPPORT BEHIND THAT
AS WELL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.THANK AN UNEXPECTED
WILL COME FROM LINE NINETY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING CARE
AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS DEANNA
HILL AND I'M AN ATTORNEY WITH
THE TECHNICAL SERVICES. I
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO GET THE
SAME AMOUNT OF RELEASED ONE
DOCUMENTED WORKERS HAVE BEEN
SHUT OUT OF RELIEF FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AS THEIR
COUNTERPARTS HAVE RECEIVED.
THAT DEFINITELY I URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THE
GOLDEN GATE STIMULATE PAYMENT I
CAN FILERS EIGHTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS. IN ORDER TO BEGIN THE
PROCESS OF PROVIDING NECESSARY
LEAD TO THAT AND UNDERSERVED.
IN AND RECOGNIZED COMMUNITY.
THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF MY
CLIENTS ARE WITHOUT STATUS AND
THEY ARE HURTING RIGHT NOW. SO
MANY OF THEM ARE UNEMPLOYED
THROUGH NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN
MOREOVER ANYTHING COMPLETELY
EXCLUDED FROM ALL FEDERALLY. I
TRUMP WHEN OUT OF HIS WAY TO
EXCLUDE EVEN EXTENDED FAMILIES.
THAT'S WHY WE'RE ASKING FOR
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR
EVERYONE IS THE FIRST STEP
TOWARD EQUITY. WE CAN DO BETTER
WE URGE YOU TO RIGHT THESE
WRONGS AN INCREASE PAYMENT I
CAN HOLD OR- EXPAND ACCESS TO I
CAN FOR PEOPLE WHO DON'T
ALREADY HAVE THEM. AND INCLUDE
THOSE WHO DO NOT HAVE AN I CAN
IN OUR THEATERS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE GIVE. AND I'M
NOT. OUR NEXT QUESTION WILL
COME FROM NINE EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS MADAM CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR
AND SENATOR SKINNER MY NAME IS
JUSTIN RAZA ON BEHALF OF WORKER
OWNED FOR COUNTRY CALIFORNIA.
WHICH IS THE COALITION FORMED
BY STATE AND NATIONAL EXPERTS
WORKER OWNED COMPANIES AND
LABOR UNIONS WORKING FOR YEARS.
TO ADVANCE WORKER OWNERSHIP IN
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED BY
SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC INEQUITIES.
BUILDING OFF OF CAL NONPROFIT
THAT'S MONEY TODAY. WORKER
OWNED BUSINESSES WHICH ARE
BUSINESSES- SIMILAR WE HAD
DIFFICULT HE IS ACCESSING THE
COMPUTER RELIEF GRANTS GIVEN
THAT THERE ISN'T A SOLE OWNER
AND WORKER OWNED BUSINESSES- WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS AND HAD AN
INITIAL CONVERSATION WITH YOUR
STAFF. AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUED DURING THAT
CONVERSATION AT THE RELATES TO
THE SECOND ROUND FOR THE- THE
CULTURALLY FRANCE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IF YOU.
AND THE NEXT QUESTION WILL
COME- COME IT WILL COME FROM
NINE SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND SENATOR MICHAEL DR
OFF ON BEHALF OF THE EAST CARE
YORK CALIFORNIA ACTION WELL WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS WOULD PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED RAPID CASH SUPPORT
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS WE'RE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
EXCLUSION UP INCARCERATED
PEOPLE FROM THE FUNDS AND
REQUEST THAT THE LEGISLATURE
EXTENDED ELIGIBILITY TO THE-
HONORABLE POPULATION- THREE DID
PEOPLE. WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK BROWN
AN INDIGENT DESPERATELY NEEDS
DANIEL PAYMENT TO PAY FOR PHONE
CALLS TO STAND HUTCH WITH
FAMILY AND FRIENDS TO PAY FOR
STATE FOR FOOD MEDICAL SUPPLIES
CLEANING SUPPLIES AND THE
COMMENTARY AND TO SAVE MONEY TO
PAY FOR RISING COSTS OF
REENTRY. THIS NEED IS
EXACERBATED BY EXTREMELY LOW
WAGES AND INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED RISKY FOR THEIR
LABOR WITH PUBLIC NINETEEN
RAVAGING OUR PRESIDENT AND OUR
NON INCARCERATED BLACK AND
BROWN COMMUNITIES IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT INCARCERATED
PEOPLE BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS FUNDS.
AND WE RESPECTFULLY URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO EXPAND
ELIGIBILITY THE POPULATION.
PLEASE ALSO ATTRIBUTE MY
PREVIOUS COMMENT TO THE CENTER
FOR RESPONSIBLE LENDING AND
LASTLY WHILE WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF AYE COMPILERS
BEING INCLUDED IN THE GOLDEN
GATE DANIEL F. AS UNDOCUMENTED
WORKERS HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE PANDEMIC. WE STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
EXTEND EMERGENCY CASH PAYMENTS
TO UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WITHOUT
PATIENTS. WHO ARE ESTIMATED TO
CONSTITUTE ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION OF THE TWO MILLION
UNDOCUMENTED PERSONS IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO. MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND NEXT
ONE WILL BE LINE FIFTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARKET
BORRERO REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE GOLDEN
STATE STIMULUS AND THE SMALL
GRANTS TO CULTURAL INSTITUTION
GRANT. YEAH WELL BUSINESS AND
CULTURAL INSTITUTION GRANT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS EFFORT TO
BOOST START BUSINESSES AND
SUPPORT OUR RESIDENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AND
UNLIKE NINE WILL BE LINE EIGHTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE JORDAN AND THE WITH THE ARK
OF CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIANS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND HEIR FAMILIES- THREE QUICK
POINTS ONE ONE TWO ALSO.
SUPPORT EXTENDING THE GRANT TO
INDIVIDUALS ON AT THAT TIME AS
THEY ARE SOME OF THE LOWER
INCOME IN THE STATE. SECOND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE COMMENTS
FROM SENATOR SKINNER ABOUT THE
SUSPENSION OF OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT ARE SERVING EXACTING
POPULATION WE'RE TRYING TO.
SUPPORT YEAR. ENDED THIRTY
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO EXPLAIN
QUICKLY AWAY THAT INDIVIDUAL
THE CALIFORNIA WERE LEFT OUT OF
FEDERAL THE MILITANTS ONE THAT
WE HAVEN'T HEARD ABOUT YET AND
YOU CREATION AND CONSTRUCTIVE I
JUST WANT YOU TO BE AWARE. IN
THE FIRST FEDERAL GRANTS NOW
WITH MAY FIRST IN LOS PAYMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY INDIVIDUALS
WHO WERE DEPENDENT LEGALLY
DEPENDENT WERE EXCLUDED. AND
ALSO INDIVIDUALS OF A CERTAIN
AGE OVER CERTAIN AGE WERE
EXCLUDED WHAT DOES THAT MEAN IT
MEANS THAT IF YOU HAVE AN OLDER
CHILD AT HOME AS A DEPENDENT AS
MANY FAMILIES OF CHILDREN WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES DO.
THEN YOU WERE NOT LGBT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITY
WOULD NOT. ELIGIBLE BECAUSE
THEY WERE QUITE DEPENDENT. IN
THE WITH ALL NOT ELIGIBLE THREE
THREE IT BECAUSE- THE CHILD
WITH OVER THE TERMINATE. TO AND
YOU CAN SEE I JUST WANT YOU BE
AWARE THAT SAME OVERSIGHT OF
THEM HAPPENING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHY MARSHALL
AND I'M A MEMBER OF ALL OF US
OR NONE I'M ALSO THE BOARD
SECRETARY FOR TRANS. RIGHTS
TRANSGENDER GENDER
NONCONFORMING AND RESPECT
JUSTICE PROJECT U. G. I. G. P.
THAT PROVIDES ADVOCACY TO. OUR
CARS RATED NON GENDER NON
CONFORMING AND TRANS FOLKS
INSIDE THE CAR SO COMPLEX I
JUST WANTED TO ECHO. B. I
REQUEST FROM ALL OF US HERE
NINE TO INCLUDE PRISONERS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S BEEN BENEFIT THIS ONE TO
ADD THAT. ON THE THIRTY FIVE
DAHLE PRISONS. IN CALIFORNIA
BETTER OPERATING TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN OUR FOCUS HAS VERY
LIMITED ABILITY TO DISTANCE
FROM ONE ANOTHER AND CREATE
ANY- OF THE- DESCRIBE.
BEHAVIORS THAT WOULD CAUSE THEM
TO BE SAFE FROM THE VIRUS MORE
THAN FOUR THOUSAND OF THE
STATE'S NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
CARDS THREE PEOPLE HAVE ACTIVE
INFECTION CURRENTLY- THAT
INCLUDES ONE OUT OF. EVERY
THREE AND CALIFORNIA MEN'S
CLUB- COLONY LOCATED ON THE
CENTRAL COAST AND ON ONE OUT OF
EVERY TEN IN THE STATE'S
LARGEST WOMEN'S FACILITY HAVE
THE VIRUS. SO IN MY CAN'T
REALLY WEAR THEIR MASKS ON A
SHOWER ALSO JUST THEY WANT TO
SORT OF PUT THIS PRESENT IN
YOUR MIND THE KIND OF
CONDITIONS THAT PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM ACCESSING SAFETY-
OFTENTIMES THE MEN ARE REQUIRED
TO SHOWER EIGHT OF ITS PRIME
WITH TWO FEET IN BETWEEN THEM.
AND THE REALITY OF A HUNDRED
MEN EATING MEALS- ON THERE AND
BEING ON THEIR BEDS FOR THE
JETS NO CHALLENGES FOR
CONTAINING AN AIRBORNE VIRUS-
THERE'S SPECIFIC INMATE AIDAN
O'BRIEN O'BRIEN IN THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTION FOR MEN
THAT REPORTED. WITHIN HIS DORM
OF A HUNDRED PEOPLE THERE'S NOT
THE ABILITY TO BE SIX FEET
APART THAT FOR EVERY FOR BANKS
THERE'S AN EMPTY BANK BUT IN
BETWEEN THOSE FOUR OCCUPIED
BANKS IS ONLY. THREE FEET OF
LIVING SPACE- SO AND I JUST
WANTED TO ADDRESS. YOU KNOW
WHEN WE THINK- LIVE SAID
GOVERNMENT ATTEMPTS TO EXCLUDE
IN CARS- CARTER POPULATION FROM
STIMULUS HECKS THERE WAS THAT.
SUIT WHERE THE- U. S. DISTRICT
JUDGE PHYLLIS HAMILTON RULED
THAT THAT DECISION TO EXCLUDE
THEM WAS ARBITRARY AND
CAPRICIOUS BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOTHING IN THE LAW. THAT
IDENTIFIED THE STATE'S RIGHT TO
EXCLUDE AND MADE SOME SUCH
BENEFITS. I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR MY TIME- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO
EVERYBODY THAT SENSE IT'S HARD
WORK TO BRING THIS PACKAGE
TOGETHER. IT'S SOMETHING WE
TRULY NEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT
BASEBALL HAT. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR SENATOR
SKINNER AND SENATOR NELSON THIS
PRESS THAN YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE ARE HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE SMALL BUSINESS
pPROPOSAL. AS YOU KNOW SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE STRUGGLED
TREMENDOUSLY THROUGHOUT THIS
PANDEMIC THE TO A MULTITUDE OF
REASONS INCLUDING. YOUR
LOCKDOWN ORDERS CUSTOMER
CAPACITY LIMITATIONS EXPENSIVE
REGULATORY BURDENS IN TAX AND
FEE OBLIGATIONS- THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT DO REMAIN AT
THIS POINT IN TIME LACK OF
FINANCIAL CAPACITY TO CONTINUE
ON MUCH LONGER HOWEVER THIS
SMALL BUSINESS RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM AND THE MUCH NEEDED
SUPPLEMENT FEDERAL AID PACKAGE.
AND CERTAINLY OFFERS A LIFELINE
TO BUSINESSES THAT HAVE
EXHAUSTED FEDERAL FUNDS
PREVIOUS DAY FUND IN FACT WE
COULD SEE HOW NECESSARY THE
GRANT PROGRAM IS CONSIDERING
OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
BUSINESS REPLY FOR THE LAST
GRANT PROGRAM- WELL THE GRANT
PROGRAM DOES OFFER MUCH NEEDED
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES THAT REQUIRE
CLARITY PRIMARILY- BUSINESSES
NEED GUIDANCE ON WHETHER THE
GRANTS WHAT TAX IMPLICATIONS.
WILL BE FORGIVABLE LIKE A PPP-
LOAN AND THE FEDERAL PROGRAM
THAT WOULD BE IDEAL TO KNOW
BEFORE THEY TAKE THESE GRANTS
OUT AND APPLY FOR THEM-
ADDITIONALLY THE APPLICATION
AND QUALIFICATION PROCESS CAN
BE SIMPLIFIED IT SHOULD BE
OFFERED TO A BROADER
DEMOGRAPHIC AS BUSINESSES SO
WITH THAT. I THINK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME CONSIDERATIONS THAT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BYE FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR- MY
NAME IS JACKIE ONE WITH AND CAL
PARTYING CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN
pROBUST DISCUSSION TODAY-
ALTHOUGH WE ARE PLEASED TO THE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S COUPLE TO
DATE IN THIS REPORT. WE
ACTUALLY AGREED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET CENTERS THAT-
CENTERS- COMMENT THAT WE SHOULD
GO BACK AND WE WANT TO ENSURE
THAT- UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES ARE
ACTUALLY PROVIDED ANY- NO
ROBOTS AN ACT LITTLE PAYMENT UP
TO EIGHTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS AS
WELL AS AN NINETEENTH INCLUDE
OTHER POPULATIONS WHO ARE LEFT
OUT SUCH AS THE POPULAR
RECEIVING SSI AT THE BEACH
THANK YOU AGAIN. SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND SPEAKERS MY
NAME IS MATTHEW CANTEEN WITH
UNITED WAYS OF CALIFORNIA AS A
MEMBER OF THE COUNTY ITC
ADVOCACY COALITION
REPRESENTING- ORGANIZATIONS
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT
OF THE GOLDEN STATE. AND WE
STRONGLY URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
EXPAND THE STIMULUS FOR MORE
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION TO
CALIFORNIANS FOR LOW INCOME AND
PROVIDE SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER
SIMILAR A MIXED FAMILY AND
INDIVIDUAL WHO FILE THEIR TAXES
WITH INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS I DIDN'T
BOTHER TO CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE
DENIED THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN
FEDERAL THING WITH. THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND AS A RESULT
ARE FACING THE GREATEST NEED
FOR STATE AID AS CURRENTLY
PROPOSED GOLDEN STATE
SIGNALLERS WOULD BENEFIT TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY ROUGHLY TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND AYE
COMPILERS AND THEIR CHILDREN AT
THE INCOME THRESHOLD OF. THIRTY
THOUSAND BUT EXPANDED TO FIFTY
THOUSAND THIS COULD IMPACT OVER
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND ACTION
FATHERS AND THEIR CHILDREN
LASTLY DOUBLING THE PROPOSED
SIX HUNDRED DOLLAR PAYMENT TO
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
DOLLARS AND PROVIDING IT PER
PARENT AND CHILD EACH FAMILY
FILES WITHIN I CAN WOULD
REPLACE THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE FEDERAL ECONOMIC IMPACT
PAYMENT THE FAMILIES WERE
EXCLUDED FROM. IT WOULD BE FAR
MORE EQUITABLE EQUITABLE
APPROACH TO PROVIDE EXPECTED
OKAY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK I'M SORRY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KELLY WALTERS AND
THE STAFF ATTORNEY WITH THE
LEGAL SERVICES FOR PRISONERS
WITH CHILDREN. THE GOLDEN STATE
SENATE WITH THE DESIGN TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY SUPPORT TO
LOW INCOME CALIFORNIANS DURING
THE PANDEMIC. HOWEVER THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE OUTLINED WHO
IS DETERMINED TO BE A QUALIFIED
RECIPIENT DOES NOT AS OPPOSED
TO QUALIFIED RECIPIENTS SHALL
NOT BE INCARCERATED. SERVICE
FOR FREE AGAINST OBJECTS TO THE
EXCLUSION OF THE CAR STRAIGHT A
PERSON QUALIFIED RECIPIENTS
UNDERSTAND LET'S CHECK. IT WILL
HAVEA DESPAIR INTACT AND
PEOPLE OF COLOR. THE EXCLUSION
OF A CAR SET A PERSON FROM
AMERICANS THE PARK SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AFFECT THE LIVES AND
WELLBEING OF BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE AND THE POOR. HARDEST BY
THE PANDA. BLACK AND HISPANIC
AMERICANS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY REPRESENTED
IN REPRESENTED. IN STATE AND
FEDERAL PRISONS. FOR THEIR BEEN
DETERMINED THAT THE WEALTH GAP
AMONG AMERICANS AS THE PRIMARY
FACTOR IN A DISPROPORTIONATE
INCARCERATION RATES.
ADDITIONALLY WOMEN BEAR THE
BRUNT OF THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH INCARCERATION. INCLUDING
COURT COSTS ARE THE PHONE
CALLS. COMMENTARY COSTS AND
OTHERS. HEARD RECORD EARLIER
FINE AND EVEN WITH THOUSAND SIX
AND SEVEN DOLLARS. ALMOST ONE
YEARS ENTIRE ANNUAL INCOME FOR
RESPONDING TO EARN LESS THAN
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR. FURTHERMORE THE STIMULUS
IS DESIGNED TO LESSEN THE
ECONOMIC BURDEN OF DOES
IMPACTED BY THE PANDA. YES IT
IS TO BE USED PROPOSED UNDER
QUALIFIED INDIVIDUALS ARE
SUFFERING THE MOST FROM THE
PANDEMIC ENCOURAGED HER TO
PEOPLE MOSTLY BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE CAGED UNSAFE CONDITIONS.
FACED EXPLOSIVE REYES A VIRAL
INFECTION. DESPITE MANY
CALORIES CONTINUES HERE
CONSTANTLY INCARCERATE. PEOPLE
AT THE SAME RATE. MATTERS BY
THE ALAMO THE RELEASE PACKAGE
HAS HAD NO ECONOMIC IMPACT.
THANK THE INCLUDE OF FIRST
MEASURES THE FUNDS AND NON
ISSUE IN RELATION THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT. BECAUSE RESERVE FUND
RECEIVED ARE GARNISHED UP 255%
FOR RESTITUTION AND THREE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY DOLLARS OF
THE SIX HUNDRED THAT STATE
PRISONERS ARE SEEN WITH
AUTOMATICALLY. GOING TO THE
VICTIMS RIGHT GENERAL. HOWEVER
I. FOR THE IT WOULD ENABLE
PRISONERS TO BE FROM SUFFICIENT
RESPECTFUL TO ONE YEAR THERE BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL RELIEF
THAT FAMILIES. WOULD NORMALLY
SUPPORT THEM BY ENABLING
PRINTERS TO PROVIDE FOR
THEMSELVES. RIGHT BESIDE THE
FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE OUTSIDE
IF YOU RECORD NUMBER OF LAYOFFS
UNEMPLOYMENT AND INCREASED
HEALTH COSTS. IT'S ECONOMIC
RELIEF FROM HER SORT OF PEOPLE
IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU. TO INCLUDE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE OF AND THE-
QUALIFIED RECIPIENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
PLEASE THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR SENATOR
SKINNER AND SENATOR NIELSEN
THIS IS A LIFE THE WALL I'M I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
MUSEUMS. WE ARE VERY HEARTENED
BY THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
RELIEF FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CULTURAL INSTITUTIONS
ESPECIALLY AT THE STATE RETURNS
TO THE PURPLE TEAR WHICH
CONTINUES TO PROHIBIT PROHIBIT
INDOOR MUSEUM FROM OPENING IN
ANY CAPACITY UNDER ANY
CIRCUMSTANCES. CALIFORNIA
TWELVE HUNDRED PLUS MUSEUMS ARE
GOING ON A YEAR OF NEAR TOTAL
SHUTDOWN LOSING AN ESTIMATED
TWENTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS A
DAY THANK LAST MARCH WE ARE
PLEASED TO MEET WITH YOUR STAFF
AND HALF THE MINUTE COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE PROPOSING A
DOUBLING UP THE PORT FROM
TWENTY FIVE MILLION TO FIFTY
MILLION. CRITERIA THAT
PRIORITIZES NONPROFIT CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO ACCESS OTHER RELIEF
PROGRAM AND ALLOWING CULTURAL
INSTITUTIONS. OF ALL SIZES TO A
BY. WE FORWARD TO WORK CLOSELY
WITH YOU THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION TO CRAFT A
THOUGHTFUL PROGRAM THAT
OPTIMIZES FOR FAIRNESS EASE OF
APPLICATION AND PROGRAM
ADMINISTRATION AND MEANINGFUL
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RYAN SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ICE TO THE
LAROSA AND I'M A POLICY
ATTORNEY AT THE END PLAYED
CENTER FOR COMMUNITY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. INCYTE JOINED WITH
PRIOR COMMENTS AND THE ACLU ALL
OF US OR NONE AND OTHERS IN
OPPOSING THE EXCLUSION OF
INCARCERATED PEOPLE FROM THE
GOLDEN STATE KILLER
RESPECTFULLY REQUESTING THAT
THIS EXEMPTION BE REMOVED. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE ALREADY
LIMITS RECIPIENTS OF THE
STIMULUS TO PEOPLE WHO RECEIVED
THE CAL EARNED INCOME TAX
CREDIT BUT THE LANGUAGE GOES
EVEN FURTHER. IN CARVING OUT
INCARCERATED. DOING SO HURTS%
NOT ONLY THESE INDIVIDUALS THAT
COUNTLESS COMMUNITIES AND
FAMILIES ALREADY GRABBING TO
PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE AND KEEP
THEIR LIGHTS ON. EXAGGERATION
COST A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE IN THEIR LOVED ONES
ACCORDING TO THE ELLA BAKER
CENTER WOMEN AND
DISPROPORTIONATELY WOMEN OF
COLOR BEAR THE BRUNT OF THESE
COSTS. INCLUDING COURT COSTS
COMMISSARY AND SO MUCH MORE.
ENDEMIC IS FAR FROM OVER AND AT
THIS CRITICAL JUNCTURE
CALIFORNIA CAN AND MUST DO
BETTER FOR ALL OF THE
PRESIDENT. WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT INCARCERATED
PEOPLE BE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
THE GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT TODAY. THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU I NINETY
ONE THREE FOUR AT. GOOD
AFTERNOON- PERSONAL TO DOS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA ARE
ADVOCATES WE WANT TO FIRST
THANK YOU SENATOR COMING AT ALL
AND THERE NIELSEN SENATOR
SKINNER YOUR PASSPORT FOR THE
ARTS SECTOR WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR
ADDITIONAL DIRECT SUPPORT FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND CULTURE
INSTITUTIONS. WITH THE JUST THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER SIX FOUND THE POT TO
FIFTY MILLION WITH THE DRAFT
BILL LEFT THE MAX REVENUE FROM
TWO POINT FIVE MILLION ALL
BUDGET FIVE BUDGET
ORGANIZATIONS IN THE ARTS
BECAUSE THE THING CARE ACT OF
THE PROGRAM. AS THE IMPACT IS
WIDESPREAD WE LOOK FORWARD TO
DISCUSSING IT FURTHER THANK YOU.
SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MADAM
CHAIR AND SENATORS I'M
SOMETHING PRASAD THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS AND
CALIFORNIANS FOR AT THAT SITE
WHICH REPRESENTS OVER TWO
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE WE SUPPORT THE
PROPOSAL FOR THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS ESPECIALLY THE
INCLUSION OF AYE TO FILERS FOR
THE STIMULUS. HOWEVER IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE ALSO
PRIORITIZED THE INCLUSION OF
OUR STATE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY MANY OF WHOM ARE OUR
SOCIAL WORKERS HELPING TO KEEP
US SAFE AND BAD I HAVE BEEN
BEARING THE BRUNT OF THE HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC CRISIS. AND WHO
HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL
RELIEF IT IS UNCONSCIONABLE
THAT MANY ARE HARVESTING THE
FOOD WE EAT AND YET DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH FOOD FOR THEMSELVES. AND
JUST TO REMIND EVERYONE HOW
PRECIOUS ONLY TARGETED TO ALL
PEOPLE UNDER 2100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LIMIT. SO WE
ALSO SUPPORT THE L. ELLIE IS
RECOMMENDATION TO INCLUDE I
THINK BY RECIPIENTS AND THE
GOLDEN STATE STIMULUS AT THE
FIRE SUBPOENAS ARE MOSTLY BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE AND WOMEN AND
ALSO THE HIGHEST RISK CATEGORY
FOR GETTING AND DYING FROM
POSTED. WE ARE HEARING FROM
PEOPLE STRUGGLING TO LIVE ON
THE ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS BUT THEY
HAVE INCREASED COSTS DUE TO
SHELTERING IN PLACE TO REMAIN
EIGHT DELIVERY COSTS FOR
GROCERIES AND OTHER NECESSITIES
TRANSPORTATION COSTS PP
ANNEXURE DISINFECTED BY ARE ALL
VERY COSTLY SERVICES AND ITEMS
FOR THIS PREPARED BY THE BILL
OF THE CAP POVERTY LEVEL. BUT
THEY ARE AT INCREASED RISK OF
GETTING PERMANENTLY TO THEIR
AGE MEDICAL CONDITION ON FILE
WE MUST DO WHAT WE CAN TO
PROTECT THEM. IN ADDITION TO
MAKING CHOICES BETWEEN THE
GRANT UTILITIES AND NOT A PLAN
ON THE EXTREMELY LIMITED BUDGET
THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT. THE FACT THAT THE STATE
THEY FROM PERMITTED ALREADY
DIFFICULT PLACES THEY MIGHT TO
SURVIVE THANK. YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NECK PLEASE. THANK
YOU I. FORTY THREE THREE GO
AHEAD. HI GOODAFTERNOON MY
NAME MEMORY NOT I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR THE TOP TO BE- AT THE
CAL BECAUSE THAT HASN'T AFFECT
IN THE OF THESE- ISLAND FOR
COREY OF- INCLUDING-
INDISCRIMINATE- BENEFICIARIES
OF THAT I TEN- LIVE I BELIEVE
THEY HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED IN
SEVERAL AREAS AND HAVE BEEN.
SOME OF THE MOST AFFECTED-
PEOPLE- THEY ARE VERY HARD
WORKING AND THEY DESERVE TO BE
PART OF THE STIMULUS- I ALSO
LIKE TO MENTION THAT- THERE IS
OTHER PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED SUCH AS CHILDREN THAT-
I WORKING PART TIME JOBS. AND
CANNOT BE CLEANED- DUE TO THEIR
AGE BUT THEY ALSO CANNOT FILE
TAXES BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T MAKE
ME LAUGH THROUGH THE YEARS WHO-
ADVOCATE. SO I'M NOT ADDED SOME
OF THE POPULATION THAT HAVE
ALSO BEEN AFFECTED I'M I DON'T
HAVE A JOB I CHILD WHICH I
COULDN'T CLEAN AND COULD NOT DO
THEIR TAXES BECAUSE OF- YOU
KNOW THE AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT
THEY MADE. SO HE MAY NOT HAVE
TOTALLY BEEN EXCLUDED FROM THE-
ALSO ELDERLY PEOPLE THAT ARE IN
AS SAID BY AND HAVE BEEN
CLEANED UP BY AND DEPENDENT
HAVE BEEN DISQUALIFIED FROM
RECEIVING ANY AID AND THEY ARE
THE YOU KNOW THE MOST IN NEED-
AND ALSO NAY CAR TRADED
POPULATION- I KNOW IT HAS BEEN
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY AND- IS IT
IS IT IS- ABI IS BACK YOU KNOW
THROUGH ALL THE THINGS THAT WE
HAVE HEARD. THEY HAVE BEEN
GREATLY AFFECTED BY THE
PANDEMIC AND YOU KNOW- BE
BENEFIT FROM THE POINT OF THE
FAMILIES CAN PROVIDE AND IN THE
FAMILIES OUT HERE I HAVE BEEN
GREATLY IMPACTED THERE'S NO WAY
FOR THEM TO PROVIDE THEM YOU
KNOW WITH THE POOREST THE
MEETING- BASICALLY GENERALLY.
WHICH MAY TRULY DO ARNOLD AND
THERE SO I ENCOURAGE. YOU TO
ALSO INCLUDED- THAT HAD. LAW
THEIR TIME. IN MUCH OVER. AND
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TIME.
THANK YOU I'M MODERATOR IN YOU
COULD ASK IF THERE'S A OUT THAT
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A- PUBLIC
STATEMENT I LIKE TO IF YOU WERE.
TAKE YOUR COMMENTS TO ABOUT
THIRTY SECONDS- THEY'RE GETTING
LONGER AND LONGER AND I'M
THEY'RE REALLY PASSIONATE AND I
APPRECIATE THAT BUT- WE'VE GONE
PAST THE TIME ALLOTTED FOR THE
COMMITTEE AND I DON'T WANT TO
CUT ANYBODY OFF SO IF YOU COULD
IT- AND PLEASE KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS AS BRIEFLY AS POSSIBLE
AND IF YOU WANT TO SAY THAT YOU
ALIGN YOURSELF WITH SOMEONE
ELSE'S WHO'S- I'M I'M KEEPING
NOTES WE'VE GOT A- A FULL
RECORD OF ALL OF THIS- JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE EVERYBODY GETS
A CHANCE. TO SPEAK THAT WANTS
TO THAT NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU I'M SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ALEX THE END OF BEING ON BEHALF
OF CENTRIC WITH THE LINE UNITED
FOR SINGLE ECONOMY OFTEN ACROSS
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT-
PROVIDING A FAMILY MEMBER
COMMUNITY WORKERS- INTERSTATE
WEAPON SHUT OUT- UNDER THE FROM
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SPECIFICALLY- INCREASE THE
GOLDEN STATE SENATE PAYMENT I
COMPILERS TO EIGHTEEN HUNDRED-
AND BEING REALLY- UNDERSERVED
AND UNRECOGNIZED- COMMUNITY IN
WINTER WHERE YOU WORK THERE'S A
LOT OF THE DOCUMENT. THAT ARE
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET
ARE WORRIED ABOUT ADDICTIONS
ARE SCRAPING BY WHAT THEY CAN'T
BE PART OF THEIR RENT AND ALSO
CHOOSING WHICH DOES NOT
DISSIPATE BY CHRISTIANS. BUT
THEY CAN. I'M YEAH WE AGREE
WITH- SEVEN ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AND THINKING. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I KNOW
SO PLEASED AHEAD. I MEAN IT'S
NOT YOUR FAULT YOU KNOW WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA A GRANDPA SAID.
AND I JUST MONEY YOU ASK A LOT
OF THIS YOU KNOW AT THE MADE IN
TO. AND INCREASING FUND FOR
FILERS MAKING IT EASIER FOR TO
GET I CAN AND TO BENEFIT THAT
AND ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE
INCLUDE EVERY WHO IS CURRENTLY
EXCLUDED IF YOU WERE TO TALK
ABOUT HOW TO MUCH RESPONSE AND-
YOU RESOURCES INCLUDING TO
FOCUS ON. OUT OF RELEASED.
FEDERAL CANNOT. I THINK YOU
SHOULD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT PLEASE. THANK YOU BYE
NINETY SEVEN GO AHEAD. THIS IS
A GONZALEZ THE NASH AT THE OF
WORKER HELP AND ANIMAL WITH THE
CAL FOR BY I WANT YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION THAT YOU HAVE TO BE
ON THE STATE LET ME LET
ACTUALLY MANY SPEAKER REQUEST
WITHOUT ASK FOR THE LEE AND
THEN I CAN. BUT ALSO REALLY CAN
MAKE A FOR THOSE- AT THAT I
WOULD BE AND- IN GOLDEN STATE
KAMALA- EITHER AT. MAINLY
PEOPLE AS I IN AND HE OF HOW
AND- IT SEEMS I REPRESENT OVER
PER OF THOSE WITH COPD RELATED
THAT THEN INCREASE OF BEEN PART
ABOUT- DURING THAT TIME SO THAT
WANT TO MAKE A PLEA FOR THEM TO
BE INCLUDED THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO DO YOU
THE LINE NINETY EIGHT. YEAH
CLEVELAND YOU'RE ON A HOT HI MY
NAME IS OVERLY AND I WANTED
SOMETHING DIFFERENT ON
CALIFORNIA I THINK I REMEMBER
THAT HOW IT COULD BE COALITION
A TRUNCATED COMMITTEE COULD
BENEFIT THE MOST FROM A
CALIFORNIA WELL IT HAS BEEN
LIKE THE MID VALLEY LIKE IT'S
BEEN WORKING WITH THE FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS. WHO FILE WITH
THAT FILE I IN ADDITION WHERE
I'VE BEEN FOR THE FACT THAT HE
WAS FIGHTING VIOLATE THE CLAIM
TO BE LEFT OUTSIDE NORMAL
COUNTRY BECAUSE I FOR THAT
BETWEEN THE TIME BEING-
DEVELOPING A PRACTICAL
DEPICTING LEFT ABOUT REALLY
GREAT THANK YOU TRUMP. AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE ECONOMIC
SUPPORT THERE ARE AND HI BUT A
COALITION BOB YOU I THINK
INCLUDES AN X. A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE BILL FOR THE INCLUDES
ALL COMPILED ARE COMING UP OUT
INCLUDE PEOPLE ARE YOU INCOME
ELIGIBLE FOR THE EIGHT TWENTY
ONE AND BUDGET WE OFTEN PER DAY.
AND HOW I CAN- HELPFUL- TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MAMMON
THAT IF I COULD NOT A HOLIDAY
SOME NEEDLES. HE IS STILL
EMPLOYED- IS- UTILITY SPACE
YEAH THEY- PUT A LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE- MOST OF THE OTHER
LISTEN TO COMMON DOUBLES- WHAT
IF. WE PUT A TICKET ON THE
SAMOSA. STYLE HELLO IS- INTO
SALAS THE- IS ALREADY BANNED
THE SYSTEM AND WHERE IS
SOMETHING OF HOW. OF THE DOOR
SUSPECT LOOKING DIRECTLY AT THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMIC CRITICAL
MOST ADDICTS AT. A WHOLE LITTLE
THE COMPACT BAKKIE ADELANTE.
THE REPORT OF THE PUBLIC WHAT
IT ENOUGH WELL YEAH AND IF
THEY- THINK IT'S THE MIDDLE OF
THE GOLDEN GATE STIMULUS.
PAYMENT THERE MIDDLE TOWARDS
HIM CLOSE BY THAT GET. PUT INTO
THE- WAS THE PLACE TO GET A
MONTH AND THEN ALSO SOME MEDIA
PROBABLY ONLY SMALL LETTER.
WHICH IS IN THE CLASS YES. NEXT
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M MORE TO
GO AHEAD. IF YOU'RE GONNA MY
NAME IS KIM ROOMS WHEN CAL. WE
ARE ONE TO CALL AND LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE INCLUSION OF F. REAP THE-
IN THE GOLDEN STATE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU MUCH. THANK YOU RYAN ONE OF
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR SPEAKERS
MY NAME IS BETTY GONZALEZ I'M
WITH THE WAREHOUSE WORKERS
RESOURCE CENTER OUR MOST
IMPORTANT PORTLET GS AT THE
STATE MOLEST YOU CAN'T DENY THE
IMPACT THAT CLOVER NINETEEN
THAT HAD ON IMMIGRATION ALL THE
POIGNANT. WE HAVE DIED AT THE
THREE TIMES THE RATE OF NATIVE
BORN CALIFORNIANS IN MANY CASES
IS THE FAMILY BREAK BREAD
WINNER WHO HAS BECOME ILL OR
DIE. LEAVING THE FAMILY IN
SERIOUS JEOPARDY OF HUNGER AND
HOMELESSNESS ARCHIMEDES CAN'T
WAIT ANY LONGER ON DOCUMENT IF
CALIFORNIANS NEED EQUITABLE
RELIEF NOW. STARTING WITH
INCREASE DECEMBER'S PAYMENTS TO
I CAN'T FOLLOWERS. 218-002-1800
DOLLARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU I DON'T
WANT FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ONE I. MEAN I'M A SITCOM YEAH.
HELLO NUMBER TO ONE FIFTEEN
NINETY THE SAN FRANCISCO THANK
YOU IN THE THOUGHT. THAT I
DON'T KNOW BUT GIVEN THAT I
MEAN I CAN SEE THAT THE. AND
YEAH. THE LADY OTHER GROUP HAVE
NOTHING. HOMEOWNER'S LOCAL FROM
QUOTA BACK WITH THE CITY COMING
THINK THE FINAL SHOULD NOT DO
THAT- MY BATTERY ARE GOING TO
BE A LITTLE BIT. STATE AND
LOCAL GET SAY I. I MEAN LOOK AT
THE END OF NIGHT. CONTAINS
COMMENT BETTER. HOLDEN BETTER
LET YOU GET ID I THANK OF MONEY
THAT. IF I BELIEVED YOU KNOW TO
CALL NOTHING. GET ENOUGH OF THE
SCENE THE WITHOUT. SOME OF MY
TROUBLE. AND THEN. GET CAN HELP
WITH BECAUSE HE LATEST
ECONOMICAL. ASSEMBLY MOBILE
SITE OF THE- THEY WILL A LOT
FOR COMPANIES- JUST IF YOU.
EVEN YES. THANK YOU VERY ONE
CAN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
ONE ZERO GO. I'M HARD DEADLINE
WHY HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN PLEASED
AHEAD. THE NUMBER IS THE NUMBER
IS. LOOK ON THE PROPERTY IF YOU
SPLIT SOME THE LATTER ANY.
LEVEL BUT BUT THE WORK UNITED
THE TRUMP GO. TAMBIéN IS
GIVING. BECAUSE HE TO MAINTAIN
A- LOOK AT THE PEOPLE OF COLOR
THIS IS A MENTOR. YOUR GAME
HILLS THOUGH THEY THEY HAVE TO
USE ECONOMIC PRODUCT WILL BE A
MORE ALMOST. IF PEOPLE HE- DALE
UNEMPLOYMENT INTO SAYS A STATE
OKAY. ALSO DOES GOING TO I WILL
AROUND ME I GOT MORE IMPORTANT
POLITICAL TO COURT CORNER THE
MIDDLE I. IT DOES THE- TO PUT
INTO SORT OF LOCKER- YOU WILL
MORE THAN GAME I MEAN INTO
CONNECTING. THE A LISTEN TO
SOME CUT A SENATOR BECAUSE I DO
BUT WHEN YOU'RE A KID TO THE-
AND YOU THAT YOU CAN MARK. TO A
LECTURE. CAL. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI
MY NAME IS MERRIAM- THEY ARE
LOCAL AND ABOUT HOW THIS
NEEDLES WORKERS UNITED- INFO AT
THE END OKAY BUT IN THE
NINETIES MCCARTY THAT AT YOUR
CAR HOW DOES HE KNOW HOW MANY
BATTLES CAN PEOPLE LEADERS THAT
I YOU KNOW THEY- WILL GET
NOTHING THAT I'M- ON COURT YOU
KNOW AND IF YOU GO ON. ME WHEN
I SEE MORE LEARN ABOUT THAT'LL-
IT'S EASY TO COME IN THIS STORY
BMO CAPITAL MAINTAINED A
LISTING WILL I NEED TO GET A
MEAL BUT IT IS ON A SECOND
BOOK. IN THE COMMENTS I DID
pLOOKING ON IN AND GET BACK ON
INTENDED MACKINNON BUT I'M FROM
FAT I LOVE NOTHING DEFINITELY
ADVISED BECAUSE- CHECK IT OUT
YEAH- I. BET OKAY BY YOU
AMERICA THAT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOT PLEASE. THANK YOU I
DON'T WANT ALL FOUR PLEASE CALL.
THE MANAGER MY NAME IS DAVID
NUMBER THE FRANCISCO MARIN BANK
AND WELL A MEMBER OF THE SAN OF
THE TOP INTERESTED BY COACH.
SUPPORT OF THE GOLDEN GATE
JUNIOR EMIGRATE FOR THE OF
DON'T FIND OR ANY CRIME. AND WE
YOU JOIN OUR FELLOW AT MUCH
URGING TO INCLUDE BOTH ACCESS
IRIS AND I DIDN'T IN THE
FAMILIAR I'M BACK IN THE TEN OF
THOUSANDS OF AT THE BY TO BE A
AND I THINK AND SERVICE AREA
THE CONTINUING ON FOOD. OFFERED
BY THE LIKE ARE TO BE THERE FOR
NEEDS RESPECTFULLY- URGE YOU TO
THE- ON THE CAR FOR WHO NEED AT
THE VERY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME YOU CAN. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU I WANT. THREE
PLEASE CALL AHEAD. RIGHT ONE
TWO THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. YOU'RE ON YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ANTHONY AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE UC MERCED UNION
LABOR CENTER WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE BUDGET AS THE VOTE
REVIEWS SUBCOMMITTEE FOR ALONG
THE SIXTY ON A SHIP COULDN'T
NINETEEN IN A GROUP THAT WOULD.
ACTUALLY ARE TALKING IMMIGRANTS.
OUR THAT THE- DEPARTMENT PUBLIC.
DEATH RECORDS INDICATE THAT THE
PRIOR BUT THE- HAS LED SO FAR
HIGHER. IN EMIGRATE DEATH AND
DEATH NINE THE NATIVE BORN.
FROM MARCH AUGUST OF TWENTY
TWENTY. TEN THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX MARGARET
DIED IN DURING THE SAME TIME.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. THIS
INCREASE TWENTY NINE POINT
THREE PERCENT. WITH THREE TIMES
HIGHER THAN THE NINE POINT 9%
INCREASE IN DEATH. FOR NATIVE
BORN CALIFORNIANS. BUT NINETEEN
WILL ITS YOU CALL SENSE OF IT
NOW PUBLIC UTILITY. SOLUTION
SUCH AS FINANCIALLY AND
POLITICALLY. LAST YEAR STATE
LAWMAKERS THAT THE STATE FOR TO
PROVIDE RELIEF DOCTOR GRANT
HOWEVER THE STATE HAS A- GREAT
BUDGET SURPLUS IS LAW YEAR.
MANY INDUSTRIES WHICH THIS
QUESTION I REALIZED WE DOCUMENT
WORKERS THE POETRY. PRODUCER AN
ONLINE. HAVE PROMPTED PRECISELY
BECAUSE WE ARE THE PANDEMIC
BECAUSE IMMIGRANTS MAKE THEIR
INDUSTRY PROFITABLE BECAUSE THE
STATE HAS LED TO TAXES ON. THE
JAPANESE. AGAIN YOU HAVE NEED.
TO SUPPORT BECAUSE RATE AND OUR
STATE. THE QUESTION IS YOU
WILLING TO MAKE SACRIFICES WHAT.
THANK YOU MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE. THANK YOU I IN
ONE ONE ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
DON'T UNDERSTAND I HAD. ONE ONE
ZERO THREE TO FOURTEEN DONE HOW
YOU'RE ON GOING TO SEE SERIOUS
I TO SAY NO TO PROMOTE MUCH OF.
ALL FIVE THERE BUT NOTHING
ENOUGH BUT WHEN THAT IF I EACH.
DAY FOR LETTING US MEDINA BODY-
BUT YEAH MINDS- THAT EITHER ONE
BED FLORIDA OR STAY DECIDED BY
THEN ANOTHER BECAUSE CAL BACK
IN MINNESOTA. YEAH I'M I'M BUT
I BEEN HERE FOR WATER. K.
SEVENTEEN THEN UP FOR YOU ADULT
ABOUT HOW ORDER LOCAL BANDS
BATTLE GRANT ALL THEIR- YOU
KNOW THAT I ABOUT THE THEY'VE
DONE IT BECOMING. MAKE NEEDLE
ARE LOOKING AT MAKING FOOD
COMING BAD INTO FIVE THEY LET
THE DAY LOOK AT THE MORAL DAILY
CALLS AT THIS. FOR THEIR CALL
OUR RECORD HANDLE THANK WITH.
THANK GOD NO MAN I DO THAT
FINANCIERA NOTABLY NUMBER WHAT
BOOK AND WILL NOT BETTER. IT
ALSO YOU GROUP AND I SAID IT'D
BEEN THEY DON'T THEY DO NOT A
CO COMMITTED AND HELLO JOHN I
MORE TRUCKS ONE WITH THE
FEDERAL ORDERED BUT MAKE COFFEE
THE READ ON FUNDING NOT-
CORTADO ALL. YEAH THEM FROM
BOOK BOX WITH THE ABOUT OKAY
BUT I DIDN'T THINK HE SAID
HAPPENING THE ARE NOT. YOU NEED
ECONOMY THAT POLITICAL
DEMOCRATIC. THAT YOU CAN MORE
THAN. COUNTY HELLO MY LIMIT AB
LET. OPEN UP AND THEY'RE NOT
FOR THE EVENT MAY BE. GLASSES
DAISY LOWE CENTREBOARD LAUGH I
YOU SEE ME INTO THIS IS BOTH OF
GRASSROOTS PURSUE THIS. YOU
MONEY OR YOU. NEXT PLEASE.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD- WHAT ARE THE
NORMAL AS CORPORATE LONG COURT
RULED THAT THE AWFULNESS- MEALS
THAT NONPROFIT CALIFORNIA
UNIVERSAL SAYING IS WELCOMING
THEM I MEAN NOT GOING TO LOVE.
ON ON THE COURT WELL AS A LONER
IN OAKLAND DOES NOT FEEL REAL
THAT I USE. THAT ARE A FEW
COMMENCEMENT WILL GET USE THAN
GONNA GRANT THAT IT'S BEEN
GOING IN ALL C. NINE I THINK
WHAT'S ON THE THAT I BUY THAT
OF WHICH A SCHOOL THE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES ENOUGH I THANK
ONE BODY AND OR WHAT FOR THE
LORD. JONAS THERE LET LET
LOOKING INTO STILL GET LE YOU
LOVE BUT OF THE THAT MAKE IT A
ENOUGH I DON'T LITTLE MORE NINE
MONTH BY OUR OWN HOLD UP NOT
DOWN. HERE STILL A LOT OF
WITHOUT FEELING ON THE PHONE
THE SHOWER. EAGLE IN NEW YORK
THEY'RE GONNA SEND YOUR. WE CAN
HEAR YOU YES FILE TYPE BY HI
MANY METABOLISM EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE AND THE
COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
WE'RE LOOKING RIGHT COALITION
THEY KNOW THE NUMBERS THAT
COUNTY I CALLING- YOU KNOW IT
AT THAT- I BET THE- BETTER
THANK. FUNDING OUR BUT THE
GOLDEN GATE I PHILIP AT THE WE
HAVE BEEN- COLBERT HOW BEEN
PICKED UP LIKE THE THEY LOOK
GREAT THROUGHOUT HELLO. AND WE
BEEN DELAY EMPIRE I WHERE I'M
TALKING I'M ARE LIVING PAYCHECK
PAYCHECK SOME ARE BEHIND ON
BROWN A MOVIE ARE THE CURRENT
ON ON BEING THEY'RE BUILT SOME
I'M HAVE STROKES TO FIND FOOD
AND TO PAY FOR FOOD- HAD PICKED
TO BRING FOOD TO THEIR- SO
WE'RE ASKING THAT THE- THAT
THAT IS AN INCREASE AT EIGHTEEN
HOLE DOLLARS I'M I THINK I'LL-
ACT PART OF THE PROPOSAL- I
THINK GAVE. YOU THINK SHOWS I'M
HERE I'M THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT. THANK YOU DON'T
WANT SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HE
LEARN. THIS IS A- NUMBER IS
PROBABLY ANOTHER. YOU FOR A
PHONE THE NEXT ONE OF THE- NEED
AND STUFF LIKE THIS. HE GET A
MORE WE'RE- ARE OF THE- WILL
BUY LOOK AT THE NUMBERS THANK
YOU FILES UP NAMES. WE GOT
INVOLVED BECAUSE THAT THE NAME
IF YOU HAVE BOUGHT THAT BOOK.
ONE OF THE OPEN ACCESS. MOBILE
MORE YOU DON'T PRODUCTS SALE
BUT THE FORMAL FROM. THANK YOU
CAN ALSO LOG ON QUALITY. BE.
SOME OF THE BEYOND THE PRACTICE
OF THE- POINTED AT METICULOUS
YES. THANK YOU I HAVE NO MORE
COMMON THANK YOU THIS TIME.
VERY GOOD WELL FOR LET ME THANK
ALL THE IN IN THE- THAT
PURCHASE. IN THAT PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY WHICH IS AN
AGGRESSIVE THAT TOTAL. LOSS
THIS OR A MAYES MORAL- IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY.
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE.
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE REALLY IMPORTANT TO US AND
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS. THANK YOU TO
ALL THE PARTICIPATE IN WANTED
LET YOU KNOW THAT WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION-
TODAY THANK YOU TO EVERYONE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND COOPERATION
WE HAVE CONCLUDED THE AGENDA
FOR TODAY'S HEARING. AND THE
SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE IS ADJOURNED.